>> THIS IS THE MLB GAME OF THE
WEEK LIVE ON YOUTUBE PRESENTED
BY CHIME.
LOOK WHERE WE ARE.
HOUSTON, TEXAS FOR THE ANGELS
TAKING ON THE ASTROS.
YOU WANT SUPERSTARS?
YOU HAVE SUPERSTARS ALL OVER THE
BASEBALL FIELD.
MIKE TROUT, SHOHEI OHTANI.
DUSTY BAKER'S CLUB WITH ALEX
BREGMAN AND CARLOS CORREA.
CORREA LEADING OFF FOR THE FIRST
TIME IN HIS CAREER.
OH, THERE'S ALBERT PUJOLS.
YOU NAME ITER THERE'S SUPERSTAR
INVOLVED.
WE CAN'T WAIT TO SEE THEM
BATTLE.
THEY ARE EXCLUSIVELY ON YOUTUBE
TONIGHT.
IT WILL BE LIVE WITH MATT
VASGERSIAN CALLING THE ACTION
WITH A WHOLE BUNCH OF FRIENDS
AND WE'LL GET YOU GOING FOR 30
MINUTES ALL ABOUT THE ASTROS AND
THE ANGELS, SCOTT BRAUN AND JIM
THOME.
SO GREAT TO SEE YOU.
JIM: YEAH, SO GREAT TO BE BACK.
WHAT A GAME IT'S GOING TO BE.
IT WILL BE A FUN GAME TO WATCH
BECAUSE THERE ARE SO MANY GREAT
PLAYERS AS YOU SAID ON BOTH
SIDES HERE.
IT'S ALWAYS NICE TO SEE GOOD
BASEBALL THIS EARLY IN THE YEAR.
SCOTT: I FELT WHEN I WAS WALKING
OUT WITH YOU RIGHT NOW, THERE
WOULD BE WALK-UP MUSIC.
JIM: WHENEVER THEY PLAY, THEY
COULD PLAY.
I JUST TRY TO DO THE JOB IN THE
BATTER'S BOX.
SCOTT: JIM WAS YOU KNOW WHAT,
I'M GOING TO TRY TO DO A LITTLE
BIT OF THIS.
IT ALL WORKED OUT.
LET'S SEE HOW IT WORKED OUT FOR
THESE TWO TEAMS.
>> TREVOR STORY.
1-0.
RIP IT FAIR!
JUST INSIDE THE THIRD-BASE LINE!
IT WILL ROLL DOWN ON INTO THE
TRACK.
TAPIA SCORES.
THEY'RE GOING TO SEND MCMANN, A
TWO-RUN DOUBLE FOR STORY.
>> DAZA WILL LEADOFF THE SECOND.
>> NOW, THE 2-2.
HIT WELL DOWN THE LEFT FIELD
LINE!
HOOKING TOWARDS THE CORNER!
BUT IT IS GONE!
TOUCH THEM ALL TIME!
YONATHAN DAZA!
>> HERE'S MIKE TROUT.
TWO OUTS.
NO ONE ON.
NO SCORE.
LIFT AS HIGH FLY BALL CARRYING
DEEP INTO RIGHT FIELD!
IT IS OUT OF HERE!
HOME RUN NUMBER SIX FOR MIKE
TROUT!
POWER FOR TROUT.
>> HAS HOME RUN POWER.
CAN DO DAMAGE.
>> HERE IT COMES.
DEEP CENTER FIELD!
GONE!
AND ADIEU LISS HAS PUT THE
RANGERS OUT IN FRONT.
5-3 RANGERS.
SCOTT: THE ANGELS AND ASTROS GET
GOING.
AND THE ANGELS ARE 9-7.
THEY'RE A GAME AND A HALF OUT OF
FIRST.
THE OAKLAND A'S ARE ON ANOTHER
PLANET.
THEY JUST CANNOT STOP.
MEANWHILE, THE ASTROS WERE OFF
TO A SUPER FAST START.
THEY'VE FALLEN A BIT.
7-10.
IT'S SUPER COMPETITIVE, JIM,
THEY'RE VERY CLOSE TOGETHER.
WITH THE ANGELS, THEY STILL DO
HAVE -- THERE ARE A TON OF
NAMES.
THEY DO HAVE THE BEST PLAYER I
WOULD SAY OVER -- IT'S BEEN LIKE
A DECADE NOW?
JIM: WHENEVER YOU TALK ABOUT THE
NUMBER ONE AND THE BEST PLAYER
IN BASEBALL IT'S MIKE TROUT.
I MEAN, FOR ME, HE'S CONSISTENT
EVERY YEAR.
HE PUTS UP GREAT NUMBERS.
AND IT'S HERE AT THE NETWORK.
I KNOW IT'S A JOY FOR US TO TALK
ABOUT HIM.
SO I THINK WE'RE GOING TO DIVE
IN HERE.
SO LAST YEAR, LAST YEAR
OBVIOUSLY WHAT A ROUGH YEAR IN
GENERAL FOR EVERYBODY.
AND YOU KNOW, YOU LOOK AT -- I
MEAN, HERE HE GOES -- HE GOES
DEEP TO CENTER.
HE GOES TO LEFT FIELD.
HERE ON A BREAKING BALL, HE GOES
TO LEFT CENTER.
NOW, WE'RE GOING TO GO INTO THIS
YEAR EARLY IN APRIL.
SAME THING.
THE LEG KICK.
HE'S ALWAYS IN POSITION TO GET
READY.
THERE'S A BALL OUT IN FRONT OF
THE PLATE THAT HE HITS INTO THE
SEATS IN DEEP LEFT CENTER.
NOW, HE GOES OPPO.
AND THAT TELLS ME HE STAYS ON
THE BALL.
INTERESTINGLY, SCOTT, HE'S GOT A
FLAT BAT ON HIS PRESETUP, OK?
WHEN HE GETS BACK TO THE BACK
SIDE, THE THING I LOOK FOR IS
THE ANGLE, THE NOBODY OF THE BAT
TO THE CATCHER AND WHEN THE
FRONT FOOT HITS, THAT'S WHERE
YOU GET THAT NOBODY TO THE
CATCHER AND THAT IS THE MOST
POWERFUL POSITION A HITTER CAN
BE IN AND THAT'S WHY MIKE TROUT
DOES AND IS SO CONSISTENT
BECAUSE HE'S SO TRUE WITH HIS
MECHANICS EVERY DAY.
YOU KNOW, IF THEY SAID TO ME,
HEY, GO DO A DEMO ON MIKE TROUT.
HONESTLY, LIKE YOU WOULD SEE NO
FLAW.
THERE'S NOTHING YOU COULD PICK
ON HIS SWING FROM NOW AND FIVE
YEARS AGO, THAT'S HOW CONSISTENT
HE'S BEEN.
AND IT'S JUST BEEN AN ABSOLUTE
PRESSURE AND JOY TO WATCH THIS
GUY, AND IT WILL BE FOR THE
REMAINING OF HIS CAREER.
SCOTT: WE SHOULD SHOW BREAKDOWNS
OF HIS SWINGS AND PICKING RANDOM
YEARS BECAUSE IT DOESN'T EVEN
MATTER.
IT'S ALWAYS THE SAME CONSISTENT
-- THAT'S WHAT MAKES HIM SO
GREAT.
AND HE'S TOUGH ON HIMSELF, JIM,
TOO.
HE SAID IN SPRING TRAINING, I
HAVEN'T FELT COMPLETELY ON IN A
YEAR.
HE'S CRITICIZING HIS DEFENSE
SAYING HE NEEDS TO GET BETTER
THAT'S THE TALK OF A SUPERSTAR.
JIM: THE GREAT PLAYERS ARE
ALWAYS TRYING TO GET BETTER.
AND IN THEIR MIND IF THEY LACKED
IN THEIR MIND, NOT IN BASEBALL'S
MIND BUT IN THEIR MIND, THEY
KNOW THEY LOOK IN THE MIRROR
EVERY DAY AND I'M SURE MIKE
WANTED TO GO HOME AND WORK ON
SOME THINGS AND YOU'RE SEEING
THIS YEAR, HE LOOKS MOTIVATED.
HE JUST HAD A CHILD A YEAR AGO.
SO I'M SURE THERE'S PEACE EVERY
DAY COMING HOME.
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO WATCHING
HIM, YOU KNOW, HAVE A WONDERFUL,
FABULOUS YEAR BECAUSE HE'S GOING
TO.
SCOTT: HUMBLE HUMAN.
NO EGO.
WALKS AROUND NOT LIKE HE'S THE
BEST PLAYER ON THE PLANET.
AND I MENTIONED THAT BECAUSE
MIKE TROUT IS GOING TO BE MIC'ED
UP FOR THIS GAME.
HOW ABOUT THAT?
JIM: THAT'S GREAT.
SCOTT: YOU WANT TO HEAR WHAT
MIKE TROUT SAYS, YOU GOING TO
HEAR THAT LIVE TONIGHT ON
YOUTUBE WHEN WE HAVE IT FOR YOU.
THE GAME IS ABOUT 20 MINUTES
AWAY.
WE'LL MIX IN OUR POLLS.
WE'RE BIG ON YOUTUBE ON ASKING
YOU -- LET'S KEEP IT SIMPLE TO
START.
WHO'S GOING TO WIN TODAY'S GAME?
JIM, I'LL ASK YOU LATER.
ANGELS IN
9-7.
THE ASTROS ARE 7-10.
PAY ATTENTION OF THE PITCHING
MATCHUP.
ALEX COBB WHO HAD A START
SKIPPED JUST BECAUSE THE
SCHEDULE WORKED OUT GOING UP
AGAINST CRISTIAN JAVIER, VERY
TALENTED AND WAS PART OF THE
ROOKIE OF THE RACE YEAR.
SO WE'LL GET TO ALL OF THAT.
I'M PSYCHED TO HEAR TROUT'S
WORDS DURING THE GAME AND HIS
ACTIONS.
RIGHT ON BACK WITH US ON
YOUTUBE.
WE'LL TALK TO SUPER CREATOR MATT
ANTONELLI.
JARED WALSH AND OUR PICKS TO
CLICK.
JIM'S GOING TO TELL YOU COMING
UP.
SCOTT: IF YOU DON'T KNOW HIM
ALREADY, GET TO KNOW THE NAME.
YOU'RE GOING TO SEE HIM TONIGHT.
JARED WALSH IS HITTING .327.
HE'S KNOCKED IN 13.
THE O.P.S., THAT'S REALLY GOOD.
IF YOU'RE NOT FOLLOWING O.P.S.
OVER 1,000 THAT'S PRETTY GOOD,
RIGHT?
JIM?
JIM: YES.
SCOTT: LET'S TALK TO JARED RIGHT
NOW.
HOW ARE YOU TODAY?
AND HOW IS THE SEASON GOING FOR
YOU SO FAR?
JARED: I'M DOING GREAT.
HOPE TO KEEP IT ROLLING.
JIM: JIM THOME HERE.
WHAT A GREAT RUN.
I WANT TO DIVE INTO A LITTLE BIT
ON THE HITTING END.
ARE YOU WITH YOUR CAGE WORK?
ARE YOU MORE OF A SOFT TOSS GUY
OR A TEE GUY?
AND HOW HAS THAT HELPED YOU
MAINTAIN WHAT YOU'VE BEEN DOING
SINCE LAST YEAR?
>> I'LL DABBLE IN TEE, BUT MORE
SO SOFT TOSS AND HIGH VELO IS
REALLY MY BREAD AND BUTTER.
YOU SEE TEAMS LIKE THE ASTROS
KIND OF START IT, THE DODGER,
THE HIGH FASTBALL IS AT THE TOP
OF THE ZONE, IF YOU CAN'T HIT
THAT YOU'RE GOING TO STRUGGLE.
MY WORK IS SOMETHING THAT'S
IMPORTANT TO ME.
SCOTT: CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT THE
SWING CHANGES AND TWEAKS THAT
YOU'VE MADE OVER THE PAST YEAR
OR SO SIMPLY FIGHTING --
SIMPLIFYING THINGS AND PICKING A
THING OR TWO FROM YOUR LEGENDARY
TEAMMATES?
JARED: GETTING TO WATCH THESE
GUYS ON A DAILY BASIS IS
UNBELIEVABLE, SEEING TROUT,
PUJOLS' APPROACH HAS BEEN HUGE
FOR ME.
HAVING THAT ABLE TO LAYOFF A
TOUGH 3-2 PITCH AND TAKE YOUR
WALK IS SOMETHING I'M GOING TO
CONTINUE TO WORK TOWARDS.
YEAH, IT'S BEEN -- IT'S BEEN
GREAT.
I FELT LIKE IF I CAN GET ON TOP
OF THE BALL AND HIT A FEW MORE
LINE DRIVES THAT WOULD HELP ME
AT THE BIG LEAGUE LEVEL.
SOMETHING THAT I'M REALLY HAPPY
WITH.
JIM: HAVE YOU NOTICED SINCE LAST
YEAR OR THIS YEAR ARE THE
PITCHERS DOING ANYTHING
DIFFERENT WITH YOU AS FAR AS YOU
MAKING ADJUSTMENTS TO -- TO A
YEAR AGO FROM NOW?
JARED: YEAH, I WOULD SAY A LOT
LESS FIRST PITCH FASTBALLS RIGHT
DOWN THE MIDDLE UNFORTUNATELY.
HOPEFULLY THEY GET BACK INTO
THAT SOON.
[LAUGHTER]
SCOTT: ALSO, JARED, I MEAN, WE
GO BACK TO WHEN YOU WERE
DRAFTED.
WHEN YOU SAID THIS, 29TH ROUND,
2015 OUT OF GEORGIA.
AND YOU CALLED YOURSELF, ALMOST
MR. IRRELEVANT.
WHAT WAS THAT EXPERIENCE LIKE
FOR YOU?
I MEAN, WE'RE GOING LATE IN THE
DRAFT.
AND HOW MUCH DO YOU TAKE THAT
WITH YOU EVEN INTO GAMES LIKE
TODAY BECAUSE YOU WERE
OVERLOOKED BY A LOT OF TEAMS
FRANKLY?
JARED: IT STICKS WITH ME A
LITTLE BIT.
BUT THERE'S NOTHING TO BE BITTER
ABOUT.
I GET TO PLAY WITH A LOT OF
FUTURE HALL OF FAMERS.
GET TO PLAY IN A GREAT DIVISION.
LIVE IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
NO REASON TO CRY OVER SPILLED
MILK.
JIM: WE READ YOU WERE A STEELERS
FAN.
DESCRIBE WHO MADE YOU A STEELERS
FAN AND WHO IS YOUR ALL-TIME
FAVORITE STEELER?
JARED: OH, GOODNESS.
I WOULD HAVE TO SAY HINES WARD
AND A HUGE STEELER FAN.
WE WOULD FLY TO PITTSBURGH FOR
STEELERS GAME.
MY PARENTS WERE HUGE FANS.
SCOTT: WHAT'S IT LIKE BECAUSE
MIKE TROUT THINKS THE EAGLES ARE
A PRETTY BIG DEAL?
WHAT'S IT LIKE IN THE CLUBHOUSE
WITH GUYS?
>> THE CLUBHOUSE GETS PRETTY
ROWDY.
EVERYBODY'S GOT THEIR TEAM.
YOU KNOW, IT'S A LOT OF FUN.
A LOT OF SMACK TALK GOES ON
ABOUT ALL SPORTS.
IT'S SOMETHING THAT KIND OF --
KEEPS A TOUGH SEASON ABLE TO GO
THROUGH.
ANY TIME YOU CAN HAVE FUN WITH
YOUR TEAMMATES AND HAVE A LITTLE
BANTER BACK AND FORTH, IT'S
GOOD.
SCOTT: CAN YOU GIVE ME AN
EXAMPLE OF SOMETHING IN THE PAST
WEEK AN EXCHANGE THAT YOU HAVE,
NAME IT, MIKE TROUT, ANTHONY
RENDON, SHOHEI OHTANI, JUSTIN
UPTON, SOMETHING CASUAL?
SOMEBODY WATCHING AT HOME AT
YOUTUBE SAYING ALL RIGHT RG
THESE ARE NORMAL DUDES BECAUSE
WE LOOK AT THEM IN SUCH A HUGE
WAY.
OHTANI OVERSEAS FOR A LONG TIME
AND NOW COMING OFF TO MAJOR
LEAGUE BASEBALL PLAYER AS A
TWO-WAY BASEBALL PLAYER OR
PUJOLS -- GIVE ME A COMMON
PHRASE THAT SOMEONE MIGHT SAY TO
YOU?
JARED: COMMON PHRASE.
I WAS ABLE TO GRAB A STEAK AND A
GLASS OF WINE WHICH I ASSUME
THAT'S EVERYBODY DREAM
ESPECIALLY PEOPLE IN JAPAN,
GETTING TO PLAY WITH DIFFERENT
PEOPLE.
IT DOESN'T MATTER IF YOU PLAY
JAPANESE, SPANISH, WE'RE ALL
FRIENDS IN THE CLUBHOUSE.
SCOTT: YOU CAN THROW THE
BASEBALL FROM THE MOUND PRETTY
WELL, JARED.
HAVE YOU GUYS DISCUSSED THAT?
AND CAN YOU TELL THE YOUTUBE
FANS ABOUT EUROPE EXPERIENCES ON
THE MOUND AND IF WE'LL SEE THAT
AGAIN AT SOME POINT?
JARED: I WAS A BRIEF TWO-WAY
PLAYER, BUT PITCHING HURTS.
AND HE AND I DON'T TALK ABOUT
PITCHING.
MOSTLY HITTING.
SCOTT: DO YOU EVER THINK ABOUT
THE MIND OF A PITCHER WHEN YOU
HAVE BEEN ON THE MOUND IN BIG
MOMENTS AND WHAT GUYS ARE TRYING
TO THROW AT YOU?
AND WHAT YOU MENTIONED EARLIER,
HEYER, HE'S NOT GETTING THE
FIRST PITCH DOWN THE PIPE
ANYMORE.
THEY KNOW ABOUT YOU, JARED, HOW
CAN YOU PITCHER PITCHING
EXPERIENCE HELP YOU AS A HITTER?
>> JUST REMEMBER THAT EVERYONE'S
HUMAN.
YOU'RE NEVER GOING TO BE
PERFECT.
I WOULDN'T SAY PUT TOO MUCH
PRESSURE ON YOURSELF.
SOMETIMES YOU'LL GET A PITCH
RIGHT DOWN THE MIDDLE AND POP IT
UP.
DON'T GIVE EVERYBODY TOO MUCH
CREDIT.
HAVE A LITTLE FUN.
JIM:: WHO HAD THE BIGGEST
INFLUENCE ON YOU FROM EITHER THE
YOUTH LEVEL, HIGH SCHOOL LEVEL
AS YOU WERE COMING UP?
OR MAYBE IT WAS YOUR DAD?
WHO HAD THE BIGGEST INFLUENCE ON
YOU FOR BASEBALL?
JARED: MY MOM.
LISA WALSH.
WHEN I WAS A KID, MY DAD HAD
CANCER.
HE WASN'T ABLE TO THROW ANYMORE.
SO MY MOM THREW ME BATTING
PRACTICE.
MY MOM TRAVELS ALL IN THE EAST,
PAID FOR COLLEGE.
CAN'T SAY ENOUGH ABOUT THEM.
SCOTT: THAT'S REALLY COOL,
JARED.
AND FOR THE PREGAME MEAL AND IF
YOU'RE THAT KIND OF GUY, WHAT
ARE YOU DOING?
ARE YOU GOING REAL HEAVY OR ARE
YOU KEEPING IT LIGHT?
WHAT ARE YOU EATING BEFORE A
GAME LIKE TODAY?
JARED: I'VE DONE A TERRIBLE JOB
AT ALL THE QUESTIONS YOU'VE
ASKED ME.
THE VENTI COLD BREW.
FOOD NOT SO MUCH BUT I NEED A
LITTLE CAFFEINE RUNNING THROUGH
MY VEINS.
SCOTT: YOU DID GREAT.
FIRST TIME TALKING TO YOU.
I'M SURE IT WON'T BE THE LAST.
CONGRATS ON YOUR SUCCESS.
GOOD LUCK THE REASON -- REST OF
THE SEASON.
JARED: THANK YOU, GUYS.
STAY SAFE.
SCOTT: HE'S CLEANING UP IN THE
LINEUP AND WELL CALF FATED.
THE MLB GAME OF THE WEEK
PRESENTED BY CHIME IS 15 MINUTES
AWAY.
SCOTT: IT IS TIME FOR OUR
YOUTUBE CREATOR SPOTLIGHT.
HE'S A FORMER BIG LEAGUER.
HE'S A FORMER FIRST ROUND PICK.
HE'S BEEN ON THE YOUTUBE GAME
FOR A LONG TIME.
THE CHANNEL IS ANTONELLI
BASEBALL.
MATT ANTONELLI NOT ONLY PLAYED
IN THE BIGS.
NOT ONLY WENT THROUGH THE
COLLEGE RANKS AND THE FARM
SYSTEM.
YOU KNOW WHAT, I'LL GOING TO GO
INSTRUCTIONAL VIDEOS, MECHANICS
AND GIVE YOU A LITTLE TASTE OF
WHAT IT'S LIKE TO BE A BIG
LEAGUER.
LET'S CHAT WITH MATT.
MATT, HOW ARE YOU?
I WILL START BY SAYING, I
DRAFTED YOU IN MY MINOR LEAGUE
FANTASY DRAFT ABOUT 15 YEARS
AGO.
SO I'VE BEEN FOLLOWING YOUR
CAREER ALL THE WAY BACK PRETTY
MUCH WHEN IT STARTED AS FAR AS A
PRO.
>> WELL, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
IT'S GREAT TO BE HERE.
AND LIKE I SAID EARLIER, I COULD
HAVE DISAPPOINTED YOU.
THERE WERE A FEW GOOD YEARS BUT
A COUPLE OF BAD ONES AS WELL.
SORRY ABOUT THAT.
SCOTT: I'LL TAKE THE UPS AND
DOWNS AND THE DEVELOPMENT.
YOU LEARNED A TON GOING THROUGH
THAT SYSTEM AND HAVE BEEN
SHARING WITH THE WORLD WHAT YOU
WENT THROUGH AS A MINOR LEAGUER,
WHAT YOU'VE LEARNED.
SO LET'S JUST START THERE WITH
THE CHANNEL.
WHERE DID THE IDEA COME FROM?
AND DID YOU EVER THINK IT WOULD
GET TO THIS POINT WHERE THERE
ARE SO MANY PEOPLE BENEFITING
FROM WHAT YOU'RE DOING?
>> NO, NOT AT ALL.
I STARTED MY YOUTUBE CHANNEL
WHEN I WAS PLAYING.
ALWAYS HAD A VISION OF ME
COACHING.
I WAS ABLE TO LEARN A LOT.
I PLAYED FOR FIVE DIFFERENT
TEAMS.
I PLAYED FOR A LOT OF GREAT
COACHES.
A LOT OF GREAT MANAGERS.
AND JUST TOOK BITS AND PIECES
FROM ALL OF THEM.
WAS ABLE TO PASS THAT ALONG.
ONE OF MY PASSIONS IS TO PASS
THAT ALONG TO THE YOUNG KIDS.
SO I'VE BEEN LUCKY TO DO THAT
OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS.
SCOTT: JUST PICK OUT ONE OF YOUR
HOTTEST VIDEOS THAT YOU'VE EVER
HAD.
WHICH ONE RACKED UP THE VIEW IS?
AND IS THERE A REASON WHY?
>> I THINK THE YOUTUBE CHANNEL
TOOK OFF WHEN I STARTED TO GIVE
SOME INSIGHT INTO MY PLAYING
CAREER BOTH AT THE MINOR AND
MAJOR LEAGUE LEVEL.
I THINK PROBABLY EVEN MORE MINOR
LEAGUE STUFF AND THE MAJOR
LEAGUE STUFF, I THINK FANS DON'T
EXACTLY KNOW HOW THE MINOR
LEAGUES WORK.
A LOT OF THOSE POPULATION ONES
WERE HOUGH DO MINOR LEAGUERS GET
PAID?
AND WHAT IS IT LIKE COMING
THROUGH THE RANKS?
ANYTHING TALKING ABOUT THE GAME
OF BASEBALL HAS BEEN ENJOYABLE
FOR ME AND IT'S BEEN PRETTY
POPULAR.
SCOTT: LET'S GO OVER THE GETTING
PAID THING.
WE JOKE AND CHAT ABOUT IT HERE
ON MLB NETWORK AND SOME OTHER
FOLKS ABOUT HOW IT LOOKS IN THE
BANK ACCOUNT.
I DON'T NEED NUMBERS OR
ANYTHING.
ER WANT TO MORE KNOW -- WHEN YOU
KNOW, WHEN YOU WERE PLAYING FOR
THE PADRES, DOES IT POP-UP IN
DIRECT DEPOSIT OR A CHECK?
WHAT'S THAT LOOKING LIKE?
>> WHEN I SIGNED I DIDN'T KNOW
ANYTHING.
I BELIEVE IT WAS PUT RIGHT INTO
MY CAN.
BUT SOME O MY FAVORITE STORIES
WHEN I WAS DRAFTED.
I HAD A PRETTY GOOD SIGNING
BONUS.
SO A LOT OF PLAYERS WEREN'T THAT
FORTUNATE.
I USED TO TALK TO PEOPLE, HOW
MUCH ARE YOU GETTING PAID A
COUPLE OF MILLION DOLLARS?
I THINK I MADE ABOUT $5,000 LAST
YEAR.
MOST COULDN'T BELIEVE ME.
A LOT OF MISCONCEPTIONS.
ONCE YOU GET TO THE BIG LEAGUES,
IT MAKES UP FOR ALL THE SMALL
CHECKS YOU MAKE IN THE MINORS.
SCOTT: BIG BUCKS.
TELL THE WORLD WHO YOUR FIRST
CAREER KNOCK WAS OFF OF.
>> SO MY FIRST CAREER HIT WAS
OUT OF GREG MADDUX.
I CAN TELL THE GRANDKIDS AND MY
KIDS ABOUT THAT.
IT'S FUNNY.
I WAS PRETTY NERVOUS GOING INTO
THAT GAME AS I'M SURE MOST
PLAYERS ARE MAKING THEIR DEBUT.
I WAS HITTING EIGHTH IN THE
ORDER.
SO I DIDN'T GET TO HIT THE FIRST
INNING.
HAD A GROUND BALL.
RUSSELL MARTIN HIT ME A BALL.
I MADE THE THROW TO FIRST.
ALL OF A SUDDEN I FELT THIS
CALMNESS COME OVER ME.
WHEN I DID HIT, IT HONESTLY FELT
LIKE ANOTHER AT-BAT FOR ME.
I GOT A FASTBALL.
HIT A SING TO CENTER FIELD.
ROUNDED FIRST BASE AND I SAID
THAT'S PRETTY EASY.
I THINK I'M GOING TO GET 3,000
MORE OF THESE.
I WAS A LITTLE OFF IN MY
PREDICTION.
I HIT OFF OF A HALL OF FAMER.
SCOTT: THAT'S AWESOME.
I'M GLAD WE HAD THAT.
LET'S TALK ABOUT SOMETHING SILLY
OR SOMETHING FROM A FAN OR
SOMEBODY THAT'S BEEN IMPACTED
SAYING HEY, YOU REALLY HELPED ME
FROM MY CAREER?
ANY FEEDBACK THAT YOU CAN SHARE
WITH US?
>> SURE, I THINK ONE OF THE MOST
REWARDING THINGS FOR ME IS THE
FEEDBACK.
AND IT'S NOT JUST HELPING KIDS
AND AMERICA BUT HELPING PLAYERS
ALL OVER THE WORLD.
AND THE POWER OF THE INTERNET
AND YOUTUBE IS AMAZING.
I TALKED WITH -- WITH PARENTS,
WITH COACHES, WITH KIDS FROM
LITERALLY EVERY PART OF THE
WORLD PRETTY MUCH EVERY DAY, I
RECEIVE E-MAILS AND DIFFERENT
COMMENTS ON OUR SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS, JUST BEING ABLE TO
TAKE A LITTLE BIT OF SOMETHING
THAT I LEARNED AND I UNDERSTAND
HOW HARD THIS GAME IS AND HOW IT
CAN BE SEPARATING AT TIMES
BECAUSE IT IS A GAME OF FAILURE,
BEING ABLE TO GIVE THOSE PLAYERS
SOME HOPE, AND MAYBE JUST
SOMETHING SMALL THAT HELPS THEM,
YOU KNOW, IMPROVE A LITTLE BIT
AND GET THROUGH THE NEXT GAME OR
THE NEXT PRACTICE.
AND SO THAT REALLY WHAT GETS ME
MOTIVATED AND KEEPS ME DOING
WHAT I'M DOING. YOU'VE BEEN CRU
IT.
AND I'VE BEEN CALLING THESE
GAMES AND I'VE SEEN YOUR LIVE
COMMENTARY, LOOKING FORWARD TO
SEEING YOU DURING THIS GAME AS
WELL.
A PLEASURE SPEAKING TO YOU
PERSON TO PERSON FOR THE FIRST
TIME.
MATT: ABSOLUTELY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
SCOTT: HE'S GREAT.
YOU'LL SEE HIS COMMENTS IN THE
LIVE CHAT.
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE SUPERSTARS.
POWER, ATHLETICISM.
I ALSO WANT TO MENTION, CONTACT.
JOSE IGLESIAS, DAVID FLETCHER IS
INCREDIBLE IN THAT DEPARTMENT.
SAME WITH MICHAEL BRANTLEY.
CONTACT SPECIALIST.
SOME OF THE BEST CONTACT HITTERS
IN ALL OF MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL
IN ALL OF THE PLANET.
ANGELS-ASTROS ARE FIVE MINUTES
AWAY.
AND WE'LL DO OUR PICKS TO CLICK
IN A MOMENT.
>> OH, HANG ON TO THE ROOF!
>> THIS ONE IS OUT OF HERE!
>> THIS BALL HIT HARD AGAIN.
MICHAEL BRANTLEY, HOME RUN FOR
THE THIRD STRAIGHT OPENING DAY!
EVERY YEAR AS AN ASTRO, MICHAEL
BRANTLEY HAS HIT A HOME RUN!
>> U.K. -- UNCLE MIKE.
THEY'RE SAYING MIKE UNCLE.
>> ALEX BREGMAN DRIVES ONE DEEP
TO LEFT FIELD!
THAT BALL IS GONE!
BACK-TO-BACK JACKS!
BRANTLEY AND BREGMAN!
AND THE ASTROS NOW LEAD 5-1!
>> BACK-TO-BACK BANGERS.
>> YORDAN SENDS ONE IN THE AIR
TO LEFT CENTER FIELD.
GOING ALL THE WAY BACK TO THE
WALL!
THAT BALL IS GONE!
THE BIG MAN, ALVAREZ HITS ONE TO
LEFT CENTER FIELD, A THREE-RUN
SHOT!
AND THE ASTROS TAKE A 5-1 LEAD.
>> HERE WE GO.
WE'VE GOT LIFTOFF THAT IS NOT AN
EASY PITCH TO GET.
AND THAT'S ON THE OUTSIDE
CORNER.
AND YORDAN STAYS ON IT, STEPS ON
IT AND DRIVES IT.
♪
SCOTT: YOU'RE WATCHING THE MLB
GAME OF THE WEEK, PREGAME SHOW
PRESENTED BY CHIME.
CARLOS CORREA IS LEADING OFF,
FIRST TIME IN HIS CAREER.
THAT'S GOING TO BE FUN, JIM.
JIM: YEAH, LIKE THAT.
OBVIOUSLY, THE ATHLETICISM IS
THERE.
HE CAN RUN.
LIKE SOMETIMES MOVING A GUY UP
TO LEADOFF OR EVEN AS YOUR CLUB
CAN SPARK YOU AND GET YOU GOING.
SCOTT: LIKE IT.
WE'LL SEE HOW THAT LOOKS.
IT'S PICK TO CLICK PRESENTED BY
FANDUEL SPORTS BOOKS.
JUST FOR THE YOUTUBE CROWD TO
UNDERSTAND, YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE
PLENTY OF POLL QUESTIONS COMING
YOUR WAY DURING THIS GAME.
JIM, ARE YOU READY?
JIM: I'M READY.
SCOTT: WHAT'S NUMBER ONE HERE?
LET'S START WITH, OTHER THAN
MIKE TROUT, OK, SO YOU CAN'T
PICK THE GUY WE'RE ABOUT TO SEE,
WHO WOULD BE YOUR PECK FOR AL
M.V.P.?
JIM: I'M GOING TO GO JOSE ABREU.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE WHOLE
DYNAMIC OF HIM AND THE TEAM HE'S
ON AND HIS WORK ETHIC, I LIKE 60
R.B.I.'S IN 60 GAMES WAS
IMPRESSIVE.
YOU KNOW, WHAT A GREAT PLAYER.
AND IT'S FUN NO WATCH HIM.
I'M GOING JOSE ABREU.
SCOTT: IT'S A GREAT CALL.
SO YOU THINK HE CAN DO IT
BACK-TO-BACK?
JIM: I DO.
SCOTT: I LIKE IT.
I WANT YOU TO FOCUS ON THIS GAME
IN PARTICULAR.
THE OVER/UNDER FOR TONIGHT'S
GAME, TOTAL RUNS IS EIGHT AND A
HALF.
ARE YOU GOING UP OR DOWN?
JIM: I'M GOING TO GO URN.
I'M GOING TO GO DOWN.
DOWN.
FOR SOME REASON THE PITCHING
MATCHUP, COBB -- CRISTIAN JAVIER
HAS GOT THE REALLY GOOD SLIDER,
CURVEBALL AND THIS THING COBB
THROWS THE HYBRID SPLIT
CHANGEUP, YOU KNOW, WATCHING HIM
THE FIRST SERIES, I THINK
AGAINST THE WHITE SOX, HE HAD --
THAT BALL WAS REALLY MOVING.
AND IT WILL BE -- I THINK IT'S
GOING TO BE UNDER FOR SURE.
SCOTT: AND IT PLAYS TO WHAT
WE'VE BEEN SEEING LESS
FASTBALLS.
AND WE'VE SEEN THAT FROM COBB.
MORE RELYING ON THE THING.
WE'LL SEE THAT AT PLAY.
WHAT ABOUT YOUR FAVORITE IN THE
AMERICAN LEAGUE WEST?
BECAUSE THIS DIVISION LOOKS LIKE
PRETTY MUCH ANYONE'S GAME AT
THIS POINT?
JIM: NOT BECAUSE OF THE WAY
THEY'RE PLAYING RIGHT NOW, BUT
OAKLAND IS A TEAM YOU ALSO HAVE
TO WATCH.
THEY DO EVERYTHING FUNDAMENTALLY
SOUND.
THEY PITCH WELL.
THEY DO -- THEY HIT GOOD WITH
TWO STRIKES.
AS THEY PROGRESS DURING THE
YEAR, THEY'RE ALWAYS A CLUB TO
WATCH.
AND FOR SOME REASON.
I THINK THEY'RE GOING TO WIN THE
WEST.
NO DOUBT.
SCOTT: DID YOU FALL FOR THE SLOW
START FOR THE A'S?
BECAUSE IT WAS ROUGH.
THEY WERE 1- TO START THIS
SEASON?
JIM: LOOK.
YOU CAN'T WIN A CHAMPIONSHIP IN
APRIL.
BUT YOU CAN PUT YOURSELF BEHIND.
BUT IT'S HOW YOU BOUNCE BACK
FROM THOSE -- FROM THOSE BAD
TIMINGS.
I THINK THE OVERALL, THE YEARS
THAT OAKLAND HAS DONE THIS,
THERE'S CONFIDENCE, AND MELVIN
DOES A FABULOUS JOB FOR THEM.
AND HE ALWAYS HAS THEM READY TO
PLAY.
SCOTT: WHO'S GOING TO WIN THE
AMERICAN LEAGUE?
JIM: I LIKE THE WHITE SOX.
I LIKE THEIR BULLPEN, THEIR
STARTING PITCHING.
THERE'S ANOTHER CLUB THAT AS
THEY KEEP DOING THIS, AS THEY
CLIMB DURING THIS LONG GRIND OF
162, I THINK THAT BULLPEN AND
THAT -- AND THAT STARTING
PITCHING WILL -- PUT THEM IN IN
A POSITION TO WIN THE AMERICAN
LEAGUE.
SCOTT: YOU'RE ALL IN ON THE
WHITE SOX.
JIM: I LOVE THE WHITE SOX.
I THINK THEY'RE BUILT FOR MAJOR
SUCCESS.
SCOTT: AND SO WE HAVE THE ANSWER
TO THE POLL QUESTION THAT WE RAN
THROUGH FOR YOU EARLIER.
AND ANGELS FANS GOING BIG
TONIGHT, JIM.
WHO'S GOING TO WIN TODAY'S GAME?
AND THEY SAY ALEX COBB AND MY
TROUT AND ALBERT PUJOLS AND
JARED WALSH OUR GUEST FROM
EARLIER.
WHO'S YOUR PICK?
JIM: I'M GOING TO GO THE ANGELS.
I THINK -- YEAH, WHEN TROUT IS
HOT RIGHT NOW, OHTANI AS WELL,
AND THIS -- THIS PITCH THAT COBB
-- HE'S VERY CRAFTY.
AND HE KNOWS HOW THE PITCH.
IT SHOULD BE AND ALL-AROUND
GAME.
SCOTT: YOU HEARD IT FROM JIM.
LOW SCORING GAMEISH.
ANGELS ARE TAKING IT.
WE'RE LIVE ON YOUTUBE, ANGELS
AND ASTROS, I'LL PUT THIS IN A
SUPER PLUG EARLY TEASE.
JIM ANDLY BE CALLING NEXT WEEK'S
GAME, INDIANS AND TWINS.
LATROY HAWKINS WILL JOIN US AS
WELL.
REALLY TWO OF THE NICEST HUMANS
ON THE PLANET.
I'M GOING TO SPEAK FOR YOU.
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A LOT OF
FUN.
AND LATROY IS SUCH A GREAT DUDE
TOO.
IT'S GOING TO BE GREAT.
FOR NOW, IT'S ALL ABOUT THE
HOUSTON ASTROS AND THE LOS
ANGELES ANGELS.
AND AS YOU CAN SEE ALEX BREGMAN
IS IN THERE TONIGHT FOR HOUSE
TOVEPBLET ASTROS ARE TRYING TO
GET BACK ON THE WINNING SIDE OF
THINGS.
IT'S BEEN A MINUTE.
MIKE TROUT.
WHAT ARE YOU SAYING RIGHT NOW?
WE'RE GOING TO KNOW WHAT HE'S
SAYING DURING THE GAME.
HE'LL BE MIC'ED UP.
YOU'LL HARE PLENTY OF SOUNDS
FROM THE BEST PLAYER ON THE
PLANET.
HAVE FUN.
ENJOY THE GAME.
>> DOWNTOWN HOUSTON WHERE THE
ONLY POSITIVE THING TO COME OUT
OF THE PANDEMIC IS NO TRAFFIC IN
A BIG SPRAWLING DOWNTOWN
COMMUNITY.
READY FOR BASEBALL FROM THE
SPACE CITY TONIGHT.
WELCOME TO THE MLB GAME OF THE
WEEK LIVE ON YOUTUBE PRESENTED
BY CHIME.
TONIGHT, FROM MINUTE MAID PARK,
A BATTLE IN THE A.L. WEST
BETWEEN THE LOS ANGELES ANGELS
AND THE HOMESTANDING HOUSTON
ASTROS.
AND WELCOME TO A WORLDWIDE
AUDIENCE ON YOUTUBE TONIGHT.
ABOUT A GAME AND A HALF
SEPARATING THE ASTROS AND ANGELS
IN THE A.L. WEST.
TOO EARLY TO MAKE ANY
DETERMINATIONS ABOUT TEAMS
TRENDING UPWARD OR DOWNWARD.
WE CAN TELL YOU THIS, THE ASTROS
ARE HAPPY TO BE BACK HOME AFTER
A ROUGH ROAD TRIP CULMINATING IN
A LOST YESTERDAY PLAYING IN THE
COLDEST TEMPERATURES EVERY IN
DENVER.
AND THE ANGELS ARE OPENING A
10-GAME ROAD TRIP WITH THE FIRST
OF THIS FOUR-GAME SERIES IN
HOUSTON.
LITTLE NOTE ON WHAT YOU'RE
WATCHING TONIGHT.
THIS IS THE SECOND OF 21 LIVE
MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL GAMES
EXCLUSIVELY PRESENTED ON
YOUTUBE.
CAN'T WATCH THIS ONE ANYWHERE
ELSE.
IT STREAMS LIVE ON MLB'S YOUTUBE
CHANNEL FOR FREE.
CLICK THE BELL ICON.
RECEIVE KNOWFICATIONS PRIOR TO
TONIGHT'S GAME.
>> THIS IS GOING TO BE FUN FOR
ME TODAY BECAUSE I'M WORKING
ALONGSIDE TWO GUYS WHO KNOW AND
WHO HAVE WON.
I'M THE ONLY GUY WITHOUT A
CHAMPIONSHIP AND QUOUT A POCKET
HANDKERCHIEF.
LET'S START WITH SHOHEI OHTANI
AND MIKE TROUT.
FOR MIKE TROUT, WE KNOW ABOUT
THE ACCOMPLISHMENTS.
A.L. ROOKIE OF THE YEAR.
A ROOM FULL OF SILVER SLUGGER
AWARD AND THREE M.V.P.'S.
HE'S GOTTEN OFF TO GOOD STARTS
IN THE PAST AS YOU'VE WATCHED
OVER THE YEARS.
THIS YEAR IS ONE OF HIS BEST.
>> IT'S BEEN UNBELIEVABLE.
ON-BASE PERCENTAGE AT .507
LEADING MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL.
AND HE SHOWED A LOT OF
ENTHUSIASM.
HE'S GOT A COUPLE OF BIG KEY
HITS.
HE'S PUMPING HIS FIST.
HE'S TOTALLY INTO GETTING THIS
TEAM ON HIS BACK GETTING INTO
THE POSTSEASON.
ALL THOSE QUESTIONS IN BRING ARE
YOU GOING TO GET TO THE
POSTSEASON?
RIGHT NOW, HE'S SAYING I'M GOING
TO DELIVER THE NUMBERS THAT HE
HAS FOR THE HALO THIS IS SEASON.
MATT: TO THOSE WHO SUGGEST MIKE
TROUNT HASN'T PLAYED ENOUGH TO
BE A HALL OF FAMER RIGHT NOW, WE
OFFER THIS TO CONTEND WITH THAT
THOUGHT.
THROUGH 1,268 GAMES THAT'S WHERE
TROUT IS RIGHT NOW.
THIS GRABS YOUR ATTENTION.
>> KEN GRIFFEY JR. IS A
CONTEMPORARY.
I REMEMBER SEEING HIS ENTHUSIASM
AND THE NUMBERS OF HOW HE CAN
CARRY A CLUB.
MICKEY MANTLE.
HE KNOWS THAT'S A LOT OF
PRESSURE.
BUT HE'S THRIVING ON THAT
PRESSURE PUT ON HIM.
MATT: GEOFF, IT WAS THE NOT OK
CORRAL.
REGULAR SEASON WAS NOT A GOOD
ONE.
JUSTIN VERLANDER, ARM INJURY AND
MADE ONE START.
INJURIES COST YORDAN ALVAREZ
WHAT WOULD HAVE BEEN THE ROOKIE
OF THE YEAR CAMPAIGN.
CARLOS CORREA NOT HIMSELF LAST
YEAR.
SAME WITH JOSE ALTUVE.
YET, DESPITE ALL THAT THEY
TURNED IT ON IN THE FALL AND
CAME WITHIN ONE GAME OF ANOTHER
WORLD SERIES APPEARANCE.
JEFF, YOU WATCH THIS TEAM EVERY
DAY.
THERE'S TOO MICHIGAN TALENT FOR
THEM TO STAY VERY COLD FOR VERY
MUCH LONGER.
GEOFF: HE'S ONE OF THOSE GUYS
THAT IS GOING TO BE PART OF THE
CLASS THIS SEASON.
EXPECT HIM TO HAVE BEA BIG YEAR.
BUT YORDAN ALVAREZ IS GOING TO
BE A NICE POWER SOURCE FOR DUSTY
BAKER.
YOU SEE THE 60 EXTRA-BASE HITS
IN HIS FIRST 100 CAREER GAMES IS
LEGENDARY ALREADY.
BUT THIS GUY RIGHT HERE, DR.
SMOOTH -- WE CALL HIM UNCLE MIKE
IN HOUSTON BECAUSE HE'S BEEN SO
RELIABLE IN WHAT HE DOES, BOTH
STATISTICALLY AND WHAT HE BRINGS
TO THAT CLUBHOUSE.
HE'S A GUY THAT CAN GIVE THEM
SOME COMFORT DURING SOME CITY
MULTUOUS TIMES.
MATT: THEY ARE ONE OF ONLY FIVE
CLUBS TO REACH AN L.C.S. IN
CONSECUTIVE SEASONS.
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A LOT OF
FUN.
NOT ONLY ARE WE WITH YOU FOR
INNINGS ONE THROUGH NINE.
WE HAVE A FOURTH MEMBER OF OUR
BROADCAST CREW AS WE SAY GOOD
EVENING TO BRETT DOLAN.
BRETT: TO SAY THE LEAST IN THE
FIRST WEEK THINGS WORKED OUT
WELL.
HOUSTON WON 6-7 GAMES.
THE TEAM WAS SCORING MORE THAN
SEVEN RUNS.
THE EARNED RUN AVERAGE WAS VERY
LOW.
BUT THINGS HAVE CHANGED AND
CHANGED IN A RATHER DRAMATIC
FASHION.
THE STROS HAVE LOST 9-10 GAMES.
YOU BARLEY RECOGNIZE THEIR
O.P.S. AND THE TEAM E.R.A. HAS
GONE WAY UP.
THIS DOES COME WITH AN
EXPLANATION.
THE ASTROS HAD FIVE PLAYERS PUT
INTO COVID PROTOCOL.
ALVAREZ, MALDONADO, BREGMAN AND
ALTUVE.
THEY GOT FOUR BACK TOES AND
SNOW FLURRIES IN DENVER,
COLORADO.
BUT STILL NO ALTUVE YET.
SO DUSTY BAKER WAS ASKED WHETHER
OR NOT HE'S ADDRESSED THIS SLOW
START WITH THIS TEAM.
MEANING ALTUVE.
HE COULD BE SEVERAL MORE GAMES.
THEY'RE OUT OF THE SNOW.
HOPEFUL THAT DUSTY CAN GET HIS
TEAM BACK TO THE WAY THEY WERE
PLAYING IN THE FIRST GAME OF THE
SEASON.
MATTY?
MATT: AND THE WARM WEATHER OF
HOUSTON, TEXAS NEVER LOOKED SO
GOOD TO A CHILLY GROUP OF ASTROS
YESTERDAY IN DENVER.
WHEN WE COME BACK, IT'S TIME FOR
LINEUPS AND THE OPENING PITCH,
THE ANGELS AND ASTROS ARE COMING
UP MEX.
-- NEXT.
MATT: WELCOME BACK TO THE MLB
GAME OF THE WEEK PRESENTED ON
YOUTUBE PRESENTED BY CHIME WITH
GEOFF AND BRETT AND MARK.
GREAT TO HAVE A WORLDWIDE
AUDIENCE ALONG WITH US TONIGHT.
WELCOME TO THE FUTURE,
GENTLEMEN.
LIVE BASEBALL ON YOUTUBE.
YOU CAN ONLY WATCH THE ANGELS
AND ASTROS RIGHT HERE TONIGHT.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT JOE
MADDON'S ANGELS' LINEUP TO
KICKOFF THIS FOUR-GAME SERIES
PRESENT BED CHIME.
FLETCHER, OHTANI AND TROUT OUT
OF THE GAME.
MIKE TROUT WITH A HOMER AGAINST
THE ASTROS AND HE HASN'T
STOPPED.
WALSH, UPTON AND PUJOLS BAT
FOURTH THROUGH SIX.
IGLESIAS AND ROJAS AND SUZUKI
ROUND IT OUT.
I'LL START THIS WITH YOU, LEAGUE
THE AMERICAN LEAGUE IN HOMERS
AND I LONG WITH A RED-HOT
OAKLAND A'S TEAM AND IT'S MIKE
TROUT WHO FLEEDS THAT CATEGORY.
MARK: JUST ABSOLUTELY CRUSHING
THE BASEBALL.
GOING UP AGAINST A VERY TOUGH
PITCHER IN CRISTIAN JAVIER.
HE'S GOT A FASTBALL 92, 96.
VERY GOOD SLIDER.
CURVEBALL AND CHANGEUP.
SO FAR THIS SEASON IT'S A 2.08
E.R.A. IN 8 2/3.
LOOK AT THOSE STRIKEOUT NUMBERS.
5-1 AS FAR AS STRIKEOUTS TO
WALKS.
MATT: THIS IS HIS FIRST BIG
LEAGUE SENATOR A COUPLE OF
WEEKS.
BUT THAT WAS ALL BY DESIGN, WE
UNDERSTAND.
GEOFF: YEAH, DEFINITELY WAS.
THE ASTROS HAD SOME LUXURY OF
HAVING SOME DAYS IN THERE.
THEY HAVE BEEN ABLE TO SEND
CRISTIAN JAVIER OUT THERE.
THEY THEM TO GIVE HIM A GOOD
START.
THAT FOUR-SEAM FASTBALL IS GOOD.
THIS IS ONE OF THEIR SPIN RATE
KINGS.
MATT: LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE
ASTROS DEFENSIVELY BROUGHT TO
YOU BY CHIME.
SEVEN ERRORS IN THEIR 17 GAMES.
NICE TIGHT DEFENSIVE UNIT.
IS IT RANGE IN ATHLETICISM OR
FLASHY PLAYS OR ARE THEY A MORE
WORKMAN LIKE DEFENSIVE GROUP?
MARK: THEY CAN DO IT WITH THE
FLASH, ESPECIALLY A GUY LIKE
CARLOS CORREA WHO A 6'4", 6'5"
AT SHORTSTOP.
YOU HAVE TO KEEP IN MIND, THE
ASTROS ARE HIGHLY ANALYTICAL
THEY'LL SHIFT THEM AND PUT THEM
IN BETTER POSITIONS TO MAKE
PLAYS.
MATT: UNDERWAY ON YOUTUBE
TONIGHT WITH THE FIRST PITCH OF
THE GAME FOR JAVIER.
IN FOR STRIKE ONE.
DAVID FLETCHER, SHOHEI OHTANI
AND MIKE TROUT FOR THE VISITING
ANGELS.
THE NUMBERS ON JAVIER'S START
AND IT WAS TWO WEEKS AGO TO THE
DAY, FIVE SHUT OUN ININGS IN A
6-2 VICTORY, STRUCK OUT SEVEN.
ALLOWED ONLY THREE BASE HITS.
AND GUYS LIKE THIS FASCINATE
PEOPLE LIKE ME BECAUSE HE'S NOT
THROWING 98, 99 MILES AN HOUR.
YET, HE CAN STILL MAKE GOOD
FASTBALL HITTERS SWING AND MISS.
>> YEAH, IT'S THAT DISAPPEARING
FOUR-SEAMER ON THE UPPER THIRD
OF THE STRIKE ZONE.
MATT: A BALL AND TWO STRIKES BY
DAVID FLETCHER.
GEOFF: GOOD TAKE BY FLETCHER ON
THAT SLIDER, HUH?
[LAUGHTER]
MATT: I'VE GOT TO RECALIBRATE TO
YOUR SENSE OF HUMOR.
I HAVE NOT SPENT SUBSTANTIAL
TIME WITH YOU IN THE BETTER PART
OF ABOUT 12 YEARS.
STRIKEOUT FOR JAVIER.
HOW ABOUT THE CHIME BREAKDOWN ON
TONIGHT'S ASTROS' STARTER,
GUBEY?
MARK: MY THREE KEY POINTS FOR
HIM IS CONTROLLING.
VERY GOOD IN POP-UPS AND FINISH
WITH THE SLIDERS.
AND BETTER SECOND TIME THROUGH.
0-0-0.
SECOND TIME THROUGH, HADN'T 462
BATTING AGAINST JAVIER THIS
SEASON.
SECOND TIME THE HITTERS GET TO
SEE HIM.
MATT: SHOHEI OHTANI WITH ONE
AWAY TO START THE NIGHT.
OHTANI HAS HAD A CARTOONISH
START TO THE 2021 SEASON ALL
OVER THE STAT CAST LEADERBOARD
IN TERMS OF EXIT VELOCITY WITH A
BAT IN HIS HANDS.
AND PLAIN, OLD PITCH VELOCITY
WHEN HE'S OUT ON THE MOUND.
1-1.
MARK: HE CAN GENERATE SOME BAT
SPEED.
I'LL TELL YOU WHAT.
MATT: YOU CAN SEE THE ASTROS ARE
RIGHTSIDE OVERLOAD AS BLUM
TALKED ABOUT A MOMENT AGO.
GEOFF DO THEY SWITCH FOR
LEFT-HANDED BATTERS OR ON BOTH
SIDES OF THE PLATE THAT THEY
WILL GO TO THAT SHIFT?
GEOFF: YOU KNOW WHAT, WHEN THEY
HAVE ALTUVE THEY WON'T SHIFT
BECAUSE IT'S A LITTLE BIT LONGER
THROW.
BUT WHEN THEY HAVE A LEFT-HANDED
HITTER OUT THERE THEY WILL SHIFT
DRASTICALLY ON THE RIGHT SIDE OF
THE FIELD LIKE YOU SEE ON YOUR
SCREEN.
MATT: TWO BALLS AND TWO STRIKES
ON OHTANI.
GEOFF: CAN I JUST SAY OF ENVIOUS
OF MARK AND HIS ABILITY TO WATCH
GUYS LIKE MIKE TROUT AND SHOHEI
OHTANI REGULARLY.
I CAN'T IMAGINE WHAT IT'S LIKE
WATCHING ATHLETES OF THIS
CALIBER AS OFTEN AS GUBEY DOES.
MATT: TWO STRIKEOUTS FOR
CRISTIAN JAVIER.
MARK: IT'S ALMOST LIKE WATCHING
JACKSON AND OHTANI TOGETHER.
THERE ARE -- THEIR SKILLS.
PRETTY NASTY CHANGEUP.
MATT: SO TWO GONE.
AND NOW MIKE TROUT WHO GETS HERE
RED-HOT.
5-8.
HUGE NUMBERS TO START THE YEAR.
SIX BIG BOYS, 12 R.B.I.'S.
JAVIER UNDERSTANDABLY TRYING TO
WORK HIM AWAY.
MISSING WITH A SLIDER.
A BALL AND NO STRIKES.
TROUT HAS HOMERED IN
BACK-TO-BACK GAMES ENTERING THE
SEASON.
IF HE CAN HOMER TONIGHT IT WOULD
ALREADY BE THE SECOND TIME THIS
YEAR THAT HE WOULD HAVE HOMERED
IN THREE STRAIGHT.
THESE TWO TEAMS SPLIT THEIR
OPENING SERIES IN ANAHEIM.
TROUT HOMERED IN THE OPENER IN
THE ANGELS' 7-6 WIN.
ASTROS COME BACK AND EVEN IT UP
THE FOLLOWING NIGHT WITH A
VICTORY THAT INCLUDED A BIG
HOMER BY CARLOS CORREA.
JAVIER IS FALLEN BEHIND TWO
BALLS AND NO STRIKES.
MARK: TROUT HAS BEEN MORE
AGGRESSIVE 3-0 THIS YEAR.
MATT: 3-1.
WELL, YOU KNOW, TO BLUMMER'S
POINT A MOMENT AGO.
THE CARTOONY NUMBER FOR TROUT,
WHEN HE'S AHEAD IN THE COUNT,
SINCE THE START OF THE 2019
SEASON, HE'S GOT APPEAR O.P.S.
OF 1700.
AND THERE'S BALL FOUR.
SO TROUT'S ABOARD WITH TWO GONE.
THAT WILL BRING UP JARED WALSH
WITH A BIG OPPORTUNITY.
HE TOO STARTS THE SERIES HOT.
HE'S HIT SAFELY IN FIVE STRAIGHT
GAMES.
5-15 RUN TO WRAP-UP THE
HOMESTAND.
AND OF ALL THE KNOWN COMESITIES
ON THE ANGELS, GUYS LIKE TROUT,
UPTON, PUJOLS, JARED WALSH IS
THE GUY THAT MIGHT SNEAK UP ON
THE CASUAL FAN.
BUT THAT'S NOT TO SUGGEST THAT
HE'S NOT EVERY BIT AS GOOD AS
THAT AFOREMENTIONED LIST OF BLUE
BLOODERS.
AND HE TAKES A STRIKE.
MATT: .619.
IF YOU GO UP TOP, THAT'S .696
SLUGGING PERCENTAGE IS SEVENTH
BEST IN BASEBALL.
AND THE GUYS AHEAD OF HIM ARE
THE GUYS YOU WOULD EXPECT TO SEE
ON THE LIST.
AND HE LAYS OFF THREE BALLS AND
A STRIKE.
MARK: BUT THE INTERESTING THING
ABOUT THAT, YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
RIGHT-HANDED BATTER.
NOT MANY LEFT-HANDED BATTERS
PREFER THE LOWER THIRD TO DODGE
THEIR DAMAGE.
MATT: TWO BALLS AND STRIKE, THE
COUNT TO JARED WALSH.
FULL COUNT NOW.
MATT: ON HIS WAY BACK TO THE
BENCH, HE'S LOOKING OUT TO THE
MOUND THINKING HOW DID I NOT HIT
THAT.
JUST LIKE THAT.
THREE STRIKEOUTS.
NOTHING COMES WITH A TWO-OUT
WALK UNDERWAY IN HOUSTON
TONIGHT.
>> HERE'S MIKE TROUT BATTING.
TWO OUTS, NO ONE ON.
NO SCORE.
AND HE SWINGS AT THE PITCH.
LIFT AS HIGH FLY BALL THAT'S
CARRYING DEEP OUT INTO RIGHT
FIELD.
IT IS OUT OF HERE!
HOME RUN NUMBER SIX FOR MIKE
TROUT!
>> DAMAGE, FIRST PITCH.
POWER FOR TROUT.
OHTANI HITTING .304.
SHOHEI OHTANI HITS A HIGH FLY
BALL TO RIGHT FIELD.
TO THE WALL
MATT: CARLOS CORREA WILL IS IT
ATOP THE LINEUP CARD FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN HIS CAREER.
DUSTY DESPERATE TO GENERATE A
LITTLE OFFENSE.
BRANTLEY IN SECOND.
BREGMAN AND ALVAREZ THREE
THROUGH FIVE.
AND MARTIN MALDONADO THE FORMER
ANGEL TO START THINGS OFF.
ALEX COBB ON THE MOUND FOR THE
THIRD TIME AS AN ANGEL.
HIS ATTEMPT WAS A SCRATCH
BECAUSE OF A SERIES LOSS AGAINST
THE MINNESOTA TWINS.
SO IT'S BEEN A WHILE FOR ALEX AS
WELL.
HIS LAST START BACK ON THE 12TH
OF APRIL A REALLY GOOD ONE, MARK
SAW 10 STRIKEOUTS IN KANSAS
CITY.
MARK: HAD A NASTY SPLIT WORK.
AND HIS FASTBALL VELOCITY HAS
BEEN PICKING UP.
HE'S BEEN TOUCHING 95 MILES PER
HOUR.
AND ALSO A GOOD CURVEBALL AS
WELL.
MATT: A STRIKE TO CARLOS CORREA
TO THE LEADOFF HITTER, YEAH,
LEADING OFF TONIGHT.
WE TALKED TO DUSTY BAKER BEFORE
THE GAME.
DUSTY, WHILE ALWAYS OPTIMISTIC
IS KIND OF READY TO SHAKE THINGS
UP A LITTLE BIT FOR HIS GUYS.
GEOFF: YEAH, HE'S GOT TO DO
SOMETHING.
THE ASTROS 1-9 IN THEIR LAST TWO
GAMES HAVING BASE RUNNERS ON HAS
BEEN AN ISSUE.
JOSE ALTUVE WHEN HE WAS IN THERE
WAS HITTING .318 AND HAVING
MYLES STRAW MOVE INTO THAT TOP
SPOT DIDN'T WORK.
HE SEEMED LIKE THE LOGICAL GO-TO
AS FAR AS FILLING THAT SPACE.
IT WAS THE INABILITY TO GET
THINGS ON BASE AND GET THINGS
GOING IN THE MIDDLE OF THIS
LINEUP.
MATT: ASTROS' LINEUP THAT HIT
176 DURING THE RECENTLY
COMPLETED FIVE GAME TRIP.
DUSTY IS CREEPING UP ON A
MILESTONE WIN AS WE GET GOING.
STILL A BALL AND TWO STRIKES ON
CARLOS CORREA.
WEIRD STATISTICAL PROFILE FOR
THE ASTROS.
THEY DON'T STRIKE OUT.
THEY'RE AROUND THE MIDDLE OF THE
PACK AROUND MANY OFFENSIVE
CATEGORIES.
BUT THERE'S NOT ANY TRACTION AT
ALL WITH  THIS STAGE OF THE
SCHEDULE.
GEOFF: HERE RECENTLY IN THIS
LAST 10-GAME STRETCH, IT'S BEEN
HITTING WITH RUNNERS IN SCORING
POSITION WHERE THEY WERE HITTING
.163.
SO THE INABILITY TO DRIVE IN
RUNS HAS BEEN A REAL ISSUE.
MATT: FULL COUNT TO CORREA.
HE SQUARES UP ON A BALL AND GOES
TO CENTER.
AND THE FIRST OUT IS IN THE
BOOKS FOR ALEX COBB.
GUBEY, LET'S BREAK THEM DOWN.
GEOFF: GOT TO BE CAREFUL.
.375, .368 IN HIS CAREER.
AND SWING AND MISS WITH HIS
SPLIT.
13 STRIKEOUTS WITH A SPLITTER
THIS YEAR.
AND GROUND BALL ACTION FOR ALEX
COBB.
58.6% GROUND BALLS THIS YEAR FOR
ALEX COP -- COBB.
MATT: WE'LL GO TO MICHAEL
BRANTLEY WHO HAS BEEN THE ONLY
RELIABLE BAT FOR DUSTY BAKER.
AND BRANTLEY TAKES A STRIKE.
MICHAEL JUST OVER .300 FOR THE
SEASON RIGHT AROUND HIS CAREER
AVERAGE SITS, NOT IRONICALLY.
HE'S NEVER HAD GOOD LOOKS FOR
ALEX COBB.
MAKE IT 1-11 AS IGLESIAS MAKES
THE PLAY FOR THE SECOND OUT.
GEOFF: HIS POWER SINKING
FASTBALLS WILL GET A LOT OF
GROUND BALLS.
HE THROW AS LOT OF SPLITTERS.
45.4%.
IF YOU'RE A HITTER FOR THE
ASTROS, THAT'S WHERE YOU'RE
CRACKING, LOWER THIRD OF THE
STRIKE ZONE.
MATT: 33-YEAR-OLD GOING TO WORK
ON ALEX BREGMAN.
DROPS IT IN FOR A BASE HIT.
WHAT WAS THAT YOU WERE SAYING
ABOUT BATTING AVERAGE ON THE
FIRST PITCH EARLIER?
GEOFF: THAT'S YOUR BEST CHANCE
TO GET IT AND HE PUT IT IN PLAY.
GETS UP A BASE HIT.
STOLEN BASE AS WELL.
MATT: IS THAT A COINCIDENCE?
IS BREGMAN SOMEONE WHO HAVE
KNOWN THAT INFORMATION COMING IN
TO THE START?
GEOFF: YES, 100%.
THE ASTROS DO A GOOD JOB OF
GETTING THAT INFORMATION TO
THEM.
THE TWO HITTING COACHES ARE VERY
GOOD ABOUT GETTING THAT
INFORMATION TO THOSE GUYS.
MATT: SO BREGMAN IS ABOARD.
AND HERE'S YORDAN ALVAREZ.
2019 A.L. ROOKIE OF THE YEAR.
TWO HOMERS FOR THEM TO START
THIS SEASON.
ALVAREZ ONE OF THE ASTROS BUMMER
SIDELINED WHILE GOING THROUGH
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY PROTOCOLS,
LIMITED TO PINCH HITTING DUTIES
OUT IN DENVER.
AND GOOD HAVE HIM OUT HERE
TONIGHT.
GEOFF: HE REALLY BURST ON TO THE
SCENE WITH SOME PRODIGIOUS
POWER.
HE DID A GREAT JOB OF STRIKES ON
RECOGNITION, GETTING SOME
PITCHES TO DRIVE.
AND WHEN HE BARRELS THEM UP,
THEY HAVE A TENDENCY TO GO A
VERY LONG WAY.
MATT: HOW ABOUT THE COMPANY HE'S
KEEPING ON THIS LIST?
FIRST 100 CAREER GAMES, MOST
EXTRA-BASE HITS.
ONLY JOE DIMAGGIO HAD MORE.
NOBODY RUNS A LOT.
LET'S FACE IT.
FOUR TOTAL BASES, FOUR STOLEN
BASES FOR THE ASTROS, THE ANGELS
WITH FIVE.
TWO OF THE SMALLER TOTALS IN ALL
OF THE GAME.
OUTSIDE OF A FEW INDIVIDUAL
PLAYERS.
RAMON LAUREANO, TIM ANDERSON, I
GUESS WE COULD NAME A COUPLE.
SPLIT, CHANGE.
NO?
OR WAS IT AND CAUGHT TOO MUCH OF
THE PLATE.
FIRST AND THIRD WITH TWO GONE.
WHAT WAS THAT, GUBEY?
GEOFF: WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
NUMBERS THIS YEAR FOR ALVAREZ
VS. SINKER, 0-83.
IT ENDED UP BEING A SPLITTER
GOT TOO MUCH OF THE PLATE.
THAT'S WHY I THOUGHT IT WAS A
FASTBALL.
IT WAS FLAT.
GOOD SWING BY ALVAREZ NOT TRYING
TO PULL THAT.
MATT: TWO OUT MICRO RALLY
DEVELOPING FOR HOUSTON.
NOW, IT'S YULI GURRIEL.
OFF TO THE BEST START OF ANY
HITTER IN 2021.
GEOFF: HE SAID HE PUT ON ABOUT
15, 20 POUNDS.
AND THAT TIME MAY HAVE DONE HIM
GOOD MOVING AROUND WELL GOING
FIRST TO THIRD.
THAT'S A GOOD SIGN FOR ASTRO
FANS.
MATT: THREE BALLS AND NO STRIKES
FOR GURRIEL WHO IS THE ONLY
HITTER THAT HAS WALKED MORE THAN
HE STRUCK OUT TO START THE YEAR.
KYLE TUCKER WAITING NEXT  AND
GURRIEL IN A 3-0 COUNT.
MATT: THE PITCH TO GURRIEL IS
CALLED FOR A STRIKE.
GEOFF: IT'S A PRETTY NASTY COMBO
TO GET BACK IN THIS COUNT.
INSIDE CORNER.
OUTSIDE CORNER.
MATT: WHAT DO WE SEE HERE NEXT,
GUBEY.
PLAY ALONG WITH US?
GEOFF: I'M GOING WITH THE SPLIT.
I'M GOING WITH THE THING RIGHT
HERE.
MATT: LOST HIM WITH ANOTHER
KNUCKLE CURVE.
AND THAT IS LOADED THE BASES.
SO HOW MUCH OF THIS, GUBEY, IS
THE FACT THAT ALEX COBB MISSED
HIS LAST START.
AND IT'S BEEN A GOOD 10 DAYS
SINCE HE'S BEEN OUT THERE?
GEOFF: THE WORST THING YOU CAN
HAVE FOR A SHRINKER BALL PITCHER
IS BE TOO STRONG ON THE MOUND
BECAUSE YOU'RE GOING TO
OVERTHROW.
YOU SEE THE BALLS IN THE UPPER
PART OF THE FASTBALL.
HE FEELS TOO STRONG.
I KNOW IT SOUNDS ODD.
BUT BUT THE STRONGER YOU ARE THE
MORE IT'S GOING TO FLAT  OUT.
MATT: HUGE OPPORTUNITY FOR KYLE
TUCK WHORE IS THE HAPPIEST TO BE
OFF OF THAT DREADFUL TRIP IN
DENVER.
1-16 ON THE RECENTLY COMPLETED
FIVE-GAMER.
HE'S GOT THE BASES LOADED WITH
TWO GONE.
GEOFF: BASEBALL'S AN AMAZING
GAME.
IT WILL PUT YOU IN SPOTS WHEN
YOU'VE BEEN STRUGGLING LIKE THIS
WHEN THE BASES ARE LOADED.
TWO OUTS AND YOUR TEAM NEEDS A
BIG WIN TO GET THINGS GOING BACK
HOME IN THEIR BALLPARK.
MATT: BREGMAN, ALVAREZ AND
TUCKER.
SWUNG ON AND MISSED.
THOSE ARE THE CAREER BASES
LOADED NUMBERS FOR TUCKER.
THIS YEAR, 2-21 WITH RUNNERS IN
SCORING POSITION.
MARK: ALMOST PAT TABBLER FOR
TUCKER.
[LAUGHTER]
MATT: 0-2.
FOR THE UNINITIATED PAT TABBLER
WHO HAD A GOOD CAREER WAS A
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT PLAYER WITH
THE BASES LOADED.
AND I MEAN THAT AS A POSITIVE.
MARK: HE TOLD ME HE WOULD BE A
.500, IF THEY DIDN'T GIVE AN
EARN TO EDGAR MARTINEZ AGAINST
RANDY JOHNSON.
HE WAS THAT GOOD JUST UNDER .500
WITH THE BASES LOADED.
MATT: 0-2 TO TUCKER.
BECAUSE WE'RE SUPER RELIANT ON
TECHNOLOGY WHERE THE THREE OF US
ARE IN ALL DIFFERENT LOCATIONS
ON MY COMPUTER HERE IN THE
STUDIO, MY EYEBALLS TELL ME MORE
KNUCKLE CURVES THAN SPLIT
CHANGES SO FAR FOR ALEX COBB.
GEOFF: SO FAR, YOU'RE EXACTLY
RIGHT ON THAT, SURPRISING.
IT'S A FEEL FOR THEM ON THE
SPLITTER RIGHT NOW, THE THING.
HE'S FRUSTRATED AS HE DELIVERED
THAT ONE WELL OUT OF THE STRIKE
ZONE.
HE WANTS TO MAKE IT TANTALIZING
ENOUGH FOR A HITTER TO CHASE OUT
OF THE STRIKE ZONE.
BUT WHEN IT STARTS THAT LOW,
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO GET CHASES.
MARK: IF IT'S LOW, LET IT GO.
MATT: THERE'S A GOOD ONE.
SO THE STRIKEOUT GETS HIM OUT OF
A BASES LOADED TWO-OUT JAM.
WE GO TO THE SECOND SCORELESS IN
HOUSTON.
MATT: WE OFFER A MULTIPLE CHOICE
QUESTION POSED IN LIVE GAME
COMMENTARY.
STAY TUNED AS THE RESULTS WILL
BE REVEALED AND DISCUSSED
LAETTNER THE BROADCAST AND WE'VE
GOT OUR FIRST POLL QUESTION TO
KIND OF GET YOU GOING HERE
TONIGHT.
AND I THINK -- I THINK I COULD
GUESS ON SOME OF THE RESPONSES
HERE.
WHO'S THE MOST EXCITING PLAYER
NOT NAMED MIKE TROUT?
OHTANI?
ACUNA?
TATIS?
BETTS?
I'M JUST DISAPPOINTED THERE'S NO
PLACE TO FILL IN MY OWN RESPONSE
BECAUSE ALEJANDRO KIRK IS MY
GUY.
THE PLAY MOOKIE BETTS MADE TO IN
THE GAME AGAINST THE PADRES THE
OTHER DAY IN SAN DIEGO WAS
UNBELIEVABLE.
>> MOOKIE IS PRETTY UNBELIEVABLE
WITH HIS ABILITY TO MAKE -- HE
MADE A COUPLE OF PLAYS IN THE
WORLD SERIES LAST YEAR TO HELP
WIN BALLGAMES, BUT THAT WAS A
HECK OF A WAY TO FINISH THINGS
OFF.
>> HERE'S ALBERT PUJOLS.
AND ALBERT SIGNS A HIGH FLY BALL
FOUL.
SOME OF HIS GREATEST CONQUESTS
ALONG THE COURSE OF HIS 21 YEAR
HALL OF FAME CAREER RIGHT HERE
IN THIS BUILDING, AND I DO NOT
MEAN TO SALT UP OLD WOUNDS, BUT
I AM NOT SURE BRAD LYNCH HAS
GOTTEN A CLEAN NIGHT SLEEP SINCE
THEN.
>> NO, THAT HOME RUN HE GAVE UP
TO ALBERT PUJOLS IN THE
CHAMPIONSHIP SERIES IN 2005, I
THINK THEY HAD TO REPLACE THE
PLEXIGLAS OVER THE RAILROAD
TRACKS.
BUT THAT HOME RUN HAS LEFT AN
INDELIBLE MARK,
WATCHING ALBERT PUJOLS OVER THE
YEARS.
>> A BALL AND TWO STRIKES, THE
COUNT TUPLES.
>> I BET -- IN HIS LAST SERIES,
HE PICKED UP A STOLEN BASE, THE
115TH OF HIS CAREER, THEN HE
HITS HIS 664TH CAREER HOME RUN.
>> DID I SEE SOMEPLACE WHERE
THAT MADE HIM THE OLDEST PLAYER
TO EVER STEAL THIRD?
>> TWO GONE AND FIVE STRIKEOUTS
FOR CRISTIAN JAVIER.
>> I AM NOT SURE WHAT IS GOING
ON AT THAT ALTERNATE SITE.
>> DOESN'T THAT SOUND CREEPY,
MYSTERIOUS?
IT SOUNDS LIKE THEY ARE TESTING
A NUCLEAR REACTOR SOMEPLACE AWAY
FROM THE WATCHFUL EYE OF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
ALTERNATE SITE.
COULD NOT DO ANY BETTER THAN
THAT.
[LAUGHTER]
>> WAIT FOR A "STRANGER THINGS"
EPISODE TO START.
>> BOY, CRISTIAN JAVIER HAS
EVERY PITCH WORKING TONIGHT.
IT IS A BALL AND A STRIKE TO
JOSÉ IGLESIAS.
THIS IS THE BABY OF THE ROTATION
AT THE AGE OF 24.
AND A GUY THAT WAS ONLY PRESSED
INTO DUTY LAST YEAR BECAUSE
JUSTIN VERLANDER BECAME
UNAVAILABLE.
>> LAST YEAR WAS INTERESTING FOR
THE ASTROS PITCHING STAFF.
A LOT OF GUYS MAKING THEIR MAJOR
LEAGUE DEBUTS.
TO YOUR POINT, CRISTIAN JAVIER
ENDED UP IN THIRD PLACE IN
ROOKIE OF THE YEAR VOTING.
THAT DISAPPEARING FAST WHILE
UPSTAIRS.
IT LOOKS LIKE HE HIT IT, BUT IT
IS BY YOU.
>> THE 1-2 TO IGLESIAS.
BY THE WAY, I WAS JUST SENT A
TWEET.
MATT BIRCH BY THE ANGELS PR
STAFF WAS QUICK TO REMIND ME
THAT ICHIRO STOLE THIRD AT THE
AGE OF 42.
A YEAR OLDER THAN ALBERT WHEN HE
DID IT THIS WEEK.
WE JUST GOT TO MAKE SURE WE
CLEAN THAT STUFF UP.
THANKS, MATT.
>> YOU CAN NEVER DOUBT MATTIE
BIRCH.
HE HAS THE SIDE INFORMATION.
>> TWO BALLS AND TWO STRIKES TO
JOSÉ IGLESIAS.
IS HE IN SWING MODE OR WHAT?
MAN.
HIT OVER .370 LAST YEAR, A SHORT
SPRING WITH THE ORIOLES.
HAD A GREAT SEASON.
10 YEAR VET.
CAREER HIGHS LAST YEAR IN
BATTING, ON BASE, SLUGGING.
CELEBRATED HIS FIRST HOMER AS AN
ANGEL YESTERDAY.
THE ANGELS HOMERED FOUR
TIMES, BUT STILL LOST.
MIXING AND A GROUND OUT, DUDE.
BALLSTRIKEOUT.
-- BALL SIX VIA THE SWINGING
STRIKEOUT.
>> AND TROUT GETS A HOLD OF ONE
AND OF THE CORNER IN LEFT, AND
HE GOT IT!
THEY TO RUN SHOT FOR TROUT.
GOT HIM.
REGISTERING ANOTHER PUNCH OUT
FOR ALEX COBB.
>> THE 1-1 TO OHTANI.
THAT IS HIT INTO THE CORNER.
THAT WILL RATTLE AROUND AND
CLEAR THE BASES.
>> SHOHEI TAPS THAT ONE BACK UP
THE MIDDLE.
OVERLOAD.
HE BEATS IT OUT.
ONE BASE RUNNER ON THE TWO-OUT
WALK.
DID SHOHEI GET HIM?
GET GOING TO WRITE, AND GONE!
-- GET GOING TO RIGHT, AND GONE!
ANOTHER ROCKET OFF OHTANI'S BAT.
>> AN INCREDIBLE SWING FIRST
SHOHEI OHTANI, A THREE-HIT
PERFORMANCE.
EVERYTHING HAS BEEN HIT HARD.
>> THERE IS A BALL BLASTED OUT
INTO LEFT FIELD.
IT IS OUT OF HERE!
HE DID BUST THE GAME WIDE OPEN.
IT IS A GRAND SLAM, AND NOW IT
IS 9-3 ANGELS.
>> HE KNEW IT WAS GONE, IT WAS
JUST A MATTER OF HOW FAR IT WAS
GONE.
>> BACK FOR THE BOTTOM OF THE
SECOND INNING, NO SCORE IN
HOUSTON.
DUSTY BAKER CREEPING UP ON THE
1900 WIN CLUB.
HE IS ON THE DOORSTEP.
ONCE HE GETS INTO THE ROOM, HE
WILL FIND THE LIKES OF BOBBY
COX, WALTER ALSTON, SPARKY, JOHN
MCGRAW, ALMOST 3000 WINS AS A
MANAGER.
BOCH.
SERVING THEM UP AT THE BAR,
RICKY HARRIS, JOE MCCARTHY, AND
TONY MARISSA.
THAT IS AN EXCLUSIVE CLUB,
GENTLEMEN.
>> AND TAKING ALL OF HIS TEAMS
TO THE POSTSEASON.
>> HOOKS A BALL TO LEFT FIELD
AND THAT WILL POUND UP AGAINST
THE CORNER.
THE FIRST HIT OF THE NIGHT!
AND IT DIAZ IS ABLE TO STAY ON
THE BAG!
WHAT THE MARY LOU RUTTEN IS
GOING --WHAT THE MARY LOU RETTON
IS GOING ON OUT THERE?
>> SHE IS LOCAL.
I AM NOT SURE IF SHE IS STILL
GIVING OUT LESSONS, BUT THAT WAS
A DRAMATIC SLIDE INTO THIRD.
THE SHORT PORCH IN MINUTE MAID
PARK HERE CREATES SOME
INTERESTING PLAYS, BUT THAT
LOOKED LIKE IT HURT.
>> THAT IS RIGHT THERE.
THAT IS TOP OF THE FILE FOR WHY
YOU HAVE TO STRETCH TO PLAY PRO
SPORTS, KID.
YOU ARE GOING TO TEAR A GROIN OR
SOMETHING IF YOU ARE NOT READY
FOR THAT PLAY.
AND HERE IS MYLES STRAW NOW.
>> IF THAT WAS A UFC FIGHT, I AM
TAPPING OUT AFTER THAT SLIDE.
I AM DONE.
>> [LAUGHTER]
>> STRAW THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
KID WHO HAS A BIG OPPORTUNITY TO
PLAY EVERY DAY IN HOUSTON.
FASTBALLS IN FOR A STRIKE.
IT IS WORTH LOOKING AT THAT
AGAIN.
>> DID A GOOD JOB STAYING DOWN
ON THE PITCH AND YANKING IT INTO
THE CORNER.
RIGHT HERE, HE REALIZES HE HAS
TO TURN IT ON.
THERE WAS A COLLECTIVE GROAN
BETWEEN THE THREE OF US WHEN
THAT HAPPENS.
MYLES DID NOT PLAY
YESTERDAY AND WAS SLOW TO
RESPOND TO EVERYDAY OPPORTUNITY.
A WORLD OF TALENT.
THE ASTROS LOVED HIM.
THEY WOULD HAVE GIVEN HIM THE
KEYS TO THE JOB IN THE GEORGE
SPRINGER-LESS DAYS THAT ENSUED
IF THEY HAD NOT BEEN FANS OF
MYLES STRAW.
HE WANTS HIM TO BE MORE
AGGRESSIVE AT THE PLATE.
>> THAT WAS WHAT WAS
INTERESTING.
WHEN SPRING TRAINING BEGAN FOR
THE ASTROS.
HAVING A GUY LIKE MYLES STRAW,
HE FITS MORE OF THE TRADITIONAL
THE OFF MAN MENTALITY, WHERE HE
TAKES PITCHES, GET ON BASE,
CREATE HAVOC WITH HIS SPEED.
IT HAS BEEN TOUGH GOING BECAUSE
HE HAS BEEN MORE PASSIVE.
DUSTY HAVING THE HEART-TO-HEART
SHOULD HELP MYLES STRAW CALM
DOWN A BIT.
ONE THING THAT HE HAS NOT DONE
IS LAID DOWN THAT BUNT IN
CERTAIN SITUATIONS.
THAT MIGHT BE SOMETHING HE HAS
TO WORK ON BECAUSE IT MIGHT BE A
VALUABLE WEAPON TO GET HIM ON
BASE.
>> TWO BALLS AND TWO STRIKES.
SHARPLY HIT PAST THE THIRD
BASEMAN.
ROJAS INTO THE CORNER.
THAT WILL GET DIAZ AROUND TO
SCORE.
MYLES STRAW DRIVING IN THE FIRST
RUN OF THE NIGHT, AND IT IS 1-0
ASTROS.
A BALL INTO THE SHORT LEFT-FIELD
CORNER, THEN HE TURNS IT INTO A
TRIPLE.
>> THAT SPEED ON DISPLAY.
ONE OF THE MOST DIFFICULT THINGS
IS A SINKERBALL PITCHER WITH A
MAN ON SECOND AND NO OUTS,
GETTING AN OUT OTHER THAN A
GROUND BALL.
6% OF THE TIME IT GETS UP BY
ROJAS AND INTO THE CORNER.
YOU CAN SEE THE WHEELS ON
DISPLAY BY MYLES STRAW.
>> THAT IS ALSO A VERY GOOD VIEW
FROM BEHIND HOME PLATE.
THAT WAS A LONG WAY FOR JUSTIN
UPTON TO GO TO GET THAT BALL
INTO THE CORNER BECAUSE TO BE
HONEST ABOUT MYLES STRAW, HE
GOES THE OTHER WAY A LOT OF THE
TIME.
HE RARELY TURNS ON THE BALL, SO
IT WAS A TOUGH PLAY FOR JUSTIN
UPTON TO GET ALL THE WAY INTO
THE OWNER.
>> HERE IS MARTIN MALDONADO.
CHANCE FOR A FLY BALL TO MAKE IT
2-0 ASTROS EARLY.
A COUPLE OF CURVEBALLS HAVE HIM
CHASING.
MALDONADO RE-UPPING A CONTRACT
EXTENSION FOR HIM, JUST
ANNOUNCED THIS WEEK.
HAS ALWAYS BEEN REGARDED AS ONE
OF THE BETTER PITCH HANDLERS.
HE CHASES FOR A STRIKEOUT.
THREE STRAIGHT KNUCKLE CURVES.
HE HAD THE BEST CHASE PERCENTAGE
.
HE HAD A MOST 50%.
HE STARTS CURRY A WITH A
CURVEBALL -- HE STARTS CORREA
WITH A CURVEBALL FOR A STRIKE.
THIS IS A GUY WHO HAS BEEN
THROUGH A LOT PHYSICALLY ALONG
THE COURSE OF HIS DECADE-LONG
CAREER.
A BETTER FASTBALL, BETTER
COMMAND OF HIS SPLITTER, AND IT
SAME THING WITH HIS KNUCKLE
CURVE.
>> HAS HE ALWAYS BEEN A GUY THAT
STARTED ON THE FIRST-BASE SIDE
OF THE RUBBER?
HE REALLY STRIDES TOWARD THE
RIGHT-HANDED HITTER AND CRATES
THE CROSSFIRE.
HE MIGHT CREATE MORE DECEPTION.
>> PART OF WHY HE DOES THAT IS
TO MAKE SURE HE GETS INSIDE.
HE HAS BEEN REALLY EFFECTIVE
AGAINST LEFT-HANDED BATTERS,
MORE SO THAN RIGHTIES.
>> TWO BALLS AND TWO STRIKES TO
CORREA.
>> HE HAS TO MAKE SURE HE CAN
RUN THE FASTBALL TO CATCH THE
INSIDE CORNER.
>> A GROUND BALL THAT TRICKLES
THROUGH THE INFIELD AND WILL
ALLOW STRAW TO SCHEDULE EASY --
TO SCORE EASILY.
THAT WAS ACCOUNT THAT GOT AWAY
FROM COBB.
GOT TO A FASTBALL ON 2-2.
THAT MADE CORREA'S JOB A LITTLE
EASIER.
>> YOU WILL SEE THAT SUZUKI'S
SET UP ON THE INSIDE, AND THIS
BALL TAILED ON THE OTHER SIDE.
YOU TALK ABOUT THE LOW STRIKEOUT
NUMBERS.
THEY TRY TO FIGHT THOSE COUNTS
AND IT PAYS OFF.
>> R.B.I. FOR CORREA, HIS EIGHTH
OF THE YEAR.
HERE IS MICHAEL BRANTLEY NOW.
THE LITTLE TWEAK ATOP THE LINEUP
CARD.
SO FAR, SO GOOD FOR DUSTY BAKER.
CHAIRS THAT IS ROTATED?
>> KNOWING THAT DUSTY IS
APPROACHING MILESTONES WITH THE
WINS, IF THEY END UP WINNING
THIS BALLGAME AND CARLOS CORREA
IS ON DECK A COUPLE TIMES
DRIVING RUNNERS IN, IT LOOKS
LIKE THE OFFENSE IS PICKING UP.
I DON'T THINK HE WOULD MOVE HIM
UNTIL ALTUVE CAME BACK, TO BE
HONEST WITH YOU.
>> THIS APPLIES LEGAL WIDE.
-- THIS APPLIES LEGAL WIDE.
THE GUY WHO GOT ON BASE AND RAN,
YOU COULD NAME THEM ON ONE HAND.
>> THE REASON WHY HE HAS AN
EXTRA AT-BAT IN THE LEADOFF
SPOT.
YOU ARE ONLY A LEADOFF MAN THE
FIRST INNING.
OTHER THAN THAT, YOU HAVE THE
CHANCE TO DRIVE IN RUNS  AND
GET AN EXTRA AT-BAT.
>> TWO BALLS AND A STRIKE, THE
COUNT TO MICHAEL BRADLEY.
CARLOS CORREA DOES NOT HAVE A
STOLEN BASE ATTEMPT THIS YEAR.
I ALSO GET THE RISK-REWARD OF
THE STOLEN BASE.
I UNDERSTAND WHY MIKE TROUT DOES
NOT RUN AS OFTEN.
I UNDERSTAND WHY A GUY LIKE
CARLOS WOULD NOT RUN OFTEN.
THE INJURY RISK IS TOO GREAT TO
IGNORE SOMETIMES.
>> THE BASE RUNNERS ARE DOING
THE BEST THEY CAN TO AVOID SOME
OF THOSE INJURIES YOU ARE
TALKING ABOUT.
A LOT OF THESE GUYS ARE GOING
OUT THERE WITH THE OVEN MITT
APPROACH.
>> A CURVEBALL IN FOR A STRIKE.
2-2.
MICHAEL BRANTLEY, OF COURSE,
RETURNING TO HOUSTON ON A
TWO-YEAR FREE AGENT CONTRACT
THIS YEAR AFTER A HEAVY
COURTSHIP FROM THE TORONTO BLUE
JAYS, WHEN MANY PEOPLE THOUGHT
HE WOULD JOIN GEORGE.
COBB STRIKES HIM OUT.
THAT IS THREE FOR ALEX COBB
TONIGHT.
DO YOU WANT TO KNOW WHAT IT IS
LIKE TO BE A ROOKIE IN THE BIG
LEAGUES?
JOIN THE ORIOLES FOR A
BEHIND-THE-SCENES JOURNEY ON
YOUTUBE.COM/MLB.
TWO RUNS IN, TWO GONE WITH A
RUNNER AT FIRST FOR ALEX
BREGMAN, WHO SINGLED BACK IN THE
FIRST.
AND THAT ONE GOT HIM.
COBB CAME IN WITH THE FASTBALL,
GOT HIM ON THE ELBOW.
>> A COUPLE THINGS ON THAT PITCH
RIGHT THERE FOR ALEX COBB,
STROM DROPS HIS WRIST.
IT WILL HAVE SINK ACTION.
THAT IS WHY HE WAS HIT.
RIGHT ON THE ELBOW AREA.
>> DID THAT GET HIM ABOVE THE
PAD?
>> IT MAY HAVE.
I HOPE IT DIDN'T.
BUT ALEX COBB THREW THE SAME
PITCH THAT ALEX GOT A HIT ON IN
THAT FIRST AT-BAT.
THEY WERE TRYING TO DO THE SAME
THING THEY DID IN THE FIRST
AT-BAT.
BUT IT JUST GOT AWAY FROM HIM.
>> HERE IS YORDAN ALVAREZ.
THE ANGELS OVERLOAD THE RIGHT
SIDE.
TWO RUNS IN.
IT SOUNDED LIKE IT HIT THE PAD
THE FIRST PASS WE TOOK.
AND ALVAREZ SLICES THAT ONE OUT
OF PLAY.
>> YOU GO BACK TO THIS INNING,
MYLES STRAW WITH HIS SPEED
CREATED A COUPLE RUNS.
HE HITS A GROUND BALL DOWN THE
LINE, GETS A TRIPLE.
HE WAS THINKING, I HAVE TO BE
QUICK TO THE PLATE WITH THE
SPEED OF MYLES STRAW, UNABLE TO
MAKE THE PLAY ON THE GROUND OR
BY CORREA.
TWO RUNS SCORE BECAUSE OF THE
SPEED BY MYLES STRAW.
>> TWO BALLS AND A STRIKE.
MOST R.B.I.'S IN HIS FIRST 100
CAREER GAMES.
DROVE100 SIX RUNS IN HIS FIRST 0
GAMES.
YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT SOME
HISTORICAL FIGURES THERE.
THE ONLY CONTEMPORARY NAME ON
THE LIST IS THE GUY AT THE
PLATE.
2-2.
>> I HAD NO IDEA YORDAN ALVAREZ
WAS GOING TO ALLOW FOR SO MANY
REFERENCES IN MY LIFE.
>> THAT'S A GOOD POINT.
HONORING KNOW THAT -- I DON'T
KNOW THAT WALT WOULD HAVE COME
UP TONIGHT IF IT WEREN'T FOR
ALVAREZ.
>> I THINK WALT GOT ALL OF HIS
R.B.I.'S IN THE FIRST THREE
YEARS OF HIS CAREER.
THERE WAS A DRASTIC DROP OFF
AFTER THAT.
>> RAN THAT FASTBALL IN ON THE
BIG LEFT-HANDED BATTER AND NOW
IT'S A FULL COUNT, 3-2.
PLAY THE GUESSING GAME, WHAT
DOES HE THROW ON THE FULL COUNT?
>> YOU GO DOWN AND AWAY.
>> 3-2, WENT BACK UP THERE WITH
THE FASTBALL AND LOST HIM.
THAT LOADS THE BASES FOR THE
SECOND TIME IN AS MANY INNINGS.
I'M SURPRISE, I WAS WITH YOU, I
THOUGHT HE HAD HIM ALL SET UP
FOR THE SPLIT CHANGE.
HERE COMES COACH MATT WISE.
>> IF IT LEAKS OUT OVER THE
PLATE AT ALL, YOU'RE GOING TO
RUN INTO SOME PROBLEMS.
SPLITTER DOWN AND AWAY, YOU
COULD HIT A GROUNDBALL AND MAKE
IT AWAY.
THE FASTBALL STAYS OUT OVER THE
PLATE.
>> BIG PLATE APPEARANCE FOR YULI
GURRIEL.
THE ASTROS WOULD LOVE TO TAKE
FURTHER ADVANTAGE OF WHAT HAS
BEEN AN INNING WHERE THERE ARE
RUNNERS ON BASE THROUGHOUT.
CASHED IN FOR TWO OF THEM, BASES
LOADED WITH TWO ON.
GURRIEL WALKED IN THE FIRST.
ALONG WITH CARLOS CORREA, EIGHT
R.B.I.'S EARLY ON TO FACE THE
TEAM.
AND A GUY THAT HAS BEEN A REAL
HORSE WITH THE BASES LOADED.
A NEAR 500 HITTER.
TAKES A STRIKE.
IN FACT HE'S EXACTLY .500.
21 FOR 42 WITH THE BASES LOADED.
HIS TWO RUN HOMER YESTERDAY,
HOUSTON'S ONLY HOME RUN IN THEIR
LAST FIVE GAMES.
AND HE'S BEHIND 0-2.
TAKE YOU BACK TO THE SNOWY DAY
IN DENVER.
>> THE ONE TIME THIS ENTIRE
SEASON I WAS GLAD WE WEREN'T
TRAVELING.
THE CURVEBALL FROM GOMBER DROVE
IT OUT TO LEFT CENTER FIELD.
THAT WAS PRETTY MUCH THE MOST
EXCITEMENT THOSE GUYS HAD, OTHER
THAN MAYBE WATCHING SNOWFALL FOR
THE FIRST TIMES IN THEIR LIVES.
>> DUSTY BAKER TELLING US BEFORE
THE GAME TODAY, 60 YEARS IN
PROFESSIONAL BASEBALL AND HE HAD
NEVER PARTICIPATED IN A GAME IN
THE SNOW, WHICH WE ALL FOUND
KIND OF HARD TO BELIEVE FOR A
GUY THAT YOU WOULD THINK HAD
BEEN PART OF EVERY CIRCUMSTANCE
IMAGINABLE.
>> THAT ONE GOT ME.
DUSTY BAKER HAS SEEN SEVERAL
DECADES OF BASEBALL, AND TO HEAR
THAT SHOCKED ME A LITTLE BIT.
>> TO STRIKE COUNT REMAINS TO
YULI GURRIEL.
A BALL INTO STRIKES NOW.
>> AS A PITCHER, GURRIEL IS YOUR
WORST NIGHTMARE WITH THE BASES
LOADED BECAUSE HE CAN HIT THE
BALL TO ALL FIELDS.
HE CAN HIT OFF-SPEED PITCHES AND
PASSED BALLS WELL.
HE HAS DONE A TON OF DAMAGE
AGAINST THE ANGELS IN HIS
CAREER.
>> THAT BALL WASN'T EVEN IN THE
STRIKE ZONE AND YANKED JUST
FOUL.
THAT'S SIX INCHES OFF THE INSIDE
CORNER.
>> HE DOES SUCH AN AMAZING JOB.
>> TO YOUR POINT, WHERE DO YOU
GO TO GET HIM OUT?
>> THE OLD ROD CAREW SCOUTING
REPORT, THROW IT RIGHT DOWN THE
MIDDLE, LET HIM HIT A LINE DRIVE
TO SOMEBODY.
HE DOES A GREAT JOB OF PULLING
THAT KNOB OF THE BAT THROUGH SO
EARLY IN THERE SO MUCH LAG ON
THE BAT THAT IT CREATES ALL
KINDS OF COVERAGE.
HE IS NOT A VERY DISCRIMINANT
HITTER WHEN HE'S GOT R.B.I.'S
OUT THERE.
>> COBB SHOOK SUZUKI OFF TO GET
TO THAT FASTBALL AND JUST MISSED
HIS SPOT.
SO NOW IT'S 2-2.
IT'S BEEN A 35 PITCH INNING FOR
ALEX COBB AND IT HAS NOT BEEN
THE BREEZY RESULTS HE HAD 10
DAYS AGO IN KANSAS CITY WHEN HE
STRUCK OUT 10 AGAINST THE
ROYALS.
2-2.
EASY TAKE FOR GURRIEL ON THE
CHANGE.
A DOUBLE, TRIPLE, A SINGLE AND A
WALK THIS INNING.
BASES LOADED.
3-2 PITCH, AND HE JUST MISSED
WITH THE SPLIT CHANGE.
DIDN'T MISS BY MUCH.
AND R.B.I. FOR GURRIEL, HIS TEAM
LEADING, 3-0 ASTROS.
>> I'LL TELL YOU WHAT, GUYS.
IT'S BEEN REALLY IMPRESSIVE TO
WATCH YULI THIS SEASON.
HE'S NOT TYPICALLY A GUY WHO IS
GOING TO LAY OUT PITCHES OUT OF
THE ZONE.
IN THE PAST HE HASN'T BEEN A GUY
THAT'S BEEN ON TYPE GUY.
AS USUALLY GUY THAT SWINGS HIS
WAY ONTO THE BASE BUT NOW THE
SEASON WITH TWO WALKS, 15 ON THE
SEASON, IT RARITIES FOR GURRIEL.
>> HE HAS ALREADY WALKS MORE
THAN HE DID LAST SEASON.
12 WALKS ALL OF LAST YEAR, 15
THIS SEASON AND AGAIN, THE ONLY
ASTRO THAT HAS WALKED MORE THAN
HE'S STRUCK OUT.
A BALL AND NO STRIKES TO KYLE
TUCKER.
TRYING TO GET OUT OF ANOTHER
BASES-LOADED JAM.
FASTBALL IN FOR A STRIKE.
>> A SHORT LITTLE STRIDE, HE WAS
LOOKING TO MAKE SOME CONTACT.
HE WASN'T THINKING GRAND SLAM,
HE WAS THINKING MIDDLE OF THE
FIELD AND MAKING CONTACT.
>> TWO BALLS AND A STRIKE.
AND ASTROS TEAM THAT IS AMONG
THE MOST DISCIPLINED AND
BASEBALL.
FEWER STRIKEOUTS IN THE AMERICAN
LEAGUE AT THE START OF PLAY.
THERE HAVE BEEN EASY TAKES LIKE
THAT AND THERE HAVE BEEN SOME
BORDERLINE PITCHES THAT THEY'VE
BEEN UP TO STAY AWAY FROM THAT
HAS HELPED MOVE THE LINE IN THIS
THREE RUN INNING.
NOW MATT WISE IS ON THE PHONE
WITH THE BULLPEN.
THREE BALLS AND A STRIKE TO
TUCKER.
AND THAT'S LINED INTO SHALLOW
RIGHT WHERE FLETCHER HAD IT
PLAYED PERFECTLY TO AVOID ANY
FURTHER DAMAGE.
THE ASTROS DO CRACK THE
SCOREBOARD FOR THREE IN THE
SECOND.
A LONG INNING FOR HOUSTON.
RESULTS IN THREE BIG RUNS.
ARLY.
A REALLY COOL MOMENT HERE, A LOT
OF THE FANS WERE STANDING IN
SHOWING THEIR APPRECIATION FOR
THE TIMES WHEN A.J. WAS THE
MANAGER.
I KNOW IT HAD TO BE AN EMOTIONAL
TIME FOR HIM.
RONNIE DAWSON, A FIST PUMP AS HE
HEADS DOWN THE LINE.
RONNIE DAWSON, CONGRATULATIONS,
HIS FIRST MAJOR LEAGUE HIT
LEADING OFF THE SEVENTH INNING
WITH A CLEAN SINGLE TO LEFT.
>> ON THE GROUND, RIGHT SIDE.
THAT'S A BASE HIT.
THE THROW WIDE AT THIRD.
HERE COMES TAYLOR JONES.
NO SCORE.
>> FIRST MAJOR LEAGUE HIT.
A SINGLE AND AND R.B.I..
>> MCCORMICK RIPS ONE TO LEFT
CENTER FIELD.
THAT BALL IS DOWN AND ALL THE
WAY TO THE WALL.
CHAZ MCCORMICK INTO SECOND BASE
WITH AN R.B.I. DOUBLE.
3-0 ASTROS.
>> THROWS TO FIRST AND THE
INNING IS OVER.
EIGHT SHUTOUT INNINGS FOR ZACK
GREINKE.
>> WELCOME BACK, 3-0 ASTROS.
TOP HALF OF THE THIRD.
EARLIER WE HAD OUR MOST EXCITING
PLAYER NOT NAMED MIKE TROUT
PLAYER POLE AND SHOHEI OHTANI
WINS IT IN A LINE -- LANDSLIDE
WITH MORE THAN 50% OF THE VOTE.
WE'LL HAVE ANOTHER POLL QUESTION
COMING UP A LITTLE LATER ON.
WE WELCOME DYLAN BUNDY TO THE
TELECAST.
HAVE YOU EVER PLAYED WITH THE
GUY EVEN REMOTELY AS SKILLED AND
INTERESTING AS SHOHEI OHTANI?
DYLAN: I'M GOING TO SAY NO, I
HAVEN'T.
THERE'S NOT ANYBODY ELSE IN THE
GAME THAT DOES THAT.
>> A BALL INTO THE OPPOSITE
FIELD FROM JOSÉ ROJAS.
ROJAS GETS THAT ONE OFF THE TOP
OF THE WALL.
INCHES AWAY FROM HIS FIRST
BIG-LEAGUE HOMER.
>> I REALLY THOUGHT THAT BALL
WAS GOING.
>> I THINK HE DID, TOO.
TAKING ANOTHER LOOK AT THE
REPLAY HERE AND HOW FAR UP ON
THE WALL DID IT GO.
HIT THAT BIG GARAGE DOOR.
SO ROJAS HAPPY WITH A LEADOFF
DOUBLE.
CONGRATS ON A GREAT START TO THE
SEASON, MAN.
TELL US ABOUT HOW YOU ARE
FEELING.
TELL US ABOUT THE WEIRD LAYOFF,
GETTING THAT SERIES CANCELED
AGAINST THE TWINS.
GIVE US THE REPORT CARD.
DYLAN: IT'S BEEN KIND OF A WEIRD
START TO THE SEASON.
SEEMS LIKE WE HAD A LOT OF OFF
DAYS AND RAINOUTS AND THE
WEATHER DOWN IN DUNEDIN,
FLORIDA.
DID NOT CANCEL WITH THE TWINS.
SO IT'S DEFINITELY WEIRD.
BUT WE ARE DOING THE BEST WE CAN
AND TRYING TO WIN BALL GAMES.
>> TALK ABOUT THE COMFORT YOU'VE
HAD WEARING AN ANGELS UNIFORM,
GOING OUT THERE TO ATTACK AND
THE STRIKE ZONE NEVER GOOD START
THIS YEAR.
-- ANOTHER GOOD START THIS YEAR.
DYLAN: I DON'T KNOW, I MEAN I
GET ALONG WITH EVERYBODY HERE.
WE HAVE GOOD CHEMISTRY IN THE
CLUBHOUSE WITH THESE GUYS WE
HAVE HERE.
GOOD STAFF.
YOU REALLY CAN'T ASK FOR MUCH.
NEW DIVISION, STILL TRYING TO
GET TO KNOW ALL THE TEAMS IN
THIS DIVISION NOW.
ALWAYS LEARNING AS A PITCHER,
DEFINITELY.
>> DYLAN, I THOUGHT ROJAS HIT
THAT BALL OUT OF HERE.
I'M KIND OF CURIOUS, WHEN YOU
COME INTO A BALLPARK LIKE MINUTE
MAID PARK WHERE THE DIMENSIONS
ARE SO UNIQUE, DO YOU HAVE TO
ALTER YOUR GAME PLANNING WHEN
YOU COME IN HERE AND FACE THIS
TEAM?
DEFTLY: DEFINITELY DON'T DO
THAT.
YOU STICK TO THE GAME PLAN,
WHETHER IT'S READING THEIR
SWINGS OR KIND OF THE GAME PLAN
YOU WANT TO ATTACK WITH THE
OFFSPEED FASTBALLS OR WHATEVER
IT MAY BE.
I DON'T THINK YOU CHANGE BASED
ON BALLPARK DIMENSIONS.
OR THE SHAPE OF IT.
>> KURT SUZUKI POPS ONE UP
BEHIND THE PLATE AND THAT WILL
BE OUT OF PLAY.
DYLAN, YOU ARE SCHEDULED ON
SUNDAY.
IF YOU ARE THE LAST GUY TO PITCH
IN A LONG SERIES LIKE THIS ONE,
WHAT ARE YOUR OFF DAYS LIKE?
ARE YOU LOOKING AT VIDEO?
WHAT TO DO BEFORE GAMES LEADING
UP TO YOUR START DATE?
DYLAN: THIS IS MY THIRD DAY
AFTER MY LAST START.
BULLPEN JUST TO KIND OF FEEL OUT
SOME THINGS AND WORK ON A FEW
THINGS, AND THEN JUST CATCH
TOMORROW, RECOVERY, SAME THING
THE FOLLOWING DAY, GET READY FOR
YOUR START ON SUNDAY.
>> SUZUKI SINCE ONE INTO THE
CORNER AND JUST FILED.
IT IS DECEIVING, WE ARE IN THE
STUDIO SO WE CAN'T TELL WHAT IS
GOING ON.
YOU'VE GOT A BETTER VIEW THAN WE
DO.
>> MAYBE WE SHOULD LET HIM GIVE
YOU SOME PLAY-BY-PLAY.
>> IT WOULD BE BETTER THAN MINE
ALREADY.
HERE'S A QUESTION FOR YOU, DO
YOU BUY INTO THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE ROOF OPEN AND THE
ROOF CLOSED AT A PLACE LIKE
THIS, OR DO YOU NOT EVEN CARE?
DYLAN: I DON'T READ TOO MUCH
INTO IT, BUT I'VE HEARD THOSE
THINGS LIKE TORONTO, DOES THE
BALL CARRY MORE?
I'M SURE IT HAS AN EFFECT,
DEPENDING ON HOW MUCH OR WHICH
WAY THE WIND IS BLOWING OR HOW
IT COMES INTO THE STADIUM, I
GUESS.
I THINK YOU WOULD HAVE TO BE THE
HOME TEAM TO KNOW WHAT IT DOES
EXACTLY.
>> DID YOU SEE THAT GUY, THE DO
JUST ABSOLUTELY BIT IT.
THERE IS PARTIAL ATTENDANCE ALL
AROUND MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL, SO
WHEN A GUY FALLS THAT
SPECTACULARLY, WE SEE IT
CLEARLY.
YOU ARE GOING TO LOVE THIS IF
YOU CAN SEE IT AGAIN.
A BALL INTO STRIKES, THE COUNT
TO KURT SUZUKI.
WE ARE GOING TO TAKE A LOOK AT
IT AGAIN, SO BEAR WITH US.
CHECK THIS DUDE OUT.
>> I'VE GOT THE NUMBER FOUR A
GOOD SPINE SPECIALIST IN TOWN.
HE IS FINE.
WALK IT OFF.
>> KEPT IT IN FRONT OF HIM,
THOUGH.
>> STILL A BALL INTO STRIKES ON
KURT SUZUKI AS WE CONTINUE
VISITING WITH ANGELS
RIGHT-HANDER DYLAN BUNDY.
BECAUSE WE ARE ON YOUTUBE
TONIGHT AND HAVING A GOOD TIME
WITH THIS, WE'VE ASKED A LOT OF
PEOPLE, INCLUDING YOUR MANAGER,
WE WILL ASK YOU THE SAME THING.
WHAT WAS THE LAST INSTRUCTIONAL
VIDEO THAT YOU LOOKED AT ON
YOUTUBE TO LEARN HOW TO DO
SOMETHING?
DYLAN: THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION.
INSTRUCTIONAL?
MAYBE ABOUT AN ELECTRIC BIKE,
MAYBE?
I DON'T KNOW.
>> TO RIDE IT, TO BUILD IT?
DYLAN: JUST HOW TO WORK IT AND
HOW THE BATTERY WORKS, STUFF
LIKE THAT I GUESS.
I BOUGHT AN ELECTRIC BIKE.
>> WE THOUGHT IT WAS GOING TO BE
A HUNTING OR FISHING VIDEO AND
WE WERE WRONG ABOUT THAT.
>> IT'S GOT LIKE REALLY FAT
TIRES ON IT.
>> HE'S ON HIM, JUST CAN'T GET
IT TO DROP INTO FAIR TERRITORY.
>> DYLAN, HOW IS IT TO THROW TO
KURT SUZUKI BEHIND A PLAY?
HE'S ALWAYS HAD A REPUTATION OF
WORKING WELL WITH PICTURES.
>> HE'S BEEN IN THE GAME FOR 14
OR 15 YEARS NOW.
A LOT OF KNOWLEDGE BACK THERE.
ANYTIME YOU HAVE A GUY LIKE THAT
WITH HIS VETERAN PRESENCE BACK
THERE YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE A LOT
OF TRUST IN HIM.
>> TWO BALLS AND TWO STRIKES TO
KURT SUZUKI.
WE WILL HANG WITH YOU FOR THIS
AT-BAT BECAUSE SO FAR, SO GOOD.
>> HOW MANY PITCHES IS THAT?
>> WE HAVE PEOPLE WHO CAN TELL
YOU THAT.
>> DOES IT DRIVE YOU NUTS WHEN A
HITTER IS FOULING ALL SOFT LIKE
THIS?
>> YEAH, KIND OF.
IT'S NOT FUN.
YOU'D RATHER PUT IT IN PLAY OR
MISS IT.
>> THIS IS GOING TO BE THE 11TH
PITCH COMING UP TO KURT SUZUKI
AFTER THE LEADOFF DOUBLE BY JOÉE
ROJAS.
3-0 ASTROS.
>> 19 OR 20?
>> THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION.
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT MODERN
HISTORY BUT I KNOW LAST YEAR THE
LONGEST BY AN ANGELS BATTER WAS
JUSTIN UPTON, 11.
THAT'S WHERE WE ARE AT RIGHT NOW
WITH KURT.
AND I'M TOLD THAT THE LONGEST ON
RECORD IS 21.
A21 PITCH AT BAT, BACK IN 1988.
>> THAT SOUNDS TERRIBLE.
[LAUGHTER]
NOT FUN, NO.
>> FOR THE HITTER, TOO.
>> I COULD STAND HERE ALL DAY
AND SAY I WAS UP THERE FIGHTING
THESE PITCHES OFF WHEN IN
REALITY I COULDN'T SQUARE ONE
UP.
>> DYLAN, WE APPRECIATE THE
VISIT.
WE LOVE WATCHING YOU PITCH AND
WE WILL ENJOY WATCHING YOU PITCH
ON SUNDAY TO WRAP UP THE SERIES.
WAY TO GO.
DYLAN BUNDY JOINING US ON THE
BROADCAST TONIGHT.
I DIDN'T ASK LOOKED AT ON
YOUTUBE?
>> COOKING AND MAKING A REALLY
CHEESESTEAK, BELIEVE IT OR NOT.
BEING A PHILLY GUY YOU WOULD
THINK I WOULD KNOW.
I HAD TO GET A LITTLE
INSTRUCTION ON YOUTUBE ON HOW TO
MAKE ONE.
>> YOUR SECRET IS SAFE ON SOUTH
STREET WITH ME.
>> ALL THE SPECIAL INGREDIENTS.
>> TOP OF THE ORDER.
HERE IS DAVID FLETCHER.
>> YOU HAD TO WATCH A VIDEO FOR
CHEEZ WHIZ?
>> NO, I HAD TO GO BY PROVOLONE
CHEESE.
>> HOW ABOUT YOU?
>> I HAD TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
DISMANTLE MY GARBAGE DISPOSAL
AND FIX IT BECAUSE MY BEAUTIFUL
WIFE PUT DOWN AN ENTIRE HEAD OF
LETTUCE INTO THE GARBAGE
DISPOSAL AND LOCKED IT UP.
AND THAT'S LIVING IN A HOUSE
WITH FIVE WOMEN RIGHT THERE.
>> FLY BALL INTO THE CORNER.
THAT'S GOT A CHANCE IF IT STAYS
FAIR.
AND THAT ONE IS FOUL.
0-2 TO DAVID FLETCHER.
DID IT WORK?
DID YOU UNCLOG IT?
>> I WAS AN ABSOLUTE HERO THAT
NIGHT.
I DIDN'T HAVE TO DO THE DISHES.
BEERS WERE BROUGHT TO ME.
IT WAS GLORIOUS.
>> CRISTIAN JAVIER HAS NOT DONE
ANYTHING BUT STRIKE PEOPLE OUT.
ALL SEVEN OUTS ON SWINGING
STRIKEOUTS.
THE WAY HE IS PITCHING TONIGHT,
IT'S HARD TO IMAGINE IS NOT
BEING A PART OF THE OPENING DAY
ROTATION PLANS.
EVEN IF EVERYBODY IS HEALTHY.
>> VERY TRUE, WITH THE ISSUES
THE ASTROS HAVE HAD IN THEIR
STARTING ROTATION.
JAKE ODORIZZI BEING ADDED TO THE
ROTATION, BUT HE WASN'T ABLE TO
JOIN THE TEAM UNTIL TWO OR THREE
STARTS INTO THE SEASON.
I AGREE WITH YOU IN THE SENSE
THAT HE'S GOT THE STUFF TO PLAY.
UNFORTUNATELY HE WAS ONE OF THE
GUYS THAT HAD TO BE SENT TO THAT
ALTERNATE SITE WHEN THOSE DAYS
OFF CAME INTO PLAY.
>> A BALL INTO STRIKES THE COUNT
TO DAVID FLETCHER.
>> SECOND TIME THROUGH FOR HIM
NOW.
SEE HOW HE REACTS.
WE TALKED ABOUT THAT AT THE
BEGINNING.
SECOND TIME THROUGH FOR JAVIER.
A LITTLE MORE DIFFICULT WITH
THIS PART OF THE ORDER COMING UP
FOR THE ANGELS WITH A MAN IN
SCORING POSITION.
>> IF THAT'S NOT A PERFECT
PITCH, BREAKING BALL AGAINST THE
VERY OUTSIDE OF THE CORNER.
>> IF YOU ARE STRIKING OUT DAVID
FLETCHER, THERE'S SOMETHING GOOD
ABOUT THAT BREAKING BALL.
PRETTY IMPRESSIVE, EIGHT
STRIKEOUTS TONIGHT FOR JAVIER.
TIES A CAREER-HIGH FOR HIM.
LAST TIME HE DID IT WAS AGAINST
THE OTHER LOS ANGELES TEAM.
>> YOU MAKE A GOOD POINT ABOUT
STRIKING OUT DAVID FLETCHER.
HERE IS SHOHEI OHTANI WITH THE
RUNNER AT SECOND AND TWO GONE.
BACK TO BACK STRIKEOUTS.
FLETCHER'S STRIKEOUT PERCENTAGE
SINCE THE START OF THE 2018
SEASON.
IT'S A SECOND LOWEST IN ALL OF
BASEBALL.
ONLY ANDRELTON SIMMONS, FORMER
ANGEL, AND JOE PANIK, A CURRENT
BLUE JAYS, HAVE STRUCK OUT IN A
FEWER PERCENTAGE OF PLATE
APPEARANCES.
0-1 TO OHTANI.
CHECK IT OUT, WE'VE GOT THREE OF
THE FIVE LOWEST STRIKEOUT
PERCENTAGES IN BASEBALL ON THE
FIELD TONIGHT.
RIGHT UNDERNEATH FLETCHER IS
BRANTLEY AND GURRIEL ON THIS
LIST.
HE DOESN'T HIT IT HARD?
, BUT WHO CARES?
-- DOESN'T HIT IT HARD, BUT WHO
CARES?
OHTANI HAD ONE TO HIT BUT FLIES
IT INTO CENTER FOR STRAW.
NOTHING COMES OF THE LEADOFF
DOUBLE.
IMPRESSIVE BY 24-YEAR-OLD
CRISTIAN JAVIER.
>> OPPOSITE FIELD BASE HIT FOR
SHOHEI AND ANGELS HAVE A ONE HIT
BASE RUNNER IN THE FIRST.
THAT WILL RATTLE AROUND AND
CLEAR THE BASES.
ONE TO MANY FASTBALLS AGAIN
SHOHEI OHTANI AND THE ANGELS GET
THEIR THREE RUN LEAD BACK IN THE
SEVEN.
SHOHEI SERVES THAT INTO THE
OPPOSITE FIELD AND THAT WILL
DROP IN FRONT OF AN ATTENDEE AND
ROLL ALL THE WAY TO THE TRACK.
FLETCHER COMING AROUND THIRD
INTO SCORE.
8-3 ANGELS LEAD.
MORE DAMAGE BY OHTANI.
>> SHOHEI OHTANI, ANOTHER R.B.I.
GIVING HIM THREE IN THE GAME.
>> GET GOING, AND GONE.
THE SUPERHERO DOES IT AGAIN.
NUMBER FOUR OR SHOHEI OHTANI.
WHAT A JOB BY SHOHEI.
>> WELCOME BACK TO MINUTE MAID
PARK.
WE HAVE ANOTHER POLL FOR YOU.
WOULD LIKE TO KNOW WHICH
UPCOMING FREE-AGENT SHORTSTOP
WILL GET THE BIGGEST DEAL.
YOU CAN VOTE FOR CARLOS CORREA,
STORY, SEAGER, OR BIAS.
OF GOT A FEELING ALL OF THOSE
GUYS WILL BE PAID QUITE WELL
VERY SOON.
>> THERE IS NO WRONG ANSWER
THERE.
LINDOR WAS ON THAT LIST BUT
RE-UPPED AND GOING NOWHERE,
OUTSIDE OF FLUSHING QUEENS FOR
THE NEXT DECADE.
ALEX COBB BACK TO WORK.
BOTTOM THIRD OF THE ORDER FOR
THE ASTROS WHO LEAD IT 3-0.
JAKE ODORIZZI JOINING US.
THANKS FOR TAKING SOME TIME.
DID YOU HEAR THAT LIST OF
SHORTSTOPS?
WHO IS THE GUY ON THAT LIST THAT
YOU WOULD LIKE TO FACE THE
LEAST?
JAKE: I DON'T KNOW IF THERE'S
ONE YOU WANT TO PICK OUT OF THAT
GROUP.
I THINK THEY WOULD TAKE OFFENSE
AND IT WOULD BE WORSE IF YOU
PICKED ONE.
IT'S BEEN A WHILE SINCE I FACED
BAEZ, AND I FACED STORY.
I GUESS THREE GUYS I HAVEN'T
SEEN ALL THAT OFTEN.
I'VE SEEN CARLOS PLENTY, SO I
COULD DO WITHOUT THAT.
>> BY THE WAY, THANKS FOR COMING
ON WITH US.
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR DEAL OF
JOINING THE ASTROS.
I KNOW THE ASTROS FANS WERE
THRILLED THAT YOU DECIDED TO
SIGN THEIR.
IRONICALLY, THE TEAM YOU WERE
LINKED TO SO OFTEN IN THE
OFF-SEASON, THE ANGELS WERE
REPORTEDLY HOT ON YOUR HEELS.
TELL US ABOUT THE REASONS YOU
CHOSE THE ASTROS AND HOUSTON?
JAKE: THE ANGELS WERE ONE OF
TEAMS THAT TALK TO US PRETTY
MUCH FROM START TO FINISH.
I THOUGHT IT WAS A GOOD FIT FROM
A PITCHING STAFF WISE, I'VE
HEARD TREMENDOUS THINGS ABOUT
STROM.
GOOD PITCH RIGHT THERE.
HE DOES A LOT OF THE
PHILOSOPHIES I TRAINED WITHIN
THE OFF SEASON AND HAS THE SAME
THOUGHT PROCESS.
THERE HAVE BEEN A LOT OF GUYS
THAT HAVE HAD A LOT OF SUCCESS.
I HAVE A LOT OF FORMER TEAMMATES
ON THIS TEAM.
JASON CASTRO IS HERE SO I
THOUGHT THE REPORT OF SHOWING UP
TO SPRING TRAINING AND HAVING A
PITCHER AND CATCHER RELATIONSHIP
WAS IMPORTANT SO I HAD A LOT OF
INFLUENCE ON IT AS WELL.
THE TEAM IN GENERAL, THIS IS A
VERY GOOD TEAM.
WE HAVEN'T PLAYED LIKE IT IN THE
LAST 10 DAYS OR SO BUT HOPEFULLY
WE START TURNING IT AROUND.
THERE'S A LOT OF GOOD THINGS
AHEAD FOR US HERE IN THE FUTURE.
>> JAKE, YOU AND ALEX COBB HAVE
THAT SPLIT CHANGE, IS THERE ANY
SIMILARITY BETWEEN YOUR CHANGE
IN HIS SPLIT?
DOES THAT GO BACK TO YOUR TIME
IN TAMPA BAY TOGETHER?
JAKE: HE'S THE ONE WHO TAUGHT ME
HOW TO THROW THE SPLIT.
HE WAS THE ONE WHO TAUGHT IT TO
ME AND THAT WAS KIND OF A
TURNING POINT IN MY CAREER.
I FINALLY HAVE AN OFFSPEED THAT
WASN'T A BREAKING BALL.
IT'S FUNNY HOW THINGS COME FULL
CIRCLE.
I WAS A ROOKIE, TRYING TO MAKE
THE TEAM IN THE SPRING.
HE WENT OUT OF HIS WAY AND
WORKED WITH ME IN SPRING
TRAINING, HELP ME THROW AND
MANIPULATE IT AND IT REALLY
CHANGED THE WAY I PITCHED TO
THIS DAY.
>> SPEAKING OF HOW THINGS TURN
AND COME AROUND, YOU WERE TRADED
FOR ZACK GREINKE AND NOW YOU ARE
TEAMMATE WITH HIM.
HOW IMPORTANT IS IT TO BE AROUND
HIM AND LEARN HOW TO PITCH?
HE IS ONE OF THE ALL-TIME
GREATS.
JAKE: HE IS FANTASTIC.
ANYTHING IN GENERAL, I JUST WANT
TO SIT THERE AND SOAK IT UP
BECAUSE HE HAS SUCH KNOWLEDGE
AND HE HAS THE REASONS TO BACK
IT UP.
HE HAS THE REASONING BEHIND WHY
HE THINKS SOMETHING AND THERE IS
DATA TO BACK IT UP.
HE IS FANTASTIC TO BE AROUND AND
I KNOW A LOT OF THE GUYS HERE
REALLY LIKE SITTING AND JUST
LISTENING TO HIM TALK.
IT'S NOT OFTEN THAT WE GET A
CHANCE TO SIT AND TALK BUT IT'S
GREAT TO HAVE A GUY LIKE THAT IN
A ROTATION.
HE IS THE GUY I MODEL MYSELF
AFTER AFTER I WAS DRAFTED.
IT'S WEIRD HOW IT WORKS OUT BUT
I'M JUST TRYING TO PICK HIS
BRAIN AND LEARN AS MUCH AS I CAN
FROM HIM EVERY SINGLE DAY.
>> THAT'S INTERESTING THAT YOU
TALKED ABOUT THAT.
I KNOW AFTER THE LAST START AT
MINUTE MAID PARK YOU TALKED
ABOUT POSSIBLY GETTING NEAR
JUSTIN VERLANDER.
TALK ABOUT WHAT YOU GUYS TALK
ABOUT AS PITCHERS IN MINUTE MAID
PARK.
DO THEY OFFER ANY TIDBITS ON HOW
TO HANDLE PITCHING IN A
BALLPARK?
HE GOT SNAKE BIT BY COUPLE OF
HOMERUNS IN THAT CRAWFORD BOXES.
>> THAT'S A BALL THAT IS FOUR
INCHES IN ON HIS HAND.
CARLOS BLOOPS IT INTO CENTER FOR
AN R.B.I. BASE HIT.
WHAT A FINE JOB AT THE PLATE BY
CARLOS CORREA.
4-0 ASTROS.
JAKE: IT WASN'T THE MOST IDEAL
START TO MY ASTROS CAREER.
I WOULD'VE LIKED SOMETHING A LOT
BETTER THAN WHAT IT WAS.
BUT THAT'S BASEBALL.
YOU CAN'T FAULT IT TOO MUCH, BUT
THERE'S GOING TO BE GAMES WHERE
THAT HAPPENS.
I MIGHT HAVE JUMPED THE GUN A
LITTLE BIT TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHOLESALE CHANGES.
IT'S STILL EARLY.
I'M PLAYING CATCH UP PRETTY BIG
RIGHT NOW.
I ONLY HAD A COUPLE OF STARTS
LAST YEAR AND THIS YEAR.
I'M STILL IN THE CATCH-UP MODE.
I REALLY NOTICED HOW MUCH
EXECUTION IS THE LAST THING THAT
COMES AFTER MISSING SOME TIME,
BARELY PITCHING AT ALL.
THE STUFF I FEEL IS THERE IS THE
EXECUTION, SO I CAN FOCUS ON
THAT, PICK BETTER LOCATIONS AND
MAKE BETTER PITCHES AND THAT
SOLVES THAT PROBLEM RIGHT FROM
THE GET-GO.
>> WE APPA R.B.I. SINGLE CHASESX
COBB.
WE WILL BE RIGHT BACK.
>> THERE YOU SEE RIGHT-HANDERS
ZACK GREINKE ON THE MOUND.
>> GREINKE PICKS UP HIS FIRST
STRIKEOUT.
PULL THE STRING ON IT WITH THE
CHANGEUP AND ZACH PICKS UP
BACK-TO-BACK STRIKEOUTS.
>> BREAKING BALL, SWING AND A
MISS.
>> ANOTHER CURVEBALL FROM
GREINKE.
THAT'S HIS FOURTH STRIKEOUT.
>> HERE'S THE PITCH.
CHANGEUP, SWING AND A MISS.
INSIDE CHANGEUP AND HE GETS HIM
ON THREE PITCHES.
FIVE STRIKEOUTS FOR GREINKE.
>> SWING AND A MISS, 67 MILE AN
HOUR CURVEBALL, ZACK GREINKE
LOOKING GREAT TONIGHT.
>> FLIP THAT BREAKING BALL OUT
THERE.
>> GROUND BALL HIT TO THE RIGHT
SIDE OF THE SHIFT.
EIGHT SHUTOUT INNINGS FOR ZACK
GREINKE.
>> WELCOME BACK TO THE YOUTUBE
GAME OF THE WEEK DAVID WE ARE
PRESENTED BY CHIME.
THE ANGELS GO TO THE BULLPEN
EARLY.
A LITTLE BIT OF A DICE ROLL AS
ALEX COBB DID NOT HAVE HIS ACE
STUFF AS HE DID 10 DAYS AGO.
HOWEVER, HE HAD GOTTEN MICHAEL
BRANTLEY OUT TWICE TONIGHT AND
IS KEPT HIM AT A 1-12 FOR HIS
CAREER.
THE DICE ROLL IS THIS.
BECAUSE OF THE THREE BETTER
MINIMUM, CLAUDIO LET'S MICHAEL
BRANTLEY GET ON BASE, HE'S GOT
TO FACE ALEX BREGMAN.
IT WAS A CALCULATED RISK.
JOE MADDON'S FELT LIKE IT WAS
TIME FOR ALEX COBB.
>> WITH CLAUDIO YOU ALWAYS HAVE
A CHANCE WITH THE CHANGEUP TO
NEUTRALIZE A RIGHT-HANDED BAT.
IF HE CAN'T GET HIM OUT HE STILL
HAS A CHANGEUP AGAINST BREGMAN
TO GET HIM OUT.
IT WAS A STRESSFUL AMOUNT OF
PITCHES THE ENTIRE GAME FOR HIM.
>> A BALL AND A STRIKE THE COUNT
TO BRANTLEY.
1-4 AGAINST ALEX CLAUDIO AND
1-12 AGAINST ALEX COBB.
A TWO-OUT DOUBLE BY MARTIN
MALDONADO THEN IN R.B.I. SINGLE
BY CARLOS CORREA.
BRANTLEY LINES THAT WENT INTO
FAIR TERRITORY AT RIGHT.
IT WILL BE A GROUND RULE DOUBLE
FOR MICHAEL BRANTLEY.
AND THAT FOR THE TIME BEING HAS
PREVENTED A RUN.
THIS HAS PLAYED RIGHT INTO DUSTY
BAKER'S HANDS NOW.
IS THIS AN AUTOMATIC TO WALK
ALEX BREGMAN HERE?
>> COULD BE, ESPECIALLY THE WAY
ALEX IS SWINGING THE BAT.
YOU SEE BRANTLEY JUST SNEAKING
THAT ONE IN THE RIGHT-FIELD
LINE.
KEEPS PIRELA AT THIRD BASE.
>> BRANTLEY THE RUNNER AT SECOND
AFTER HIS SIX DOUBLE OF THE YEAR
ALREADY.
0-1 THE COUNT TO ALEX BREGMAN.
>> I HAVE NOT SEEN THIS BALLCLUB
IN EIGHT LONG SWINGING LIKE THEY
ARE EARLY.
>> KIND OF, YOU'VE GOT AN ASTROS
TEAM THAT COULDN'T WAIT TO GET
OUT OF DENVER, THEN AFTER ALL
THE COVID PLAYOFFS, GUYS THAT
WERE INACTIVE OR HEALTHIER YOU
WOULD THINK, YOU ALREADY MADE
THE POINT ABOUT BREGMAN'S LEGS
LOOKING FRESH.
AND THEY CATCH ALEX COBB ON A
NIGHT WHERE HE WAS 10 DAYS
BETWEEN STARTS.
A BALL INTO STRIKES THE COUNT TO
ALEX BREGMAN.
>> THERE WAS A LOT OF
CONVERSATION AROUND THE HOUSTON
ASTROS ASKING MAJOR LEAGUE
BASEBALL WHY THEY WERE PLAYING
IN THE MINNESOTA TWINS WERE NOT.
ASTROS HAVING TO CALL UP FOR
PLAYERS FROM THEIR ALTERNATE
SITE TO TRY TO FIGHT FOR THAT
ROAD TRIP.
BUT YOU ARE RIGHT, THESE COUPLE
OF DAY PLAYOFFS WILL HAVE
EFFECTS ON PLAYERS.
>> THE WHOLE THING IS BLOWN UP.
TWO RUNS WILL SCORE AND THE
ASTROS TAKE A COMMANDING 6-0
LEAD.
THAT ABSOLUTELY BACKFIRED FOR
THE ANGELS.
>> THE ASTROS ARE MAKING
CONTACT.
THESE ARE NOT NECESSARILY ALL
SQUARED UP BASEBALLS TONIGHT.
A CHANGEUP THAT WAS ELEVATED.
BECAUSE IT'S ELEVATED IT'S IN
THE OUTFIELD.
THE ASTROS PUT THE BALL IN PLAY,
MAKING SOLID CONTACT THROUGHOUT.
>> HERE'S ALVAREZ WHO HAS BEEN
ON BASE IN BOTH OF HIS AT-BATS.
A BASE HIT AND A WALK EACH
COMING AGAINST ALEX COBB.
THIS IS THE CHANT YOU TAKE,
KNOWING THE THREE BETTER
MINIMUM.
IF THE MOVE DID MAKE FOR THE
FIRST HITTER, AND IT DIDN'T,
THEN YOU'VE GOT TO FACE BREGMAN
WHO HAD BIG NUMBERS AGAINST
CLAUDIO AND NOW YOU'VE GOT TO
GET ALVAREZ AS WELL.
A SERIES OF CALCULATED RISKS
MANAGING WITH THE NEW RULE.
2-0 NOW.
3-0.
WHAT HAS HELPED THE ASTROS
LINEUP TONIGHT CERTAINLY HAS
BEEN THE GENEROUS BASE ON BALLS
EQUIVALENT FROM THE ANGELS.
THREE BY ALEX COBB.
EVERY TIME HE SNEEZES IT LOOKS
LIKE A PARTY FAVOR.
YORDAN ALVAREZ SPRAYING THEM ALL
AROUND THE PARK.
PRETTY IMPRESSIVE HOME RUN
DISTRIBUTION.
FULL COUNT.
>> CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG, I
BELIEVE HIS FIRST BIG-LEAGUE
HOME RUN WAS UP TOWARD THAT
PHILLIPS 66 GAS PUMP AND LEFT
CENTER FIELD.
I THINK IT WAS DYLAN BUNDY.
>> I REMEMBER HOW FAR THAT WENT.
THIS MAN IS STRONG.
>> ALEX CLAUDIO MINIMIZES THE
DAMAGE AT THE END OF A THREE RUN
INNING.
ALL ASTROS TONIGHT AT THE E6-0 .
>> WE LANDED IN L.A. AT LIKE
6:30 WE TOOK A CAB TO ANAHEIM
WHICH IS AN HOUR AWAY.
>> HERE HE IS, CENTER FIELDER
MIKE TROUT IN HIS MAJOR-LEAGUE
DEBUT TONIGHT.
>> WE DID NOT GET TO THE STADIUM
UNTIL THE SIXTH OR SEVENTH
INNING.
WE SAID MIGHT, LEAVE US FOR
TICKETS AND WE WILL BE THERE.
HE DOESN'T LEAVE US TICKETS.
WE WILL BUY TICKETS, JUST GIVE
US A TICKET SOMEWHERE.
>> WE FINALLY GET IN THE STADIUM
AND IT'S LIKE TOP OF THE EIGHTH
INNING.
AND ABOLISH IT TO CENTER.
WE HAD JUST SAT DOWN >> >>.
HE RUNS IT DOWN.
WHAT A PLAY BY MIKE TROUT.
>> MIKE MADE THAT UNBELIEVABLE
CATCH OUTING THE OUTFIELD.
>> WELCOME BACK TO THE MLB GAME
OF THE WEEK ON YOUTUBE PRESENTED
BY CHIME.
6-0 ASTROS.
>> MIKE WILL LEAD THINGS OFF
HERE IN THE FOURTH INNING.
THE ANGELS DOWN BY SIX.
THE ONLY THING HE DOES NOT HAVE
A SHOT AT IS CHONE FIGGINS
CAREER CAUGHT STEALING RECORD.
>> HE HASN'T BEEN RUNNING AS
MUCH BUT HE PICKS HIS SPOTS
WELL.
>> 0-1 THE COUNT AGAINST MIKE.
ON ANOTHER NIGHT WHEN THE ASTROS
HAVE AN ERUPTED FOR SIX, WE
WOULD TALK ABOUT JAVIER IS BEING
THE STORY.
HE'S ONE OF THE STORY'S IN THE
MIDST OF A TERRIFIC STARTING
PERFORMANCE HAVING STRUCK OUT
EIGHT.
>> THE ASTROS HAVE SIX RUNS ON
THE BOARD AND IT STILL DOESN'T
MATCH UP TO THOSE EIGHT
STRIKEOUTS THAT JAVIER HAS.
USUALLY CREATES OFF CONTACT AND
USES THE DEFENSE BEHIND HIM, BUT
HE'S BEEN A ONE-MAN SHOW ON TOP
OF THE BUMP TONIGHT.
>> THREE BALLS AND A STRIKE THE
COUNT TO TROUT.
MIKE TROUT THREW HIS WALK
TONIGHT HAS HAD 70 LATE
APPEARANCES TO START THE YEAR.
HE'S BEEN ON BASE IN 36 OF THEM.
FULL COUNT TO HIM NOW.
YOU KNOW WHAT I DON'T UNDERSTAND
, AND YOU HAVE WATCHED MIKE
TROUT THROUGHOUT HIS CAREER.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY HE
DOESN'T GET THE BRYCE HARPER
TREATMENT MORE OFTEN.
THAT IS TO SAY, NOTHING TO HIT.
>> EARLY HE DID.
WITH ANTHONY RENDON IN THE
LINEUP, HE GOT A LOT MORE
FASTBALLS LAST YEAR.
>> HE GOT HIT IN THE ELBOW.
THERE IS NO PAD THERE, I DON'T
THINK.
>> HE HAS A LITTLE PROTECTION
RIGHT AROUND THE TRICEP AREA.
EVEN WITH THOSE ELBOW PADS AND
THAT PROTECTION, IF YOU GET
SQUARED UP ON THE ELBOW, IT IS
GOING TO HURT NO MATTER WHAT.
AND THAT BALL GOT HIM GOOD.
>> IT DID GET HIM ON THE PAD,
BUT TO YOUR POINT, IT STILL
HURTS.
THAT'S A BIG, STRONG DUDE.
HE DOESN'T REACT LIKE THAT
UNLESS IT REALLY HURTS.
UNDERSTANDABLE CONCERN BY THE
ANGELS.
>> ALMOST LOOKED AS IF HE LEFT
THAT ELBOW OUT THERE A LITTLE
BIT LONGER, MAYBE NOT
ANTICIPATING THE BALL TO STAY
THAT -- INSIDE AS MUCH AS IT
WAS.
HE WAS NOT CONCERNED ABOUT
GETTING HIT WITH THE PITCH ON
THAT ONE, THE WAY HE STUCK HIS
ELBOW OUT THERE.
>> I AGREE WITH YOU.
DEFINITELY DIDN'T SOUND GOOD.
>> HE'S GOING TO TRY TO STICK
AROUND, AT LEAST FOR THE TIME
BEING.
JUST BEING INFORMED THAT
TONIGHT'S HOME PLATE UMPIRE, YOU
GUYS REMEMBER THAT METS-MARLINS
GAME THAT ENDED ONLY HIT BY
PITCH PLAY THAT WAS
CONTROVERSIAL.
A LOT OF PEOPLE FELT LIKE
MICHAEL CONFORTO LEANED INTO IT.
SOME PEOPLE FELT THE BALL NEVER
HIT HIM AT ALL.
RON HAD THE PLATE FOR THAT ONE
AS WELL.
WEIRD PLAYS ARE FOLLOWING HIM
AROUND.
MIA KULPA.
HERE'S JARED WALSH NOW WITH THE
LEADOFF HITTER ABOARD.
WALSH ONE OF THE STRIKEOUT
VICTIMS, FIRST TIME THROUGH BY
JAVIER.
SEVEN OF THE NINE ANGELS THAT
STEPPED TO THE PLATE STRUCK OUT
AGAINST HIM FIRST TIME AROUND.
0-2.
>> IT STILL LOOKED LIKE TROUT
LEANED IN ON IT.
EARLIER THIS YEAR WHILE SCOTT
HIT BY A PITCH.
TROUT ALREADY HAS A HIGH ELEVATE
PERCENTAGE.
HE DOESN'T NEED ANY MORE LIKE
THIS.
>> HE DEFINITELY DOESN'T, AND
THE LEAGUE DOESN'T WANT TO SEE
THAT GUY GET HURT EITHER.
HE'S A LOT OF FUN TO WATCH WHEN
HE'S ON THAT BALL FIELD.
>> 0-2 TO JARED WALSH.
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT THE GUYS
THAT HAVE THE MEGA DEALS IN THE
GUYS THAT HAVE THE BIGGEST
OVERALL CONTRACTS IN BASEBALL,
TROUT'S BEING THE BIGGEST, AND
IT'S A GROUP THAT INCLUDES
LINDOR, BETTS, TATIS, PADRES
FANS WERE WORRIED ABOUT THE SAME
THING WITH THEIR SHORTSTOP AND A
SHOULDER INJURY OCCURRED.
THERE'S JUST TOO MUCH MONEY
INVESTED, TOO MUCH HOPE AND ONE
PLAYER TO HAVE SOMEBODY LIKE
THAT GO DOWN.
>> REMEMBER THE OTHER DAY,
MOOKIE BETTS, SAME THING, GOT
HIT ON THE ELBOW AS WELL.
>> THEY ARE LIKE QUARTERBACKS IN
THE NFL.
WHEN A CONTRACT COMES DUE, THEY
JUMPED TO THE FRONT OF THE LINE.
I DON'T KNOW IF ANYBODY WILL GET
PAST TROUTS NUMBER ANYTIME SOON.
THAT IS A FIRM NUMBER.
>> THOSE KINDS OF NUMBERS WILL
MAKE YOUR PORTFOLIO QUITE
STRONG.
>> BACK TO TWO BALLS AND TWO
STRIKES ON JARED WALSH.
UPTON.
HOUSTON ON TOP 6-0 HERE IN THE
TOP HALF OF THE FOURTH.
WALSH FINDS A BALL BACK UP THE
MIDDLE.
-- LINES THE BALL BACK UP THE
TROUT A BOARD AFTER BEING HIT BY
THE PITCH.
LET'S LISTEN INTO WHAT IT
SOUNDED LIKE AND SOME OF THE
REACTIONS A LITTLE WHILE AGO.
>> OK TO STICK IT OUT.
RUNNERS AT FIRST AND SECOND TO
START THE INNING FOR JUSTIN
UPTON.
TRYING TO CONVERT ON A FIVE-GAME
HITTING STREAK.
WHAT WERE THOSE NUMBERS YOU HAD
EARLIER?
>> .462 THE SECOND TIME THROUGH.
HERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
ANGELS TO GET BACK.
HIS SLIDER HAS BEEN SO GOOD
TONIGHT, IT'S NOT GOING TO BE AN
EASY TASK.
UPTON ALSO STRIKEOUT VICTIM
TONIGHT.
2-0.
>> I KNOW IT SOMETIMES SOUNDS
ODD, BUT WHEN YEAR OF PITCHER
AND YOU HIT A BATTER WITH A 6-0
LEAD, IT CAN RATTLE YOU A LITTLE
BIT.
IT SEEMS TO BE THE CASE THIS
INNING FOR JAVIER.
NOW THE2-0 COUNT WITH JUSTIN
UPTON WHO HAD A HOME RUN
YESTERDAY.
EXIT VELOCITY OF 170 MILES AN
HOUR.
-- 117 MILES AN HOUR.
>> TWO BALLS AND NO STRIKES.
CALL ON A SLIDER, 2-1.
JUSTIN UPTON HAS BEEN AROUND,
IT'S HARD TO BELIEVE THIS IS HIS
FIFTH YEAR AS AN ANGEL.
>> IT'S HARD TO BELIEVE HE WAS
DRAFTED BACK IN 2005.
THERE ARE FOUR T-REX IS LEFT ON
ACTIVE MAJOR LEAVE ROSTERS --
MAJOR LEAGUE ROSTERS.
ANYBODY WANT TO GUESS ON THE
FOUR REMAINING GUYS OTHER THAN
UPTON STILL ACTIVE ON BIG-LEAGUE
ROSTERS?
>> ARE YOU GOING TO GIVE ME TIME
TO GOOGLE IT?
I WILL SAY TO OTHERS ARE --
THREE GUYS OF THE FIVE REMAINING
THAT WERE PICKED IN THE TOP 11.
I KNOW IT WASN'T EXACTLY
YESTERDAY.
THAT CLASS MIGHT NOT BE AROUND
IN ANOTHER COUPLE OF YEARS.
>> CHASED A HIGH FASTBALL.
HIS NINTH STRIKEOUT OF THE GAME
FOR JAVIER.
RYAN ZIMMERMAN WAS THE ONLY GUY
THAT I KIND OF THOUGHT WAS
THERE.
BUT A LOT OF THESE GUYS, JAY
BRUCE JUST SHUT IT DOWN, JACOBY
ELLSBURY IS NOT PLAYING ANYMORE.
JED LOWRIE RESURGENT WITH THE
A'S THIS YEAR.
WHAT A CLASS.
THAT'S AMAZING.
INMATE -- AMAZING THAT FOUR OF
THE FIRST FIVE PICKS WERE NOT
PICTURES.
PUJOLS ALSO A STRIKEOUT VICTIM
TONIGHT.
>> THAT DRIVE FOR SO LONG AGO
THAT RYAN ZIMMERMAN WAS A DRAFT
PICK OF THE MONTREAL EXPOS,
WASN'T HE?
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
ACTUALLY I'M BEING CORRECTED.
WE WERE ALL WRONG BECAUSE OF THE
FIRST-EVER PICK BY THE NATS.
THAT WAS THEIR INAUGURAL SEASON.
>> JED LOWRIE AND WHAT HE'S
DOING FOR OAKLAND, HE'S BEEN
THROUGH A LOT WITH THE METS.
AND THE A'S JUST KEEP ON
WINNING.
THEY ARE A FUN TEAM TO BE ON
RIGHT NOW.
>> IT GETS AWAY FROM MALDONADO.
THAT WILL GET THE ANGELS OUT OF
A TRADITIONAL DOUBLE PLAY
THREAT.
>> IT IS NOT TOO OFTEN THAT YOU
GET ALBERT PUJOLS TO SWING AT A
SLIDER LIKE THAT.
THAT'S ONE PITCH HE'S HAD A
TOUGH TIME WITH SO FAR THIS
YEAR.
HE'S CHASED QUITE A FEW OF THEM
SO FAR IN THE SEASON.
>> 2-2.
>> THAT'S THE SIGN OF A VETERAN
AT BAT RIGHT THERE BY ALBERT
PUJOLS, TAKING A WHILE SWING AND
A SLIDER, THEN BACKING OFF THE
NEXT ONE.
>> 2-2, RUNNERS AT SECOND AND
THIRD.
6-0 HOUSTON.
ALBERT POPS THAT ONE UP BEHIND
THE PLATE.
MALDONADO CHASING AND RUNNING
OUT OF ROOM.
NEW TO THE MLB GAME OF THE WEEK
FOR THE 2021 SEASON IS THE
YOUTUBE PLAYER OF THE WEEK.
VOTE FOR WHICH PLAYER WILL
RECEIVE A TROPHY DURING THE POST
GAME SHOW.
STAY TUNED FOR THE POLLING
OPTIONS COMING UP A LITTLE LATER
ON.
I DON'T THINK IT'S A STRETCH TO
SEE CRISTIAN JAVIER IS AN EARLY
LEADING CANDIDATE.
ALBERT LOOKING FOR A BASE HIT TO
GET THE ANGELS ON THE BOARD HERE
IN THE FOURTH.
FULL COUNT NOW.
>> THE THING ABOUT ALBERT, HE'S
SO TUNED IN ON HOW TO GET A RUN
HOME.
ALBERT WITH OVER 2100 R.B.I.'S
FINDS A WAY TO GET A RUN HOME,
NO MATTER WHAT THE SCENARIO.
>> THREE BALLS AND TWO STRIKES,
RUNNERS AT SECOND AND THIRD.
ONE GONE IN THE FOURTH.
JAVIER SITTING ON NINE
STRIKEOUTS.
PUJOLS POPS THIS ONE UP.
TWO GONE.
NINE STRIKEOUTS.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE
LOCATION OF THESE PITCHES.
>> HE'S GOT SOME STRIKEOUTS IN
THE UPPER THIRD.
HE'S GOT SOME NASTY STUFF.
ALSO WITH THAT SLIDER AND
CURVEBALL.
UPPER PART OF THE STRIKE ZONE.
IT IS POSSIBLE TO READ.
PRETTY GOOD SPIN RATE AS WELL
UPSTAIRS.
>> JOSÉ IGLESIAS ONE OF THE
VICTIMS TONIGHT.
TROUT AND ROJAS ARE THE ONLY
ANGELS THAT HAVEN'T STRUCK OUT.
IGLESIAS TAKES A STRIKE.
THIS HAS BEEN A GAME OF DEEP
COUNTS.
ALEX COBB STRUCK OUT FOUR, HOBBY
STRUCK OUT NINE.
-- JAVIER STRUCK OUT NINE.
THERE HAVE BEEN FOUR WALKS
TONIGHT.
TWO HIT BATSMAN.
0-2.
>> HE GETS A NASTY SPIN RATE.
AVERAGE SPIN RATE ON A SLIDER,
21.
AVERAGE RATE, 26.
WELL ABOVE AVERAGE RATE FOR SPIN
ON HIS SLIDER.
>> IN THE AIR OUT TO RIGHT.
ROUTINE FLY BALL FOR KYLE TUCKER
TO RETIRE THE SIDE.
SECOND THIRD WITH ONE AWAY.
FOUR IMPRESSIVE SHUT OUT
WINNINGS FOR CRISTIAN JAVIER.
>> BEING ABLE TO CELEBRATE THE
BIRTH OF OUR CHILD AROUND HIS
BIRTH DAY DEFINITELY MEANS A LOT
TO ALL OF US.
WE ARE EXTREMELY EXCITED.
>> AARON COX WAS MIGHT TROUT --
MIKE TROUT'S BEST FRIEND, BORN
IN AUGUST OF 1994.
HE DIED IN AUGUST TWO YEARS AGO.
>> A SYMBOL OF SUICIDE
PREVENTION.
>> THEY STARTED A SUICIDE
PREVENTION CAMPAIGN CALLED, YOUR
GAME IS NOT OVER YET.
THEY WORKED WITH TINY TURNER ON
A POWERFUL DESIGN THAT INCLUDES
WORDS OF ENCOURAGEMENT AND THE
STITCHES OF THE BASEBALL.
>> IT IS SOMETHING THAT IS
SPECIAL TO US THAT WE WERE ABLE
TO DO THIS IN HIS HONOR, AND HIS
NAME.
HOPEFULLY, MAKE A DIFFERENCE AND
HELP ANOTHER FAMILY FROM HAVING
TO GO THROUGH THE TRAGEDY WE
WENT THROUGH.
>> THERE IS ONE MORE THING THE
TROUTS DECIDED TO DO IN AARON'S
NAME.
THEY DECIDED TO GIVE IT TO AARON
BECKHAM TRAPPED. -- TROUT.
>> EACH WEEK THIS SEASON ON OUR
BROADCAST WE WILL FOCUS ON A
YOUTUBE CONTENT CREATOR FEATURED
IN OUR LIVE GAME COMMENTARY
SECTION.
TODAY OUR CREATOR SPOTLIGHT IS
ON MATT ANTONELLI, MEMBER OF THE
RED SOX FAITHFUL.
MATT'S CHANNEL FEATURES TIPS,
DRILLS AND INSTRUCTION.
SEARCH YOUTUBE FOR MORE.
THAT IS MATT FROM HIS SAN DIEGO
PADRES DAYS.
PADRES GETTING READY FOR A FOUR
SERIES IN LOS ANGELES TONIGHT.
ON YOUTUBE THE ASTROS OFF TO A
COMMANDING START ON TOP OF THE
ANGELS, 6-0.
ALEX CLAUDIO WILL CONTINUE TO
FACE GURRIEL, AND DIAZ IN THE
HOUSTON FOURTH.
I REMEMBER WHEN A.J. HINCH WAS
MANAGING THE ASTROS AND TALKING
TO HIM ABOUT THE KIND OF HITTER
THAT YULI GURRIEL IS.
CERTAIN HITTERS FOR WHOM YOU
GIVE THE ADDITIONAL LAYER OF
INFORMATION, METRICS, AND A
CERTAIN GUYS YOU GIVE JUST A
LITTLE INFORMATION TO.
HE PUT GURRIEL STRAIGHT IN THAT
SECOND CATEGORY.
GEOFF: IT IS A REALLY GOOD CALL.
WHAT A LOT OF FANS DON'T KNOW,
YULI GURRIEL WAS A VETERAN
PLAYING IN CUBA FOR YEARS.
WHEN HE PLAYED INTO THE MAJOR
LEAGUES WITH THE ASTROS HE WAS
LONG AND THE TOOTH AS FAR AS
KNOWLEDGE AND HOW TO PLAY THE
GAME AND A SWING THAT DEVELOPED
IN CUBA.
HE CAME OVER HERE AND WAS A GAP
TO GAP KIND OF GUY, HE KNEW WHAT
PITCHES HE COULD HANDLE.
HE PUT TRUST IN GURRIEL TO
PRODUCE AND BE WHO HE IS.
IT WAS A GOOD MOVE.
BRETT: KYLE TUCKER HAS BEATEN
THE SHIFT WITH A LITTLE DOINKER
OVER THE MOUND.
>> THIS HAS GOT TO BE A GAME
DRIVING GOOBY NUTS.
THEY CONTINUE TO PUT RUNNERS ON
BASE.
THEY HAVE NOT HIT THE BALL THAT
HARD IN THIS GAME.
MARK: THE DUGOUT AND THE
CLUBHOUSE MIGHT BE IN JEOPARDY
AT SOME POINT TONIGHT.
[LAUGHTER]
BRETT: ALEX CLAUDIO BEING
REMOVED.
SECOND PITCHING CHANGE TONIGHT
FOR THED WE WILL BE
RIGHT BACK.
♪
>> MAKE FUN OF ME?
>> HEART IS PALPITATING.
>> YES.
>> ROBERT IS SAFE AT THIRD.
THIRD BASE.
>> A RISK WITH TWO OUTS, BUT IF
THEY GIVE IT TO YOU, TAKE IT.
>> THE SOX HAVE THE FIRST RUN OF
THE 2021 SEASON.
>> HE LOST A LITTLE BIT OF GOLD,
HEADING TO THE THIRD BASE LINE.
>> YELICH IN TO RIGHT CENTER.
>> KAPLER WAS THERE ON A WIDE
SHOT, COULD NOT MAKE THE PLAY.
IN AND OUT OF THE GLOVE.
HUGE BREAK, FALTERING
DEFENSIVELY IN THE NINTH INNING.
>> BRYCE HARPER AS A SHOES TO
DISPLAY DURING INTRODUCTIONS
EARLIER TODAY.
>> I THINK FREDDIE WAS
DISAPPOINTED WHEN HE DID NOT
WEAR THEM.
>> I THINK THEY HAD SPIKES.
>> THEY DID, THEY DID.
BRETT: JUNIOR WITH A PITCHING
CHANGE.
BEFORE WE GET TO HIM, AN
OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN MORE ABOUT
KYLE TUCKER WITH OUR TIME PLAYER
SPOTLIGHT.
NICKNAMED 10 AND ROOKIE SEASON
BECAUSE SOMEONE SAID HE SWUNG AT
LIKE TED WILLIAMS.
NO BIG SHOES TO FILL, JUST TED
WILLIAMS.
>> WHEN HE WAS COMING UP, WE
CALLED HIM TEDDY TUCKER.
HE CAME WITH A HIGH PROSPECT
TAG.
DURING THE JEFF LUHNOW ERA IN
HOUSTON, HE WAS A HIGHLY COVETED
PLAYER BY TEAMS, BUT THEY DID
NOT WANT TO LET HIM GO.
HE'S FINALLY GETTING HIS
OPPORTUNITY NOW.
BRETT: HE IS RUNNING, THROWING
TO SECOND, TRIPLES THROUGH.
TUCKER WISELY DECIDES TO STAY AT
SECOND BASE.
HIS FIRST BAG OF THE YEAR.
IT DID NOT TAKE HIM LONG TO RUN
AGAINST THE NEW ANGEL PITCHER,
RIGHT-HANDER JUNIOR GUERRA.
>> A BIG JUMP, LONG, FLOWING
MOVE.
>> THEY MAY HAVE KEYED ON THAT.
THEY WANTED TO GET IN SCORING
POSITION FOR DIAZ.
BRETT: 1-0 PITCH IS IN FOR A
STRIKE.
JUST THE FIFTH STOLEN BASE FOR
THE ASTROS AS A TEAM THIS YEAR.
GUERRA MAKING HIS SIXTH
APPEARANCE OF THE SEASON.
HE HAS BEEN EFFECTIVE IN ALBEIT
LIMITED DUTY.
FIRST RUNS OF THE SEASON DID NOT
COME UNTIL HIS LAST OUTING, HIS
ONLY OUTING, ON THE LAST HOME
STAND.
>> CONTROL PROBLEMS, WALKS.
HIS FASTBALL IS PRETTY GOOD, 91
TO 95.
HE HAS A GREAT SPLITFINGER THAT
HE THROWS A LOT.
BRETT: A BALL AND TWO STRIKES TO
ALEDMYS DIAZ.
ON THE GROUND.
IGLESIAS TO THIRD.
NOT IN TIME.
ROLLING THE DICE THERE.
JOSE THOUGHT HE HAD ENOUGH TIME
TO GET THE LEAD RUNNER, BUT THAT
WAS NOT THE CASE AND EVERYBODY
IS SAFE.
>> NOT WORTH TAKING ANOTHER LOOK
AT.
>> NOT A LOT OF EXPERIENCE FOR
JOSÉ ROJAS AT THIRD BASE AS
WELL.
A LOT OF TIMES AS A THIRD
BASEMAN, WITH A VETERAN LIKE
ANTHONY RENDON, WOULD BE CLOSER
TO THE BAG.
TUCKER TRYING TO GO, MAKES A
QUICK THROW, ABLE TO SLIDE IN TO
AVOID THE TAG.
NOW MORE PRESSURE FOR THE
ASTROS.
BRETT: MYLES STRAW HAD A BIG
TRIPLE THAT DROVE A RUN BACK IN
THE SECOND.
THE FIRST OF TWO THREE RUN
INNINGS AGAINST ALEX COXE
TONIGHT THAT WOULD DRIVE HIM
FROM THE GAME IN THE BOTTOM HALF
OF THE THIRD.
0-1 THE COUNT TO MYLES STRAW.
WHO WAS THE FASTEST GUY YOU EVER
PLAYED WITH?
GEOFF: OH MAN.
I WAS ON A BALLCLUB WITH DAVE
ROBERTS.
HE WAS PRETTY QUICK THERE WOULD
WE HAD A CENTER FIELDER MIKE
CAMERON WHO I THOUGHT COULD
ABSOLUTELY FLY, COVERED A LOT OF
GROUND IN CENTER FIELD.
THAT IS A GREAT QUESTION.
MICHAEL BOURN.
BRETT: VERY FAST.
HOT SHOT FOR ROJAS.
RECOVERS AND GETS DIAZ AT
SECOND.
SCORING EASILY FROM THIRD IS
KYLE TUCKER AND IT IS 7-0,
HOUSTON.
>> NEVER EASY TO PULL A DOUBLE
PLAY.
AT LEAST IT HAD A SHOT IF ROJAS
COULD GET IT TO FLETCHER.
TREMENDOUS AS FAR AS GETTING RID
OF THE BASEBALL ON THE TRANSFER
TO SECOND BASE.
BRETT: MARTIN MALDONADO.
TWO R.B.I.'S FOR MYLES STRAW
TONIGHT.
I THINK THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN,
CIRCLING BACK TO OUR EARLIER
DISCUSSION ON DUSTY BAKER'S
LINEUP CONSTRUCTION, WE WILL
HAVE TO TABLE THIS.
WE WILL TALK ABOUT THE ASTROS
LINEUP.
HOUSTON STRIKES FOR ONE MORE
COURTESY OF MYLES STRAW ONCE7-0.
>> GORGEOUS EVENING FOR BASEBALL
AT MINUTE MAID PARK, ASTROS
OPENING DAY.
>> 6-1, ST. LOUIS.
>> ASTROS HAVE LOST SEVEN IN A
ROW.
>> THAT IS A BIG HILL TO
OVERCOME.
>> A HIGH DRIVE.
>> THE ASTROS CLINCH.
>> THIS GAME TIED 6-6 IN THE
BOTTOM OF THE 18TH INNING.
>> TO LEFT, IT IS GONE.
HOLY TOLEDO.
WHAT A WAY TO FINISH.
>> THIS BALLGAME IS READY TO
ERUPT.
>> IT IS GONE!
THE ASTROS LEAD, 4-2.
>> IN THE AIR, LEFT FIELD.
PUJOLS IS GETTING IT.
>> EVERY SINGLE GUY IN THE
BALLCLUB SAYS THIS IS HOW IT IS
SUPPOSED TO BE.
IT IS GONE, LET'S GET ONTO THE
NEXT GAME.
>> FLY BALL INTO RIGHT FIELD.
>> HOUSTON ASTROS ARE GOING TO
THE WORLD SERIES FOR THE FIRST
TIME IN FRANCHISE HISTORY.
>> 7-0 ASTROS AS WE HIT THE TOP
OF THE FIFTH INNING.
EARLIER WE ASKED WHICH FREE
AGENT SHORTSTOP WILL GET THE
BIGGEST DEAL THIS WINTER OR
WHENEVER.
40% OF YOU SAY COREY SEAGER.
I KIND OF THINK THAT IS TRUE.
PHIL US IN ON CONVERSATION IN
HOUSTON AROUND THE SIX FOR 120
CARLOS CORREA SAID NOT EVEN
CLOSE TO, FOR THE ASTROS OFFER
RECENTLY.
GEOFF: I DON'T THINK HE
APPRECIATED THAT.
IF YOU BREAK DOWN THE NUMBERS,
YOU CAN SEE WHY.
HE WANTED CLOSER TO WHAT
FRANCISCO LINDOR WAS GETTING,
HIS FRIENDS.
HE WANTS TO BELIEVE HE CAN BE
ONE OF THE MORE DOMINANT
SHORTSTOPS.
THE ONLY KNOCK AGAINST CARLOS
CORREA WAS, HOW OFTEN WILL HE BE
ON THE FIELD?
HE AVERAGES OVER 100 GAMES
PLAYED PER SEASON SINCE COMING
INTO THE BIG LEAGUES.
THE OTHER THING TO REMEMBER
ABOUT CARLOS CORREA, ON THE
FIELD HE WILL GIVE YOU THE BEST
EFFORT AS FAR AS DEFENSE AND
OFFENSE.
HIS POSTSEASON NUMBERS, HE IS
GOING UP ON THOSE HISTORIC
LADDERS AND MARKING HIS NAME IN
HISTORY BOOKS IN THE PLAYOFFS.
BRETT: JOSE ROJAS LEADS THINGS
OFF IN THE ANGELS FIFTH.
A BIG POINT THERE, THE BRIGHTER
THE LIGHTS, THE BIGGER THE
STAGE, THE BETTER THAT GUY GETS.
IT IS HARD TO QUANTIFY THAT.
WE ARE A BUSINESS MADE OF
REGULAR SEASON NUMBERS.
A BASE HIT FOR ROJAS, HIS SECOND
OF THE GAME.
I AGREE WITH YOU.
SIX YEARS AT $120 MILLION FORK
-- FOR CORREA, WHEN YOU CONSIDER
THE MONEY COREY SEAGER IS GOING
TO GET, IT IS NOT CLOSE.
IF IT MEANS CARLOS CORREA HAS TO
GO SOMEPLACE ELSE, IT SEEMS HE
IS PREPARED TO DO THAT.
I AM CONCERNED WITH JAVY BAEZ.
HE HAD AN UNEVEN 2020.
OFF TO AN UNEVEN START THIS
YEAR.
IN A CONTRACT YEAR YOU HOPE THAT
IS NOT IN YOUR HEAD BECAUSE HE
IS AN ELECTRIFYING PERFORMER.
>> HE IS ONE OF THE BEST AT HIS
DEFENSIVE POSITION.
YOU TALK ABOUT A QUICK TAG TO
SECOND.
THOSE SHORTSTOP GUYS, COREY
SEAGER IS INCREDIBLE.
HE HITS THE BALL SO HARD TO ALL
FIELDS.
M.V.P. OF THE WORLD SERIES.
HE IS GETTING BETTER, STAYING
HEALTHIER.
TREVOR, ONE OF THE BEST BASE
RUNNERS IN THE GAME.
A SHORTSTOP WITH GREAT POWER
WITH COLORADO.
BRETT: A BALL AND A STRIKE.
KURT SUZUKI STRUCK OUT,
CULMINATING A 13 PITCH AT BAT
BACK IN THE THIRD.
>> WE HAD A CHANCE TO SEE TREVOR
STORY OUT THERE IN COLORADO
RECENTLY.
I WAS SURPRISED HE DID NOT HAVE
A HOME RUN YET THIS FAR IN THE
SEASON.
IT PLAYS INTO THE JAVIER BAEZ
MIX WHERE THEY ARE OFF TO A SLOW
START.
I WOULD IMAGINE ALL THESE GUYS
ARE GRATEFUL TO HAVE A 162 GAME
SEASON TO CORRECT THINGS AND PUT
UP BIG NUMBERS TO GO GET PAID.
BRETT: A GOOD SLIDER SWUNG ON
AND MISSED.
WE HAVE BEEN SAYING THAT ALL
NIGHT.
THE ONE GUY WHOSE TIMING WAS
POOREST AS FAR AS THAT IS
CONCERNED WITH NO WAY OF
CONTROLLING IT, MARCUS SEMIEN.
HE CANNOT DO THE YEAR AFTER
COVID, LAST YEAR, HE GOT THE ONE
YEAR $18 MILLION YEAR TO GO TO
TORONTO TO PLAY SECOND BASE.
HE WILL BE BACK ON THE MARKET
AGAIN AT THE END OF THE SEASON.
2-2.
>> MARCUS SEMIEN I SAW A NUMBER
OF TIMES AGAINST THE ANGELS.
REALLY GOOD POWER, TURNED INTO A
SOLID DEFENSIVE SHORTSTOP.
WORKED WITH THE A'S.
A REALLY GOOD SHORTSTOP, RUNS
WELL WITH GOOD POWER.
FOR ME, HE IS STILL GOING TO GET
PAID A LOT OF MONEY GOING INTO
THE OFF-SEASON.
BRETT: I AGREE.
EVEN THOUGH HE IS THE OLDEST OF
THE GROUP, IT IS A MULTIYEAR
DEAL FOR HIM.
2-2 TO SUZUKI.
LEFT FIELD, HIT PRETTY WELL.
ROOM AND TIME, HOWEVER, FIRST
DRAW.
THAT IS THE FIRST OUT OF THE
INNING.
ONE OF THE EARLY
PSEUDO-CRITICISMS ON CRISTIAN
JAVIER WAS STRIKEOUTS AND FLY
BALLS.
DOES NOT HIT IT ON THE GROUND AS
MUCH AS HE WOULD LIKE.
DOES NOT MATTER TONIGHT BECAUSE
THE FLY BALLS HAVE BEEN WARNING
TRACK VARIETY AND HE RACKED UP A
NEAR DOUBLE-DIGIT STRIKE TOTAL.
YOU CARES IF HE IS GIVING UP FLY
BALLS.
GEOFF: YOU CAN DEFINITELY SAY
THAT TONIGHT.
HE HAS DONE A GOOD JOB WITH THE
FASTBALL UP.
THE SLIDER WE HAVE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT ALL GAME LONG, WE HAVE
CREATED THE SWING AND MISS.
HE HAS GOTTEN CHASE OFF THE
PLATE.
IT IS AMAZING TO SEE THE SLIDER
SPEND NOT NECESSARILY ON THE
EDGES, BUT CATCH MORE OF THE
PLATE AND HE WOULD LIKE TO SEE.
HE GETS THE SWING AND MISS OR
YANKS IT FOUL.
BRETT: AMONG THE NINE STRIKEOUTS
TONIGHT HE HAS TWICE VICTIMIZED
DAVID FLETCHER, ONE OF THE
HARDEST PLAYERS TO STRIKE OUT IN
ALL OF BASEBALL.
ONE OUT, ONE ON.
ASTROS ON TOP 7-0.
BACKHANDED BY DIAZ TO CORREA.
A FINE PLAY UP THE MIDDLE.
>> A WISE DECISION TO GET RIGHT
TO THE BAG.
DIAZ ABLE TO GET COVERAGE.
HE IS ON THE SHORTSTOP SIDE OF
THE BAG, A QUICK FLIP.
HE GETS ROJAS JUST BARELY AT
SECOND BASE.
OUTSTANDING DEFENSIVE PLAY.
THE ASTROS ONE OF THE BETTER
DEFENSIVE TEAMS.
A BIG PLAY WOULD PREVENT A RALLY
WITH A GROUND BALL OUT.
JAVIER LOVING THAT DEFENSE.
>> THERE IS THE GROUNDBALL THAT
MATTY WANTED.
>> IS THAT HIS FIRST GROUND BALL
OUT TONIGHT?
IT IS.
>> YES.
>> HERE IS OHTANI, WHO HAS FLIED
TO CENTER AND STRUCK OUT.
SHOHEI BOUNCES IT TO GURRIEL.
NOTHING COMES OF THE LEADOFF
SINGLE.
CRISTIAN JAVIER, A CAREER-HIGH
IN ROUND TWO OF A CAREER TYPE
NIGHT, ON TOP 7-0.
♪
>> HE JUST SMOKES IT.
>> FORGET ABOUT IT.
>> OH MY GOODNESS.
GREAT BASEBALL RIGHT THERE.
>> THAT ONE IS GOING TO GO.
>> THAT BALL WAS CRUSHED.
>> THIS IS GOING TO DO IT.
>> STRIKE THREE.
THAT WAS A GREAT PLAY.
>> HE TALKED -- TALK ABOUT HIS
FIELDING SKILLS, THAT WAS
REMARKABLE.
♪
>> SOMETHING LIKE THIS IS WHAT
THEY CAME FOR.
>> THIS COPYRIGHTED TELECAST IS
PRESENTED BY THE AUTHORITY OF
THE OFFICER OF THE COMMISSIONER
AND CANNOT BE REPRODUCED OR
RETRANSMITTED IN ANY FORM.
THE DESCRIPTIONS OF THIS GAME
MAY NOT BE DISSEMINATED WITHOUT
EXPRESS WRITTEN CONSENT DON'T
FORGET TO CHECK OUT YOUTUBE'S
COMMENTARY WITH MLB, THE ASTROS,
AND YOUTUBE CREATORS.
YOU CAN VIEW THE COMMENTARY ON
YOUR MOBILE DEVICE OR SMART TV.
WE WILL BE KEEPING AN EYE ON THE
DISCUSSION THROUGHOUT THE
BROADCAST.
BE CLEVER AND THERE IS A CHANCE
WE WILL USE YOUR COMMENTS ON THE
SHOW.
MIKE TROUT HAS COME OUT OF THE
BALLGAME AFTER GETTING HIT IN
THE ELBOW.
IF WE GET WORD FROM THE TRAINERS
TABLE, WE WILL PASS IT ALONG.
WE ASSUME MIKE HAS BEEN TAKEN
OUT OF THE BALLGAME AS A
PRECAUTION IN A 7-0 DAY, WE
UNDERSTAND.
CARLOS CORREA LEADS THINGS OFF.
TOP OF THE ORDER, BRANTLEY,
CORREA, AND BREGMAN.
THE ANGELS HAVE HAD TO GO TO
THAT ALTERNATE SITE TRAVEL TAXI
QUITE OFTEN THIS YEAR.
SCHEFFLER HAD A NICE SPRING
TRAINING WITH THE ANGELS AND
THERE WERE A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO
THOUGHT HE HAD A CHANCE TO MAKE
THE OPENING DAY SQUAD OUT OF
CAMP.
AS IT TURNS OUT HE WAS PRESSED
INTO DUTY THIS WEEK BECAUSE OF A
FLURRY OF INJURIES.
3-1 TO CORREA.
FULL COUNT 3-2 TO CORREA.
IT HAS TAKEN A COUPLE INNINGS
FOR ME TO NOTICE THIS, BUT
CARLOS CORREA HAS A DECIDED
FASHION STATEMENT AT THE PLATE.
SENDS A BREAKING BALL TO THE
LEFT FOR ANOTHER BASE HIT.
HIS THIRD OF THE GAME.
HE IS A BOARD, MIKE TROUT IS OUT
OF THE GAME.
MIKE TROUT'S MIC PICKED UP THIS
BEFORE MIKE EXITED THE OCCASION.
>> AYI, AYI.
YOU TALK ABOUT THE NEW MATT?
>> I THOUGHT IT WAS A SLIDER,
DUDE.
>> HIS STUFF LOOKS LIKE THAT.
I FACE HIM A LOT.
>> IS HE TALKING ABOUT IF HE HAD
A PAD ON HIS ELBOW?
CAN SOMEBODY ORDER MIKE TROUT A
PAD?
>> I THINK HE DIDN'T HAVE THE
PAD ON THE ELBOW.
THAT IS WHAT IT WAS.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT HIS NUMBERS, HE
DOES NOT HIT THE BALL WELL IN
THIS BALLPARK.
A TWO WAY HITTER IN MINUTE MAID
PARK.
THERE IS VALIDITY THAT HE DOES
NOT SEE IT.
BRETT: YOUR REACTION WHEN HE WAS
HIT BY THE PITCH YOU SAID IT
LOOKED LIKE MIKE NOT THINK THE
BALL WAS GOING TO COME IN ON HIM
LIKE THAT, WHICH WOULD BACK UP
THE STATEMENT.
MARK: YEAH, HE WAS THINKING
SLIDER AND WAS READY TO TRACK IT
OUT OVER THE PLATE.
WITHOUT THAT PAD ON HIS ELBOW,
HE WOULD BE IN TROUBLE ON THAT.
BRETT: ALEX BREGMAN HAS BEEN ON
BASE IN ALL OF HIS PLATE
APPEARANCES.
HE WAS HIT BY A PITCH IN THE
SECOND.
ADD ANOTHER BASE HIT.
HE AND CORREA ARE GOING NUTS UP
A TOP OF THIS ORDER.
CARLOS WILL SCORE.
THE ASTROS ARE ON THE BOARD
AGAIN.
>> ASTROS DOING A GOOD JOB
FIGHTING OF PITCHES.
EXIT VELOCITY WILL NOT LIGHT UP
ANY RADAR DONE.
THE FACT THEY ARE GETTING HITS
WITH RUNNERS IN SCORING POSITION
MEANS EVERYTHING TO THEM RIGHT
NOW.
>> I WAS GOING TO SAY THE SAME.
THE EXIT VELOCITY RADAR GUN
WOULD NOT BE HIGH.
YOU LOOK AND HAVE EIGHT RUNS.
>> ALEX BREGMAN ALREADY MATCHED
HIS THREE HIT TOTAL FROM ALL OF
LAST YEAR.
NOW IT IS BIG YORDAN ALVAREZ.
FIRE STILL OUT.
ONE OUTS, ONE ON, ONE IN.
I WANT TO GET BACK TO WHAT MIKE
TROUT WAS TALKING ABOUT.
YOU HAVE BROADCAST FOR MANY
YEARS.
WHY FOR VISITING PLAYER MIGHT IT
BE HARDER THAN SOMEWHERE ELSE TO
PICK UP THE BALL?
GEOFF: GLAD YOU BROUGHT THE FACT
THAT I DID PLAY HERE WHEN I DID
NOT.
THEY HAD THAT LITTLE RAMP UP A
HILL IN CENTER FIELD, 430 FEET
AWAY.
THE BATTING EYE WAS BIGGER.
IN 2016-17 THEY TOOK AWAY THAT,
BROUGHT IN THE BATTING EYE.
THEY DID NOT CONDENSE IT, BUT IT
WAS NOT AS BIG AS IT WAS IN THE
PAST.
THEY ALSO ADDED LED LIGHTING
WHICH BRIGHTEN THINGS UP IN THE
BALLPARK.
THE ASTROS NOTABLY HAD ISSUES
PICKING UP SPIN BECAUSE THE
L.E.D. WAS SO BRIGHT ON THE
BASEBALL, IT WAS TOUGH TO PICK
UP THE SEAMS.
BRETT: WHEN DID THE L.E.D. GO
IN?
GEOFF: I BELIEVE AROUND 2017.
WHAT IS DIFFERENT ABOUT OTHER
BALLPARKS, HERE AT MINUTE MAID
PARK, THEY DO NOT HAVE THE
EXPANSIVE OUTFIELD.
THE BLEACHERS ARE NOT THAT HIGH.
THE LIGHTS ARE CLOSER TO THE
FIELD.
BRETT: ALTHOUGH REZ SENDS ONE TO
THE SCOREBOARD.
UPTON FOR ROUND NUMBER TWO.
>> DO BATTERERS FEEL IT IS
EASIER TO SEE WITH THE ROOF
CLOSED OR OPEN?
>> IN HOUSTON, IF YOU HAVE A
CHANCE TO GET OUT OF THE FREON
ZONE, THEY TAKE ADVANTAGE OF IT.
IF YOU ASK PLAYERS, THEY WANT TO
PLAY WITH THE ROOF CLOSED,
BECAUSE THEY LOVE THAT
CONTROLLED ENVIRONMENT READ --
ENVIRONMENT.
BRETT: HERE COMES GURRIEL.
AS FANS WE LIKE TO READ ALL THE
SCANDAL THEORIES INTO THE
CONDITIONS.
ROOF OPEN, ROOF CLOSED.
WE BOUGHT INTO IT IN ARIZONA FOR
YEARS, WHEN SCHILLING AND
JOHNSON WAS THERE.
CURT SCHILLING WANT THE ROOF
CLOSED WHEN HE STARTED.
PEOPLE JUMPED ON THAT AS A
SCANDAL THEORY.
GURRIEL SENDS A FLY BALL TO
SHALLOW RIGHT.
RETIRED TO THE SIDE.
COULD COME
HOME FOR THE ASTROS.
ALL HOUSTON AT MINUTE MAID
TONIGHT.
>> HAS TO FEEL GREAT ABOUT HIS
BALLCLUB NOW.
RIGHT NEXT TO THAT 1980 DIVISION
CHAMPIONSHIP BANNER WITH A WIN
THIS AFTERNOON.
BALL ONE AND STRIKE TWO TO
MALDONADO.
HERE IS THAT 2-2 PITCH.
HE HAS GOT IT.
SWING AND A MISS.
>> WE ARE IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
FOURTH INNING AT THE ASTRODOME.
THE CROWD IS IN ON IT NOW.
>> STRIKE THREE.
MIKE SCOTT HAS STRUCK OUT THE
SIDE.
HE IS THROWING ON CLINCHER DAY.
NO HITTER FOR MIKE SCOTT.
HE HAS IT GOING FOR EIGHT
INNINGS.
TWO OUTS, NOBODY ON, TOP OF THE
NINTH.
SCOTT HAS NOT GIVEN UP A HITS.
THERE IT IS.
BRETT: NEW TO THE MLB GAME OF
THE WEEK, YOUTUBE PLAYER OF THE
GAME.
FANS WATCHING CAN VOTE FOR WHICH
PLAYER WILL RECEIVE A TROPHY
DURING THE POSTGAME SHOW.
STAY TUNED FOR THE OPTIONS LATER
ON.
I WOULD SUGGEST CARLOS CORREA.
WHO ELSE?
CRISTIAN JAVIER FOR SURE.
MICHAEL BRANTLEY HAS HAD A NICE
NIGHT, BREGMAN.
A LOT OF OPTIONS ON A NIGHT THAT
HAS BEEN A HOUSTON STORY AT
MINUTE MAID PARK.
THE ASTROS GO TO THE BULLPEN.
A CAREER-HIGH PITCH COUNT AND
STRIKEOUT TALLY FOR THE YOUNG
24-YEAR-OLD STARTER CRISTIAN
JAVIER.
HE HAS GONE FIVE IN FAVOR OF
BRIAN ABREU.
SCOTT SCHEBLER THE FIRST TO FACE
HIM, IN PLACE OF MIKE TROUT.
TROUT WAS HIT BY A PITCH IN THE
FOURTH.
SCHEBLER, WALSH FOR THE ANGELS.
>> WHAT ABOUT BUDDING CARLOS
CORREA IN THE LEADOFF SPOT?
>> I LIKE THAT IDEA.
>> THAT IS GREAT.
>> DO WE GET TO VISIT WITH THE
PLAYER OF THE GAME TONIGHT?
IF WE DO, I VOTE FOR DUSTIN
BECAUSE I LOVE TALKING TO THE
GUY.
TWO BALLS, TWO STRIKES TO KURT
SCHEBLER, HAVING A GOOD SPRING
TRAINING FOR THE ANGELS.
WHEN DECISIONS WERE MADE WHO TO
BREAK CAMP WITH, JUAN LAGARES
GOT A NOD BECAUSE OF HIS
DEFENSIVE PROWESS.
SCHEBLER HAS WORKED IT TO A FULL
COUNT, THREE BALLS AND TWO
STRIKES.
>> THAT WAS AN ISSUE IN THE
OUTFIELD.
A FORMER GOLD GLOVER WITH THE
NEW YORK METS.
HE HAD A SOLID SWING, BUT HE WAS
THE DIFFERENCE MAKER.
>> IT WAS ALSO UNFORTUNATE NEWS
ABOUT DEXTER FOWLER.
>> THEY EXPECTED HIM TO BE THE
SWITCH HITTER, SOLID DEFENDER,
THE EVERY DAY GUY, GIVE EVERYONE
A CHANCE TO GET A REST BECAUSE
HE COULD PLAY ALL THREE OUTFIELD
POSITIONS SO WELL.
>> CAUGHT LOOKING AT A CALLED
STRIKE THREE.
BRETT DOLAN HAS MORE ON THE
FORMER RED AND DODGER.
BRETT: HE TOLD THE MEDIA HE HAS
BEEN PLAYING WITHOUT A SHOULDER
THE PAST COUPLE OF YEARS.
THE DOCTOR FOUND OUT THERE WAS A
SIGNIFICANT TEAR GOING BACK TO
2017.
I CAN'T IMAGINE HOW HE PLAYED
THROUGH THAT.
AS AN IOWA NATIVE I CAN
APPRECIATE THAT TOUGHNESS TO
FIND THEIR WAY TO THE MAJOR
LEAGUE, SHOULDER OR NOT.
>> YOU CORN FED IOWA GUYS ALL
FIND EACH OTHER.
IF HE HURT HIS SHOULDER IN 2017,
THAT IS THE YEAR HE HIT 30 BIG
POINTS.
HE HAD A GREAT YEAR IN
CINCINNATI.
CHOPPER ON THE GROUND TO FIRST.
GONE FOR THE RELIEVER ABREU AND
HE WILL GO TO WORK ON ABREU.
THIS HAS BEEN ALL ASTROS FROM
THE JUMP.
THREE IN THE SECOND, THREE MORE
IN THE THIRD.
LONE RUNS IN THE FOURTH AND
FIFTH.
CRISTIAN JAVIER WAS OUTSTANDING
ON THE MOUND.
HERE IS UPTON.
THIS HAS NOT BEEN A KIND PLACE
FOR THE ANGELS IN GENERAL.
WE TALKED ABOUT IT AS IT RELATED
TO MIKE TROUT.
AS MUCH AS THE ANGELS WANT A
SERIES FROM THE ASTROS LAST
YEAR, SOMETHING THAT HAS NOT
HAPPENED OFTEN, THEY DROPPED 14
OF THEIR LAST 17 GAMES IN THE
BALLPARK THAT DATES BACK TO
2017.
THE ASTROS HAVE BEEN VERY GOOD
OVER THIS STRETCH.
THIS IS NOT BEEN A KIND PLACE TO
THE ANGELS WHEN THEY COME TO
VISIT.
>> I THINK IT COMES DOWN TO THE
WAY THEY HAVE HAD THEIR
PITCHERS.
THEY HAD A GREAT PITCHING STAFF.
A LOT OF THOSE FOUR SEAM
FASTBALL'S.
A LOT OF ANGELS HITTERS USE THE
UPPER THIRD AND THAT IS WHERE
THEY DO THE DAMAGE.
>> A LOT OF CREDIT TO THE
PITCHING COACH FOR THE ASTROS.
HE CREATED ANOTHER LEGACY WITH
WHAT HE HAS BEEN ABLE TO DO WITH
THE CHORES AT MINUTE MAID PARK.
IT STARTED WITH HIM AND THE
PHILOSOPHY OF THROWING THE FOUR
SEAM FASTBALL IN THE ZONE.
IT GOT SWING AND MISS, POP-UPS,
OPENED UP THE BOTTOM OF THE ZONE
FOR THE HIGH SPIN BREAKING BALL
TYPE GUYS THEY HAVE TRIED TO GET
IN HOUSTON.
>> HE IS A GOOD ONE.
YOU HAD THE PLEASURE OF GETTING
TO TAP HIS BRAIN DAILY.
HE IS NOT A GUY THAT GOES OUT
THERE AND DIGS HIMSELF AND TALKS
ABOUT HIS PHILOSOPHY.
HE IS A GRINDER AND HAS MADE SO
MANY PITCHERS BETTER COMING TO
HOUSTON THAT I THINK RESULTS
SPEAK FOR THEMSELVES.
HE DOES NOT HAVE TO PUMP HIMSELF
UP.
>> VERY TRUE WHAT YOU SAID ABOUT
BEING A GRINDER.
HE HAS BEEN IN THE GAME A LONG
TIME AND CAME TO HOUSTON TO
BECOME THE PITCHING COACH AND
EMBRACE TO THE ANALYTICS AND
FOUND A WAY TO MARRY THAT WITH
HIS EXPERIENCE TO MAKE THESE
GUYS BETTER.
I HEARD HIM TALK ABOUT ADJUSTING
SLIDERS TO OVER A QUARTER OF AN
INCH OF RELEASE AND EXTENSION
THROUGH THE ZONE.
HE HAS ADAPTED TO THIS CURRENT
GAME AND MADE HIS KNOWLEDGE THAT
MUCH MORE VALUABLE.
MATT: 0-2 THE COUNT TO ALBERT
PUJOLS.
HAD IT NOT BEEN FOR TOMMY JOHN
-- IT IS A STORY I KNOW ASTROS
FANS HAVE HEARD MANY TIMES.
THAT LIGAMENT REPLACEMENT
SURGERY WOULD HAVE BEEN KNOWN AS
BRENT STROM SURGERY, THE SECOND
GUIDE TO HAVE IT AFTER TOMMY
JOHN DID.
STILL 0-2 TO PUJOLS.
>> IT IS INTERESTING TO BRING UP
THAT POINT.
BRENT STROM MAKES FUN OF IT,
KNOWING HE WAS THE SECOND TO GET
THAT TOMMY JOHN SURGERY.
IMAGINE IF THEY DID NOT CALL IT
T.J. SURGERY AND I WAS THE FIRST
GET IT?
[LAUGHTER]
MATT: THAT IS A GOOD POINT.
IT ALL WORKED OUT FOR A REASON.
I AM GOING IN FOR MY BS SURGERY,
IT IS NOT THE SAME GRAVITAS.
[LAUGHTER]
MATT: SAN DIEGO GUY.
I WOULD IMAGINE BRENT STROM WAS
WATCHING WITH INTEREST WHEN JOE
MUSGROVE HIT THE FIRST PADRES
NO-HITTER A COUPLE WEEKS AGO IN
ARLINGTON.
THE 1-2 TO PUJOLS.
>> JOE MUSGROVE HAS A CONNECTION
COMING UP OR THE ASTROS
ORGANIZATION, EVENTUALLY BEING
TRADED AWAY.
IT MEANT A LOT TO ASTROS FANS TO
HAVE JOE MUSGROVE DO THAT.
FOR YOU AND I BEING PADRES, I
WAS IN SHOCK AND JOY WATCHING
HIM DO IT FOR THE FRANCHISE.
MATT: SUCH A GREAT STORY FOR A
LOCAL GUY.
PUJOLS TO RIGHT FIELD.
THAT HAS A CHANCE IF IT STAYS
FAIR AND IT IS GONE.
ALBERT PUJOLS TO THE OPPOSITE
FIELD TO GET THE ANGELS ON THE
BOARD IN THE SIXTH.
>> YOU LOOK OVER THE SEASONS,
HOW MANY HOME DID ALBERT HIT
THAT WAY?
665 CAREER HOMERUNS FOR ALBERT,
61 IN HIS CAREER VERSUS THE
ASTROS FURTHER MACHINE. -- FOR
THE MACHINE.
>> THE PITCH IS UP AND AWAY AND
HE GOES WITH IT.
I AM NOT TOO SURE.
MATT: I AM WITH YOU.
ALL BOUNDARY CALLS ARE
REVIEWABLE.
OH BOY, THAT IS A FOUL BALL.
>> YOU CAN SEE THE BASEBALL
GOING BY THE YELLOW POLE.
MATT: THE ONLY THING THAT MIGHT
MAKE THIS CALL STAND AS IF THEY
CAN DETERMINE THE BALL ACTUALLY
TOUCHED THE POLE.
TO ME, IT LOOKED LIKE IT MISSED
IT.
WE WILL GIVE YOU PLENTY OF LOOKS
AT HOME ON YOUTUBE.
I DON'T THINK YOU CAN TELL IF IT
HIT THE POLE OR NOT.
YOU SEE ALBERT'S -- ALBERT?
HE IS SAYING, IT HIT THE POLE.
THE CALL ON THE FIELD WAS HOMER.
>> ALBERT WAS STILL LOOKING.
HE KNOWS THE BALLPARK WELL.
>> EY -- YEP.
I KNOW THIS BALLPARK REALLY
WELL.
>> YOU HAVE BEEN INVOLVED IN
INTERESTING REPLAY REVIEWS
THROUGHOUT THE COURSE OF THE
SEASON ALREADY THIS YEAR.
MATT: YES, THIS IS TRUE.
NOTHING WILL EXPOSE AN
OVEREXPOSED PLAY-BY-PLAY GUY
LIKE REVIEWS.
I CANNOT TELL IF IT HIT THE POLE
OR NOT.
I DON'T THINK ANYONE CAN TELL,
BASED ON THIS.
>> THAT IS REALLY TOUGH.
MATT: IF THE CALL ON THE FIELD
IS HOMER -- THIS IS A TOUGH ONE.
>> THAT IS THE BIGGEST KEY, THE
CALL ON THE FIELD IS WHAT IS
BEING SENT BACK TO NEW YORK AND
IS THERE ANYTHING TO OVERTURN
THAT?
MATT: ALBERT IS SAYING, THIS
WOULD BE MY FIRST OPPOSITE FIELD
HOMER IN TWO YEARS, DON'T TAKE
IT AWAY.
YEAH, IT IS GOING TO STAND.
[LAUGHTER]
>> HE KNEW IT.
>> ANTHONY RENDON, HOUSTON
NATIVE.
HE SAID, I HAVE BEEN IN THIS
BALLPARK A LOT.
>> IF ALBERT PUJOLS HITS A BALL
ANYWHERE NEAR AND OUTFIELD FENCE
IN MINUTE MAID PARK, SOMEONE
WILL THINK IT IS A HOME RUN,
THAT IS FOR SURE.
MATT: CLIMBING THE ALL-TIME HOME
RUN LEADER BOARD.
HE WILL HAVE TO GO CRAZY IN THE
FINAL YEAR OF HIS 10 YEAR
CONTRACT TO CATCH ALEX
RODRIGUEZ.
HE TRAILS HIM BY 31.
SOMEBODY THREW IT BACK.
I THINK ALBERT MIGHT WANT THAT.
>> HE IS STILL SAYING IT
DEFLECTED OFF THE FOUL POLE.
MATT: 0-1 THE COUNT TO JOSÉ
IGLESIAS.
WE WILL GIVE YOU VIDEO TRICKS TO
SEE IF ANYBODY CAN TELL IF IT
HIT THE POLE OR NOT.
I JUST CAN'T TELL.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT IT AGAIN.
>> SURE LOOKED LIKE IT DID.
MATT: WE CANNOT GET TOO MUCH
TIGHTER ON IT.
QUITE FRANKLY, IT DOES NOT
MATTER WHAT WE THINK, BECAUSE
THE CALL STANDS.
>> DID THAT BASEBALL DEFLECT OFF
THE FOUL POLE, OR FROM A FAN'S
HANDS INTO ANOTHER FAN'S HANDS?
ALL KINDS OF STUFF,
DEFLECTION-WISE.
>> THAT THING IS GREASED.
MATT: STILL 0-2 TO JOSÉ
IGLESIAS.
THAT IS OUT TO SHORTSTOP.
CORREA GOT IT.
THE THROW BARELY GETS HIM.
ANGELS ON THE BOARD.
THE THIRD OF THE SEASON FOR
ALBERT AND HIS FIRST TO THE
OPPOSITE FIELD IN TWO YEARS.
8-2, HOUSTON.
>> A CHANCE FOR THE FIRST 1-2-3
INNING OF THE NIGHT OR CHASE IF
HE CAN GET MANNY IN THE THIRD.
>> THAT IS ON ITS WAY.
GOODBYE, OVER EVERYTHING, ONTO
THE STREETS OF BOSTON.
>> GOING BACK, ABREU.
HEAR THE RED SOX BULLPEN.
BACK TO BACK HOMERUNS.
THE SOX ARE BACK 3-2.
>> THAT ONE IS HEADED FOR NEW
HAMPSHIRE.
WHAT A SHOCK.
THEY ARE PLAYING HOME RUN DERBY
EARLY THIS YEAR AT FENWAY PARK.
THREE BOOMING HOMERUNS IN A ROW.
>> WON'T EVEN TURN AROUND.
NUMBER FOUR IN A ROW.
FOUR CONSECUTIVE HOME RUNS.
>> WE ARE TALKING RECORD-SETTING
TERRITORY.
THE FIRST TIME IN RED SOX
HISTORY.
>> FOUR HOME RUNS IN A ROW.
MATT: DOWNLOAD THE MLB APP TO
GET BREAKING, PLAYER UPDATES,
AND MUCH MORE.
WE HAVE HAD THESE POLE QUESTIONS
ALL NIGHT.
THEY HAVE BEEN A LOT OF FUN.
WHO WOULD MAKE THE BEST ROAD
TRIP COMPANION FROM L.A. TO
HOUSTON, JOE MADDON, NOLAN RYAN,
DUSTY BAKER, OR TORII HUNTER?
CONNECTIONS TO BOTH SIDES, OF
COURSE.
>> THAT IS A GREAT QUESTION.
MATT: NO WRONG ANSWER.
8-2, HOUSTON.
JUNIOR GUERRA CONTINUES.
HE WILL HAVE TUCKER, MYLES
STRAW.
FROM HOUSTON, BRETT DOLAN AND
GEOFF BLUM.
MATT VASGERSIAN HERE AT MLB
NETWORK.
WE ARE COMING TO YOU ON YOUTUBE
IN THIS EXCLUSIVE MLB TELECAST.
1-1 THE COUNTER TUCKER WHO HAS
SINGLED, SCORED, STOLEN BASE
TONIGHT.
>> JOE MADDON HAS THIS THING
CALLED THE COUSIN EDDIE.
THAT MIGHT BE A FUN ROAD TRIP IN
HIS RV, FROM HOUSTON TO L.A.
MATT: A BALL AND TWO STRIKES.
MARK: I THINK HE IS SAYING WE
COULD -- GEOFF: I THINK HE IS
SAYING WE CAN JUMP IN WITH JOE
MADDON HAVE A GOOD TRIP.
HE LIKES THE MUSIC.
>> WE ALL GET IN JOE'S VAN,
DUSTY IS SHOTGUN, AND WE LISTEN
TO THEIR STORIES.
SPRAYED OUT TO THE LEFT SIDE OF
THE INFIELD.
ONE GONE TO START THE SIXTH.
WE ASKED BOTH MANAGERS THE SAME
QUESTION WE ASKED DYLAN BUNDY
WHEN WE VISITED HIM EARLIER,
WHAT THE LAST THING THEY WATCHED
ON YOUTUBE, AS FAR AS AN
INSTRUCTIONAL VIDEO WOULD GO,
HOW MANY TIMES A DAY DO YOU FIND
YOURSELVES TRYING TO DO A TASK
AND HAVING TO YOUTUBE IT?
FOR JOE MADDON, IT WAS HOW TO
HIT MY DRIVER.
DUSTY'S WAS MUCH MORE
INTERESTING.
HOW TO PLANT AND GROW TEXAS
ONIONS IN CALIFORNIA.
>> THAT IS EVERYTHING YOU NEED
TO KNOW ABOUT DUSTY.
RENAISSANCE MAN.
>> TWO BALLS AND A STRIKE, THE
COUNT TO ALEDMYS DIAZ.
THINK ABOUT THE BASEBALL THAT
GUY HAS BEEN WITNESS TO IN HIS
CAREER.
THE CAREER HIMSELF -- FOR
HIMSELF, WHAT HE HAD TO ENDURE
IN THE MINORS.
IN THE MARINE CORPS, BASE HIT.
DIAZ HAS DONE THAT A COUPLE
TIMES TONIGHT.
THAT IS HIS THIRD OF THE
EVENING.
>> THERE WERE FOUR ANGELS
SURROUNDING THE BASEBALL AND NOT
ONE OF THEM COULD GET IT READ
THAT IS HOW IT IS GOING FOR THE
ASTROS.
>> JOE MADDON TALKED ABOUT HIS
GAME.
THEY HAVE BROUGHT IN THE SAND
WEDGE TONIGHT.
PHIL MICKELSON WOULD BE HAPPY
WITH THIS ACTION.
>> THEY ARE BRINGING OUT THE OLD
SCHOOL FOR THIS GAME.
>> THIS IS NOT ONE OF THOSE
NIGHTS WHERE THE COLLECTIVE
VELOCITY OF THE ASTROS WILL
IMPRESS YOU, BUT THEY LEAD BY
SIX IN THE BOTTOM OF THE SIX.
MYLES STRAW HAS HAD A NICE
NIGHT.
DROVE IN ANOTHER ON A FIELDER'S
CHOICE PLAY IN THE FOURTH.
>> TODAY WAS A YOUTUBE
INSTRUCTIONAL VIDEO ON HOW TO
GET BASE HITS WITHOUT EXIT
VELOCITY FOR THE ASTROS.
[LAUGHTER]
>> JUST WHEN YOU THINK YOU NEED
TO SQUARE UP A BALL AND BARREL
IT, IF WE MAY BORROW THE
STATCAST TERM, TO DO DAMAGE.
TONIGHT IS PROOF TO THE
CONTRARY.
THE ASTROS BIGGEST HIT AND RUN
TOTAL SINCE THE FIRST WEEK OF
THE SEASON AND IT COMES AT A
TIME WHEN IT IS MOST NEEDED TO
REVISIT WHAT WE TALKED ABOUT
EARLIER TONIGHT, HAVING LOST 9-
10, A REALLY ROUGH ROAD TRIP
THROUGH SEATTLE AND DENVER.
HOME COOKING IS TASTING REALLY
GOOD TONIGHT.
>> COMPLETELY WHIFFED ON THE
IDEA OF HAVING THEM SCORE RUNS
WHAT THEY HOME RUN BALL.
IT IS HITTING WITH RUNNERS IN
SCORING POSITION THAT IS DONE
THEM WELL TONIGHT, GOING 4-10 IN
THIS GAME SO FAR.
THEY HAVE LEFT NINE RUNNERS ON.
>> TWO BALLS AND TWO STRIKES,
THE COUNT TO MYLES STRAW.
ON THE GROUND TO SHORTSTOP.
NO WAY YOU WILL TURN TWO WITH
THAT SPEED.
FLETCHER DID NOT EVEN BORROW --
BOTHER WITH A TURN.
STRAUSS A BOARD WITH TWO GONE.
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT MARTIN
MALDONADO'S CONTRACT EXTENSION
EARLIER.
AFTER A QUICK PITCHING CHANGE WE
WILL REVISIT THAT TOPIC.
I THINK JOE HAS ALREADY MADE THE
MOVE BECAUSE ROWAN WAS UP AND
BEN ROWEN IS ON HIS WAY INTO THE
GAME.
RT IN THE LAST OF
THE SIXTH.
WE WILL BE RIGHT BACK AREA --
BACK.
>> NOT A LOT OF 20-YEAR-OLDS
PLAY WELL IN EVERY ASPECT OF THE
GAME THAT QUICKLY.
I DON'T THINK ANYONE INCLUDING
TROUT THOUGHT HE WOULD HAVE THE
KIND OF YEAR HE HAD IN 2012.
>> IT WAS A SEASON WITH ALMOST
TOO MANY MIKE TROUT HIGHLIGHTS.
ONE MOMENT SHOWED HIS GIFTS MORE
FAMOUSLY THAN ANY OTHER.
>> BACK OUT IT IS TROUT, IT IS
GONE -- WHAT A CATCH BY MIKE
TROUT.
TAKES A HOME RUN AWAY.
WHAT A PLAY BY THE 20-YEAR-OLD
IN CENTER FIELD.
YOU BET HE IS SMILING.
>> THAT WAS AN UNBELIEVABLE
PLAY.
>> THAT CATCH IN BALTIMORE I
ALMOST PASSED OUT BECAUSE OF THE
ADRENALINE IN ME, WATCHING HIM
JUMP UP FOR THAT BALL.
>> MIKE TROUT WITH ANOTHER
SPECTACULAR GRAB.
>> ONE OF THE BEST CATCHES I
HAVE SEEN.
I DID NOT SEE IT.
JUST WATCHING IT, IT WAS THE
GREATEST VISION I HAVE EVER HAD.
>> ALL SEASON LONG MLB WILL
HONOR ESSENTIAL CENTRAL AND
FRONT-LINE WORKERS WHO LIFT UP
THEIR FELLOW CITIZENS DURING THE
PANDEMIC.
THANK YOU, FRONTLINE HEROES.
COVID-19 VACCINATIONS ARE SAFE
AND EFFECTIVE.
GET THE VACCINE SO WE CAN GET
BACK TO DOING WHAT WE LOVE
TOGETHER.
VISIT MLB.COM/
COVID-19RESOURCES.COM FOR MORE.
NO PITCHING CHANGES.
AN 8-2 ASTROS LEAD.
THEY HAVE OPTED FOR AN ROWAN.
>> EXPECT A SLIDER FROM BEN
ROWEN.
75% OF HIS PITCHES, A LITTLE TOO
SEAM SINKING FASTBALL.
>> MARTIN MALDONADO THE BATTER
TO THE LEFT SIDE OF THE DIAMOND.
MALDONADO DOUBLED IN SCORE
TONIGHT.
ROWEN, AS SO MANY RELIEVERS DO,
STARTED WITH A CHECK IN ON FIRST
BASE.
BEN MADE HIS ANGELS DEBUT APRIL
14 IN KANSAS CITY, HIS FIRST
BIG-LEAGUE APPEARANCE SINCE
2016.
HE HAS BEEN A GREAT STORY OF ST
ICKTOITIVENESS.
THE SIDEWINDER IS IN FOR A
STRIKE.
BEN DID NOT GET INTO GAME ACTION
IN THE RECENT HOME STANDS.
A LOT OF IT WAS CANCELED, THAT
SERIES WITH THE TWINS.
0-1 TO MARTIN MALDONADO.
MYLES STRAW ADVANCED ON DEFENSE.
>> I SAY GIVE HIM THE BAG.
I DON'T BELIEVE IN DEFENSIVE
INDIFFERENCE.
>> IT IS ONLY A SIX RUN GAME IN
THE SIXTH INNING.
I THINK THAT IS A STOLEN BASE.
>> THAT IS HOW I WOULD SCORE IT.
A BALL AND A STRIKE, THE COUNT
TO MARTIN MALDONADO.
WOW.
ROWEN GETS A CALL BELOW THE
STRIKE ZONE.
MALDONADO SENDS A FLY BALL THE
OTHER WAY TO RIGHT.
JARED WALSH HAS IT.
ANGELS COMBINE ON A SCORELESS
BOTTOM OF THEGETTING TO THE BAC.
IT IS TAKING A WHILE.
8-2, HOUSTON.
>> OH MY.
>> HANG ONTO THE ROOF.
>> THIS ONE IS OUT OF HERE.
♪
>> LINE DRIVE CRUSHED TO LEFT
FIELD.
WOW.
>> THAT DESERVES A WOW.
390 SIGN IN LEFT CENTER.
>> IT IS CRUSHING.
LEAN INTO IT.
>> 101 ON ONE HALF OF THE INNING
AND IN THE NEXT, 450 FEET.
THAT BALL WAS CRUSHED.
THAT WAS RIDICULOUS.
>> TROUT GETS A HOLD THAT ONE
END OF THE CORNER.
HE GOT IT.
HOMERS IN 10 STRAIGHT.
>> I AM GOING WITH YOU TO VEGAS
AT SOME POINT.
GOOD CALL.
LET'S GET THE HOME RUN STREET
GOING.
>> EVERYTHING GOING THEIR WAY
TONIGHT.
>> GOOGLE CLOUD IS HELPING OUR
STATCAST WITH MASSIVE AMOUNTS OF
DATA POINTS FOR NEW INSIGHTS,
TAKE YOU DEEPER INTO THE GAME
THAN EVER BEFORE.
GOOGLE CLOUD IS THE OFFICIAL
TECHNOLOGY OF MAJOR LEAGUE
BASEBALL.
WITH THE HELP OF STATCAST, LET'S
TAKE A LOOK AT THE ALBERT PUJOLS
HOMER.
ALBEIT A LITTLE CONTROVERSIAL,
SLID PAST THE FAIR POLE.
IT WAS A CALL THAT WAS REVIEWED
AND UPHELD.
AND ALBERT WAS THRILLED.
>> 665TH OF HIS CAREER.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
I'LL TAKE IT.
A LITTLE FOUL POLE SCRAPER.
>> CARRYING ON LIKE A GUY WHO
HAD NOT HIT ONE BEFORE, RIGHT?
GIDDY LIKE A 19-YEAR-OLD ROOKIE.
HERE IS JOSÉ ROJAS LEADING
THINGS OFF FOR THE ANGELS.
THAT IS REALLY THE LONE BRIGHT
SPOT FOR THE ANGELS ON THIS
SERIES OPENER BECAUSE THE
HOMESITE HAS REALLY DOMINATED
FROM THE OPENING BELL.
THREE IN THE SECOND.
CRISTIAN JAVIER WAS OUTSTANDING.
IT IS UP TO THEM TO HOLD THE SIX
RUN LEAD THREE BALLS AND NO
STRIKES TO JOSÉ ROJAS.
>> A GREAT STORY, GREW UP IN THE
ANAHEIM AREA, ANGEL FAN, 36TH
ROUND DRAFT PICK.
>> IF YOU TALK ABOUT HITS FOR A
HOMETOWN KID, OF COURSE BORN IN
ANAHEIM, HIGH SCHOOL IN ANAHEIM
FOR JOSÉ.
.
THEN YOU START DIGGING THROUGH
THE MAJOR LEAGUE RECORD BOOKS
WONDERING WHO IS THE GUY WHO HAD
THE MOST HITS FOR HIS HOMETOWN
TEAM?
IT JUST HAPPENS TO BE THE GUY
WITH THE MOST HITS.
>> PETE IN CINCINNATI.
>> FIRST STRIKE OUT OF THE
INNING.
ALL 3358 FOR PETE COUNT BECAUSE
HE WENT TO HIGH SCHOOL IN
CINCINNATI.
I DON'T THINK ANYBODY WILL
CATCH THAT.
NEXT WOULD BE CAL RIPKEN.
IF YOU WANT TO ACCOUNT ABERDEEN
HIGH SCHOOL IN ABERDEEN,
MARYLAND, WHICH WAS 40 MINUTES
AWAY FROM CAMDEN YARDS, GRANTED
IT IS NOT THE CITY PROPER.
HERE IS KURT SUZUKI NOW.
A BALL AND NO STRIKES THE COUNT
TO SUZUKI, WHO IS 0-2 TONIGHT.
GOT HIM.
OH MAN.
HOW MANY HIT BATSMEN TONIGHT?
TROUT IN THE ELBOW, SUZUKI AND
THE ELBOW, BREGMAN GOT HIT IN
THE ELBOW.
>> THEY ARE GETTING SQUARED UP
RIGHT AT THE POINT OF THAT
ELBOW.
IT IS NOT EXACTLY AN IDEAL
SITUATION.
THAT WAS A LITTLE BIT OF A
SLIDER THAT NEVER BROKE AND
ENDED UP SPIRALING ITSELF INTO
THE ELBOW OF KURT SUZUKI.
NOT SURE THOSE PADS ARE WORKING.
DID EVERYTHING RIGHT AS FAR AS
TURNING THE BODY, TURNING THE
HEAD, BUT THE ELBOW GETS HIT
RIGHT ON THE PAD, JUST LIKE
TROUT.
>> REMINDS US THAT WE DO GET
WORD ON MIKE TROUT STATUS AND
THE ANGELS ARE CALLING IT A LEFT
ELBOW CONTUSION.
AS PAINFUL AS THAT WORD MAY BE,
IT IS BETTER THAN THE
ALTERNATIVE.
SUZUKI IS ABOARD.
WHY IS IT, AS WE SAY HELLO TO
OUR WORLDWIDE YOUTUBE AUDIENCE
WAS AGAIN TONIGHT.
-- ONCE AGAIN TONIGHT.
I GET THE TECHNOLOGY HAS
IMPROVED, BUT WHEN CRAIG BIGGIO
AND BARRY BONDS WERE UP THERE,
THE STUFF LOOKED LIKE IT GAVE
YOU A LITTLE BIT MORE OF A
CHANCE.
THIS STUFF IS VERY THIN.
GO BACK TO THE OLD SCHOOL THING
IS WHAT I AM SAYING.
>> IT DID NOT AFFECT BARRY BONDS
AT ALL, I KNOW THAT.
BARRY HANGING THAT THING OVER
THE PLATE ALLOWED HIM TO GET TO
A LOT OF PITCHES.
BETWEEN BIGGIO -- I KNOW HIM, I
PLAYED WITH HIM HERE IN HOUSTON.
YOU COULD PUT THE GUARD OFF HIS
ELBOW AND PUT IT ON SOMEBODY'S
SHIN.
>> WE'VE GOT A VISIT TO THE
MOUND.
COMING OUT TO CHAT WITH ABREU.
A QUICK CHAT IT WAS, AND DAVID
FLETCHER DIGS IN.
I'VE OFTEN WONDERED WHY GUYS DO
NOT GO BACK TO THAT, BUT I AM
THE KIND OF GUY WHO STAYS UP AT
NIGHT WONDERING WHY THE OLD
BUBBLE CHEST PROTECTOR THAT
UMPIRES USE IS NOT BACK IN
VOGUE.
I LIKE THE FACT IT ALLOWED THEM
TO GET CLOSE AND PERSONAL WITH
THE STRIKE ZONE.
>> BY THE WAY, GUYS, I HATE TO
REFERENCE THIS AGAIN, BUT I HOLD
THE ALL-TIME RECORD FOR THE
KANSAS CITY ROYALS AS
FAR AS HIT BATTERS.
SOMETIMES THE BALL GETS AWAY
FROM YOU.
>> YOU STILL GOT THE RECORD?
>> LOCKS, WHILE PITCHES, AND HIT
BATTERS, ALL THE THINGS YOU WANT
TO BE -- WALKS, WILD PITCHES,
HIT BATTERS, ALL THE THINGS YOU
WANT TO BE KNOWN FOR.
>> THERE IS A TON OF
BLACK INK THERE.
THE COUNT IS A BALL AND TWO
STRIKES.
ONE OUTCOME A ONE ON, TOP OF THE
SEVENTH INNING, ASTROS UP BY
SIX.
EVERYONE OF THOSE WAS TRYING TO
ESTABLISH THE BALL INSIDE.
THAT WAS ALL I WAS TRYING TO DO.
>> OF COURSE.
>> THE TEETH OF THE ANGELS
LINEUP NOT MAKING AN IMPACT
TONIGHT.
MIKE TROUT HAS BEEN REMOVED FROM
THE GAME AFTER WALKING AND BEING
HIT BY A PITCH.
FLETCHER SWATS LET ONE PASS A
DIVING BREGMAN IN THE LEFT --
FLETCHER SWATS THAT ONE PAST A
DIVING BREGMAN IN LEFT.
SHOHEI OHTANI IS OFF TO A HUGE
START.
HERE ARE SOME OF THE INTERESTING
NUMBERS.
THE TOP PERCENTILE IN AVERAGE
EXIT, BELOW AS A HITTER -- VELO
AS A HITTER.
HE IS FAST.
>> INCREDIBLY FAST.
LIKE DEVON WHITE TYPE FAST.
>> IT LOOKS LIKE WE WILL HAVE A
CHANCE TO TALK MORE ABOUT HIM
BULLPEN DUSTY BAKER GOES FOR
BROOKS RALEY, AND WE WILL BE
RIGHT BACK.
>> HE JUST SMOKES IT.
>> FORGET ABOUT IT.
>> MY GOODNESS.
>> THAT ONE IS GOING TO GO!
>> THAT BALL WAS CRUSHED.
>> AND THIS IS GOING TO DO IT.
>> OH MY.
>> STRIKE THREE.
>> THAT WAS A GREAT PLAY.
>> WE HAVE TALKED ABOUT HIS
FIELDING SKILLS.
THAT WAS REMARKABLE.
♪
>> SOMETHING LIKE THIS IS WHAT
THEY CAME FOR.
>> A BIG OPPORTUNITY FOR SHOHEI
OHTANI, WHO IS ENJOYING FULL
HEALTH.
HAD IT NOT BEEN FOR THE
INJURIES, NO TELLING WHAT HE
COULD HAVE ACCOMPLISHED.
THE INJURY, TOMMY JOHN, THE LEFT
KNEE WAS A PROBLEM ON BOTH SIDES
OF THE SCORECARD, SURGERY TO
CORRECT THAT.
FOREARM STRAIN LAST AUGUST SHUT
HIM DOWN ON THE MOUND.
BUT OHTANI IS OVERALL HERE AND
AT THE PEAK OF HIS POWERS LAST
YEAR.
>> HE HAS TOUCHED 101 MILES PER
HOUR.
HIS SPEED RUNNING DOWN THE BASES
IS SOMETHING THAT IS TRULY
REMARKABLE.
>> 0-1 THE COUNT TO OHTANI.
>> EVEN GOING BACK TO WHEN HE
FOUND OUT HE HAD NOT HAD TOMMY
JOHN SURGERY.
THAT NIGHT, HE WENT OUT AND HIT
TWO HOME RUNS AT THE PLATE IN
TEXAS, WHICH IS INCREDIBLE TO
SEE SOMEBODY HAVE THAT KIND OF
FOCUS TO HIT HOME RUNS AFTER
KNOWING YOU ARE GOING TO HAVE
TOMMY JOHN SURGERY.
>> OHTANI BEHIND, 0-2.
BROOKS RALEY IN FOR THE BULLPEN
FOR THE ASTROS.
THE LOAN LEFT-HANDER IN THE
BUNCH. -- THE LONE LEFT-HANDER
IN THE BUNCH.
A SHORT SAMPLE SIZE.
FEWER THAN SEVEN INNINGS.
SLIDER MISSES AND IT IS A BALL
AND TWO STRIKES.
>> IT HAS BEEN THOSE LAST COUPLE
OUTINGS THAT HAVE GOTTEN TO HIM
, GIVING UP THREE EARNED RUNS IN
HIS LAST TWO OUTINGS.
HE PITCHED IN THE KBO A COUPLE
YEARS AGO AS A STARTER.
THE ASTROS BROUGHT HIM HERE AND
TOLD HIM TO GET ON THE CUT
FASTBALL, AND IT HAS BEEN
EFFECTIVE FOR HIM.
HE HAS BEEN ABLE TO GET ON THE
OUTSIDE EDGE.
>> TRYING TO SHOOT THAT OUTSIDE
EDGE.
TWO BALLS AND TWO STRIKES TO
OHTANI.
>> IT HAS BEEN A LOT OF FUN
WATCHING OHTANI.
WHEN WE USED TO BE ABLE TO GET
ON THE FIELD, HE IS A LARGE
HUMAN.
HE IS EVERY BIT OF 6'4".
HE'S GOT THE BUILD.
BUT WHEN HE TAKES OFF AND RUNS
AT 29 FEET PER SECOND, HE MAKES
IT LOOK EASY, EFFORTLESS.
>> JAMMED SHOT OFF THE FISTS AS
IT SQUIBS OUT TO CORREA.
THAT IS THE SECOND OUT OF THE
INNING.
OHTANI HOMERED YESTERDAY FOR THE
FIFTH TIME, ONE OF FOUR SOLO
SHOTS BY THE ANGELS, AND WHAT
WAS MORE IMPRESSIVE THAN THIS
WAS THE PACE AROUND THE BASES.
THIS WAS A HOME RUN TROT.
LOOK AT HIM.
>> I WAS WATCHING THE GAME, I AM
LOOKING DOWN AND HE SAID, I AM
GOING TO GET DOWN THERE AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE.
I WAS LAUGHING SO HARD WHEN HE
GOT AROUND THE BASES.
>> HE DOES NOT WANT TO SUPPRESS
THE STATCAST NUMBERS.
[LAUGHTER]
>> HERE IS SCOTT SCHEBLER,
STRUCK OUT IN HIS FIRST TRY.
NOW I AM THINKING YOU ARE
SERIOUS.
STATCAST NUMBERS DO NOT TAKE
INTO ACCOUNT HOME RUN TROT, DO
THEY?
I DON'T THINK THEY DO.
>> I'M NOT SURE.
I HOPE NOT.
HERE WE GO.
>> THAT IS ELITE.
TO YOUR POINT, IT DOES NOT LOOK
LIKE IT BECAUSE HE IS A BIG MAN.
>> HE GOT DOWN THE LINE AT 29.6
FEET PER SECOND.
>> WHEN I THINK OF BO JACKSON IN
HIS FIRST MAJOR LEAGUE HIT, HE
HIT A GROUND BALL TO SECOND BASE
GOING DOWN THE LINE.
THAT IS A GUY I WOULD THINK IS
THE FASTEST HUMAN BEING I HAVE
EVER SEEN IN PERSON.
I SAW HIM ON THE FOOTBALL FIELD,
BUT ON THE BASEBALL FIELD, HE
COULD FLAT OUT FLY.
AND IF ANYBODY WANTS TO KNOW,
WHEN WE USED TO TRAVEL TO
ANAHEIM, SOME OF THE QUESTIONS I
WOULD ASK WOULD BE ABOUT BO
JACKSON AND HIS ABILITIES.
>> TO EXTINGUISH THE THREAT.
STRETCHING IN HOUSTON IN AN 8-2
ASTROS LEAD.
>> HANG ONTO THE ROOF!
>> DEEP!
>> THIS ONE IS OUT OF HERE!
>> THIS BALL HIT HARD AGAIN.
MICHAEL BRANTLEY, HOME RUN FOR
THE THIRD STRAIGHT OPENING GAME.
EVERY YEAR AS AN ASTRO, MICHAEL
BRANTLEY HAS HIT A HOME RUN.
>> OTHER TEAMS ARE SAYING UNCLE.
>> THEY ARE SAYING MIKE, UNCLE.
>> ALEX BREGMAN ON A 2-2 PITCH
DRIVES ONE DEEP TO LEFT FIELD!
THAT BALL IS GONE.
BACK-TO-BACK JACKS, BRANTLEY AND
BREGMAN, AND THE ASTROS NOW LEAD
5-1.
>> BACK-TO-BACK BANGERS.
>> SENDS ONE IN THE AIR TO
CENTER FIELD.
GOING ALL THE WAY BACK TO THE
WALL, THAT BALL IS GONE!
THE BIG MAN, YORDAN ALVAREZ,
HITS ONE TO LEFT CENTER FIELD, A
3-1 SHOT.
AND THE ASTROS TAKE A 5-1 LEAD.
>> GOT LIFT OFF.
THAT IS NOT AN EASY PITCH TO
GET, AND THAT IS OUT ON THE
OUTSIDE CORNER.
YOUR DON STAYS -- YORDAN STAYS
ON IT AND DRIVES IT.
>> CHECK OUT THE ASTROS YOUTUBE
PAGE FOR INSIDER CONTENT,
INCLUDING BEHIND-THE-SCENES
TAKES FROM YOUR FAVORITE ASTROS
PLAYERS, COACHES, DRY HUMOR WITH
STEVE SPARKS, AND MORE.
VISIT YOUTUBE.COM/ASTROS TO
SUBSCRIBE TO THE CHANNEL TODAY.
HERE ARE THE RESULTS FROM THE
POLL.
I AM CURIOUS TO SEE HOW THIS
SHUTOUT.
JOE MADDON FINISHES SECOND,
NOLAN RYAN, OF COURSE.
>> WOW.
>> I DID NOT WANT TO INFLUENCE
THE VOTE, BUT DUSTY WAS MY GUY.
I WANT TO GET IN A CAR WITH
DUSTY AND JUST HAVE A TALK.
>> BY THE WAY, IF YOU WANTED TO
LAUGH FOREVER, TORII HUNTER.
BY THE TIME YOU GOT TO L.A. FROM
HOUSTON, YOUR RIBS WOULD BE
KILLING YOU, THE STORIES ABOUT
THE WAY HE MAKES YOU LAUGH.
[LAUGHTER]
>> NOLAN RYAN WOULD BE A GOOD
ONE.
>> IS HE AROUND A LOT THESE
DAYS?
>> HE WAS.
HIS SON USED TO BE THE PRESIDENT
OF THE ASTROS.
HE HAS SINCE MOVED ON.
BUT WHEN REID WAS AROUND, NOLAN
WAS AROUND ALSO.
THEY HONORED NOLAN RYAN A COUPLE
TIMES HERE WITH THE HOUSTON
SPORTS AWARD.
AND SOME OTHER LEGENDS WERE
INDUCTED INTO THE HALL OF FAME
LOCALLY.
NOLAN RYAN IS ONE OF THE
GREATEST CONVERSATIONS YOU COULD
EVER ASK FOR.
WE HAVE HAD THEM IN THE BOOTH A
COUPLE TIMES TELLING
STORIES ABOUT THE 1980'S ASTROS
TEAMS COMPETING IN THE NATIONAL
LEAGUE AT WEST THAT SOUTHERN
DRAWL TALKING ABOUT BASEBALL.
>> I WOULD LOVE TO HAVE BEEN
PARTY TO THAT, FOR SURE.
TWO BALLS AND A STRIKE.
>> NOLAN RYAN TALKING ABOUT GUYS
NOT BEING ABLE TO GET THREE
TIMES THROUGH A BATTING ORDER.
NOLAN RYAN WAS NOTORIOUS FOR
GOING DEEP IN BALLGAMES.
HAD A TOUGH TIME UNDERSTANDING
HOW DIFFICULT IT WAS FOR GUYS
NOWADAYS TO GET THAT THIRD TIME
THROUGH THE LINEUP.
>> T BALLS ANDWO -- TWO BALLS
AND TWO STRIKES.
CARLOS SENDS THE BALL OUT TO
RIGHT.
WALSH AT THE TRACK.
ONE GONE.
I AM CURIOUS, WE HAVE NOT TALKED
ABOUT THIS AT LENGTH AND I AM
CURIOUS AS SOMEBODY WHO CAME UP
IN A DIFFERENT ERA OF PITCHING
AND PITCHING PEDAGOGY.
YOU GUYS WERE TAUGHT TO DO IT
DIFFERENTLY.
DO YOU THINK GUYS TODAY WANT TO
POST UP AND GO LONGER?
AND IT IS FRONT OFFICES THAT
HAVE HELD THEM BACK AND CHANGED
THE TRAINING?
OR IS IT VICE VERSA?
>> I THINK THE PLAYERS AND
PITCHERS STILL WANT TO DO THAT.
I HAD A CONVERSATION WITH GERRIT
COLE, THE WHOLE THIRD TIME
THROUGH STUFF.
HE SAID ONCE I GOT THROUGH THE
FIRST TIME THROUGH THE LINEUP, I
WAS IN CRUISE CONTROL.
I DID NOT CARE IF THEY KNEW WHAT
I WAS THROWING.
I WAS GOING TO BE EFFECTIVE.
DYLAN BUNDY, IF YOU EVER GET
ANYBODY UP WHEN HE IS IN THE
SIXTH OR SEVENTH INNING, YOU HAD
BETTER BE READY TO RUN AWAY FROM
HIM AS FAR AS A PITCHING COACH
AND A MANAGER.
THEY STILL WANT TO BE OUT THERE.
NUMBERS, THEY WILL TELL YOU THE
THIRD TIME THROUGH THE BATTING
AVERAGE GOES UP, BUT THEY
AVERAGE THAT WITH THE BIG
STARTER COMPARED TO THE FIRST OR
SECOND STARTER OF THE ROTATION,
WHERE YOU GET BETTER AS THE GAME
PROGRESSES, IN MY OPINION.
>> A BALL AND TWO STRIKES TO
MICHAEL BRANTLEY.
OF ALL OF NOLAN BRIAN'S
RECORDS -- NOLAN RYAN'S RECORDS
THAT WILL NOT BE BROKEN, HERE IS
ONE THAT IS IRONCLAD.
222 COMPLETE GAMES.
BY THE WAY, THAT IS NOT THE
RECORD, BUT THAT IS NOLAN'S
NUMBER.
COME ON, TWO COMPLETE GAMES IN A
CAREER SEEMS LIKE A PIPE DREAM
NOW.
>> THAT IS INCREDIBLE.
>> 2-2.
>> CAN YOU IMAGINE IF HE WAS NOT
HAPPY WITH YOU?
I DON'T WANT NOLAN IN THERE IN
CASE HE GOT MAD AT ME.
[LAUGHTER]
>> STILL 2-2 TO BRANTLEY.
>> I WOULD HATE TO BE LEAVING
FROM HOUSTON, GET TO EL PASO,
THEN WE SIT AROUND -- WE TURN
AROUND AND SEE GUBI IN A
HEADLOCK.
[LAUGHTER]
I WOULD BE LIKE, YOU ARE ON YOUR
OWN.
[LAUGHTER]
I THOUGHT YOU WERE MY WINGMEN!
>> I HAVE SEEN THAT DUDE DO SOME
DAMAGE.
I AM NOT SURE I WANT PART OF
THAT.
>> FULL COUNT, THREE BALLS AND
TWO STRIKES THE COUNT TO MICHAEL
BRANTLEY.
YOU MENTIONED BUS TRIPS TO EL
PASO.
I HAD A TEXAS LEAGUE FLASHBACK
WORKING IN THE TEXAS LEAGUE, AS
BRANTLEY HAS A BASE HIT.
AS WE MENTIONED, THERE WAS NO
WRONG ANSWER IN THAT
POLL QUESTION.
YOU HAVE BEEN AROUND DUSTY FOR A
WHILE.
GIVE ME SOME OF YOUR BEST DUSTY
STUFF.
>> I DON'T KNOW IF PEOPLE WANTED
TO TRAVEL WITH DUSTY ON THE ROAD
TRIP, BUT IF YOU NEED SOMEBODY
ON THAT WALL, DUSTY IS YOUR GUY.
HOW ABOUT HIM TELLING US TODAY
THAT FIVE OR SIX YEARS DURING
HIS CAREER HE HAD TO STEP AWAY
FOR TWO WEEKS IN A SEASON TO DO
HIS MARINES DUTY?
CAMP LEJEUNE, QUANTICO,
PENDLETON.
THERE WERE NO REHAB ASSIGNMENTS,
SO HE HAD TO COME BACK AFTER A
COUPLE OF WEEKS OF NOT PICKING
UP A BASEBALL AND TRY TO BE
EFFECTIVE.
SO WHATEVER IT IS, IF YOU WORKS
OUT BY HIMSELF, HE CAN'T DO
ANYTHING, THE ADVICE HE WOULD
GET FROM DUSTY IS PRETEND LIKE
YOU NEVER LEFT.
THAT IS WHAT HE WAS TOLD AFTER
THREE OR FOUR SEASONS OF
STRUGGLING TO COME BACK AFTER
SPENDING TWO WEEKS EVERY YEAR IN
THE MARINES.
>> THAT TIME WITH THE MARINE
CORPS RESERVE IS SOMETHING DUSTY
LOOKS BACK ON WITH A LOT OF
PRIDE.
YOU MAKE A GREAT POINT, BRETT.
HE IS BALANCING BOTH, TRYING TO
ESTABLISH HIS MAJOR-LEAGUE
CAREER AT THAT TIME.
>> TWO BALLS AND A STRIKE TO
ALEX BREGMAN.
THE CONNECTIONS TO DUSTY BAKER
AND JOE MADDON, AS WE TAKE A
LOOK AT BOTH OF THEM ON THE
OLDEST ACTIVE MANAGER BOARD, TWO
VERY NOTICEABLE GAMES -- NOTABLE
GAMES IN EACH OF THEIR CAREERS.
THE 2002 WORLD SERIES, WHICH WAS
DUSTY'S LAST GAME AS GIANTS
MANAGER, AND DUSTY'S LAST GAME
AS NATIONALS MANAGER IN 20, WHEN
IT JOE MADDON'S CUBS BEAT THEM
IN THE DIVISION SERIES -- IN
2017, WHEN JOE MADDON'S CUBS
BEAT THEM IN THE DIVISION
SERIES.
THREE BALLS AND A STRIKE NOW THE
COUNT TO ALEX BREGMAN.
BREGMAN A CANDIDATE FOR OUR
YOUTUBE PLAYER OF THE GAME
TONIGHT, THREE R.B.I.'S FOR HIM
ON A 3-3 NIGHT AT THE PLATE.
AND A STRIKE.
FULL COUNT NOW.
>> ON BASE ALL FOUR TIMES, HIT
BY A PITCH AS WELL.
THE THROW IS NOT GREATLY AS THE
ASTROS WITH A PLAY ON THERE.
-- BUT THERE WAS NOT ON TIME AS
THE ASTROS PUT THE PLAY IN
THERE.
AND IT LOOKS LIKE EVERYBODY IS
COMING OFF THE FIELD.
DID THEY CALL MICHAEL OUT?
TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT HAPPENED
HERE.
I DID NOT SEE BRANTLEY AND HIS
CONTACT WITH THE BAG.
>> I AM NOT ENTIRELY SURE WHAT
HAPPENED.
>>>> THE PLAYERS ARE OFF THE
FIELD AND WE WILL TRY TO SORT
THINGS OUT.
D THAT A STRIKE HIM
OUT, THROW HIM OUT DOUBLE PLAY.
WHAT IN THE WIDE, WIDE WORLD OF
SPORTS IS GOING ON HERE?
♪
>> YOU SHOW UP TO EMPTY STANDS
LAST YEAR.
IT WAS NOT THE SAME.
>> PART OF MY MOTIVATION TO GET
BACK TO THE TEAM IS TO HEAR THE
FANS AND EXPERIENCE MINUTE
MAID AT FULL CAPACITY AGAIN.
>> IT IS UNMATCHED.
>> WE HAVE THE BEST FANS IN
BASEBALL.
THE MAIN REASON WE PLAY IS
BECAUSE OF THEM.
>> THIS IS THE MOST COMMUNITY
MINDED TEAM I HAVE EVER BEEN A
PART OF.
THESE GUYS ARE VERY AWARE THAT
THEY ARE PART OF THE COMMUNITY.
I HAD A LONG CONVERSATION WITH A
LOT OF THE GUYS WHO DONATED
WATER.
I HAD A REAL LONG CONVERSATION
WITH BREGMAN, WHO ALWAYS STEPS
UP.
YOU HAVE ALTUVE AND ALL OF THESE
GUYS ALWAYS STEPPING UP FOR THE
COMMUNITY.
I THOUGHT THAT WAS PRETTY COOL.
>> APPARENTLY, THAT WAS SCORED
AS A STRIKE HIM OUT, THROW HIM
OUT DOUBLE PLAY.
WE WILL SHOW REPLACE -- WE
WILL SHOW REPLACE.
A GREAT CATCH BY MYLES STRAW.
>> TELL YOU WHAT, MYLES STRAW IN
CENTER FIELD HAD SOME ISSUES OUT
THERE IN COLORADO, BUT HERE WE
GO BACK TO THAT STRIKE OUT
THROAT DOWN TO SECOND BASE.
BRANTLEY WAS SAFE, BUT THE HOME
PLATE UMPIRE WAS ALL OVER IT AS
ALEX BREGMAN LEANED OVER HOME
PLATE AND GOT IN THE WAY OF KURT
SUZUKI.
THAT WAS THE INTERFERENCE CALL
TO GET THE DOUBLE PLAY TO END
THE GAME.
TO END THE INNING, SORRY.
>> YOU DO NOT HAVE TO HAVE
CONTACT WITH THE BATTER AS A
CATCHER.
ALL IT HAS TO BE IS AN
IMPEDED THROW TO SECOND.
>> THEY MAY NEED TO RE-RACK THE
VIDEOTAPE TO SORT THAT OUT.
WE ARE GOING TO GO BACK TO A
COMMERCIAL, OR SOMETHING LIKE A
COMMERCIAL, WITH ONE OUT IN THE
EIGHTH.
>> LOOK HIM TO ANGELS BASEBALL.
TONIGHT, JOIN DAVID FLETCHER AS
HE GUIDES YOU THROUGH THIS
RELAXING BASEBALL MEDITATION.
BE SURE YOU ARE IN A COMFORTABLE
POSITION.
TAKE A DEEP BREATH.
AND NOW, DAVID FLETCHER.
>> ANGELS BASEBALL.
MIKE TROUT, HOME RUN.
HELMET NOT  -- HELMET
NACHOS.
ANDREW HEANEY, STRIKEOUT.
THE RALLY MONKEY.
ALBERT PUJOLS MILESTONE.
THE BIG A.
ANTHONY RENDON DEFENSIVE
HIGHLIGHT.
LIGHTING UP THE HALO.
DAVID FLETCHER.
>> THIS HAS BEEN AN ANGELS
BASEBALL MEDITATION.
>> DON'T MISS A MINUTE OF
EXCITING ANGELS ACTION.
HEAD TO THE ANGELS YOUTUBE PAGE
TO CATCH BIG MOMENTS,
INTERVIEWS, AND MORE.
VISIT YOUTUBE.COM/ANGELS, AND TO
SUBSCRIBE TO THE CHANNEL TODAY.
THAT DUDE IN THE THROWBACK
JERSEY LOOKED LIKE FRED LYNN.
HERE IS JUSTIN UPTON, THE FIRST
TO FACE JOE SMITH ON FROM THE
ASTROS WILL OPEN, TRYING TO
PROTECT A SIX RUN LEAD WITH ONE
AWAY AND THE BASES EMPTY IN THE
EIGHTH.
>> JOE SMITH COULD USE A CLEAN
OUTING.
IT HAS BEEN ROUGH.
HE HAS GIVEN UP EIGHT EARNED
RUNS, THE THREE-QUARTER ARM
DELIVERY FROM THE VETERAN GIVING
YOU A FASTBALL AT ABOUT 86 MILES
AN HOUR, SOME SINK UNDERNEATH
THE HANDS OF RIGHT-HANDED
HITTERS AND A SLIDER THAT SWEEPS
ACROSS.
>> TWO BALLS AND A STRIKE TO
UPTON, WHO IS 0-2 WITH A WALK
TONIGHT.
>> WE HAVE SEEN A LOT OF FUNKY
ARM ANGLES, STARTING WITH ALEX
CLAUDIO OUT OF THE BULLPEN, THEN
ROWAN, NOW JOE SMITH.
>> EVERYONE IS TAKING A PAGE OUT
OF WHAT HAS BEEN SUCCESSFUL FOR
THE TAMPA BAY RAYS.
DIFFERENT ARM ANGLES ADD TO YOUR
BULLPEN.
DIFFERENT LOOKS MAKES IT MORE
DIFFICULT FOR HITTERS TO TIME IT
AS THEY GO LONGER IN A GAME.
>> 2-2 TO UPTON.
THERE IS A SHOT INTO LEFT, A
BASE HIT.
SO NOW, ALBERT PUJOLS.
I AM NOT SURE IF THOSE BOOS ARE
FROM THE TO RUN SHOT OFF THE
FOUL POLE OR THE SHUTOUT IN
2005.
>> COULD BE A COMBO DEAL.
HE LITERALLY GETS BOOED EVERY
AT-BAT AT MINUTE MAID PARK.
10 YEARS WITH THE ANGELS, HE IS
GETTING BOOED EVERY SINGLE TIME.
>> A BALL AND NO STRIKES TO
PUJOLS.
CONTINUING HIS ASCENT UP THE
ALL-TIME LEADER BOARDS.
>> HE CERTAINLY IS.
665 HOME RUNS.
BUT I WANT TO TAKE YOU BACK TO
SEPTEMBER 2019 BEFORE AN
ANGELS-ASTROS GAME.
MARK LANGSTON HAD A HEALTH
SCARE, HAD TO BE TAKEN TO THE
HOSPITAL.
HIS FAMILY WAS NOT WITH HIM.
AFTER THE GAME, SOME ANGELS
PERSONNEL SHOWED UP, AND
LANGSTON LOOKED UP FROM HIS
HOTEL ROOM.
PUJOLS CAME IN, WANTED TO PRAY
FOR HIM.
LANGSTON TOLD ME THIS WEEK IT
WAS WHAT HE NEEDED AT THAT TIME.
WE KNOW THE IMPACT HE HAS HAD ON
THE FIELD.
THE GREAT ONES ALWAYS HAVE AN
IMPACT AS WELL OFF THE FIELD.
>> THAT IS A GREAT STORY.
THREE BALLS AND A STRIKE.
HAPPY TO REPORT THAT LANGSTON IS
FIT AND DOING FINE THESE DAYS.
>> I REMEMBER GOING TO THE
HOSPITAL THAT NIGHT.
WE WALKED IN THERE AFTER THE
GAME AND SAW ALBERT IN THERE.
WE WERE SHOCKED AND WE HAD A
HUGE SMILE ON OUR FACE TO SEE
THAT ALBERT MADE THE EFFORT TO
GO TO THE HOSPITAL TO SEE MARK
LANGSTON.
>> FULL COUNT TO PUJOLS, 3-2.
SO MUCH OF HIS LARGESE AND
HIS HUMANITARIAN WORK HAS GONE
BELOW THE RADAR, IF NOT
COMPLETELY UNREPORTED.
THAT HUMAN TOUCH JUST A SMALL
EXAMPLE OF WHY ALBERT IS SO
BELOVED.
FULL COUNT, 3-2.
SMITH STRIKES HIM OUT ON A PASS
ALBERT WOULD LOVE TO HAVE BACK.
>> JOE SMITH PLAYED A NUMBER OF
YEARS, SUCCESSFUL YEARS, WITH
PUJOLS.
REALLY GOOD FRIENDS WITH ALBERT
PUJOLS AND MIKE TROUT.
ALWAYS HAD THE LONG
CONVERSATION.
THEY VISIT EACH OTHER WHEN THEY
ARE IN TOWN.
ALBERT WILL NOT WANT TO VISIT
HIM AFTER THAT FASTBALL BECAUSE
IF IT HAD MADE CONTACT IT WOULD
HAVE BEEN OFF HIS BACK LEG.
>> HERE IS IGLESIAS.
THAT WILL BE A PROBLEM.
THAT WILL BE AN OUTFIELD SINGLE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> THAT IS NO GOOD.
-- THAT IS SO GOOD.
>> DOES NOT FEEL GREAT ABOUT IT,
BUT THERE IS A RELATIONSHIP
THERE AS WELL.
ROJAS HAS HAD A NICE NIGHT AS
WELL.
DIAZ IS IN SHORT RIGHT.
A BALL AND NO STRIKES THE COUNT
TO ROJAS.
>> THE AVERAGE EXIT VELOCITY FOR
A MAJOR LEAGUE IT IS ABOUT 88.3
MILES PER HOUR.
I AM GUESSING THERE ARE 12 HITS
TODAY.
THERE MUST BE ABOUT 17 WELL
BELOW THAT.
[LAUGHTER]
>> THE RADAR GUN WILL BE FINE.
THERE HAVE ONLY BEEN SIX BALLS
HIT OVER 98 MILES AN HOUR.
>> THAT LAST HIT BY IGLESIAS WAS
A 60 MILE AN HOUR, 12 FOOT
ROCKET UP THE THIRD-BASE LINE.
A BALL AND TWO STRIKES.
>> THAT IS A PHYSICS CLASS RIGHT
THERE.
>> 2-2.
JOE MADDON HAS SAID AS RECENTLY
AS THIS SPRING TRAINING THAT
WHAT WE CANNOT EXPLAIN WITH MATH
WE MISTAKENLY ATTRIBUTE TO LOCK.
-- TO LUCK.
JOE SMITH IN AND OUT OF TROUBLE
IN THE EIGHTH.
THE BOTTOM OF THE ENDING.
ALL ASTROS IN HOUSTON TONIGHT.
♪
>> I AM ROBIN AND I AM A LOCAL
ARTIST.
WE ARE HERE AT MINUTE MAID PARK
PAINTING A MURAL IN CENTER
FIELD.
>> MY NAME IS ETHAN BRANDON.
>> I AM A STUDENT FROM THE ART
INSTITUTE OF HOUSTON.
I AM HERE AT MINUTE MAID PARK
WORKING ON THE MURAL PROJECT.
>> THIS IS HONESTLY AN AMAZING
OPPORTUNITY FOR ME.
I GET TO WORK WITH PEOPLE WHO DO
GRAPHIC DESIGN AND MURALS AND
PAINTING, AND NOW I AM GETTING
AN IDEA OF HOW TO GET AN IDEA
AND PUT IT IN PHYSICAL FORM.
>> THE CONCEPT IS ORBIT, SLIDING
INTO HOME PLATE.
BASICALLY SAYING WELCOME HOME,
WELCOME BACK TO THE STADIUM.
WELCOME BACK FANS AND PLAYERS.
JUST TO REALLY UNIFY EVERYONE.
>> WELCOME BACK TO THE MLB GAME
OF THE WEEK LIVE ON YOUTUBE,
PRESENTED BY CHAMBER.
THE ASTROS AFTER THOSE STRONG
START BY CRISTIAN JAVIER, A
COUPLE THREE RUN INNINGS, HAVE
NEVER BEEN CHALLENGED TONIGHT.
IN FACT, WE HAVE THE FINALISTS
FOR OUR PLAYER OF THE GAME VOTE.
ALEX BREGMAN, CARLOS CORREA, OR
CRISTIAN JAVIER?
YOU CAN VOTE NOW.
VOTING REMAINS OPEN UNTIL THE
FINAL OUT OF THE GAME.
WE WILL ANNOUNCE THE PLAYER OF
THE GAME ON OUR POSTGAME
COVERAGE TONIGHT, RIGHT AFTER
"PLAY-BY-PLAY."
YORDAN ALVAREZ.
WHO DO YOU GOT?
>> I AM GOING WITH JAVIER.
HE SET THE TONE FOR THEM
TONIGHT.
IF IT WAS NOT HIM, I WOULD GO
WITH MY RIGHT IN OF DUSTY BAKER
-- WITH MY WRITE IN WITH DUSTY
BAKER.
>> DO YOU WANT TO TRY TO
INFLUENCE THE VOTING?
WHO DO YOU GOT?
>> I WISH I COULD.
I AM OBVIOUSLY A HITTER IN MY
PAST, BUT I LOVED WHAT
JAVIER DID.
HE SET THE TONE EARLY BECAUSE IT
WAS A ROUGH ROAD TRIP AND THEY
NEEDED TO SNAP THAT FUNK THEY
WERE IN, AND HE BROUGHT IT
TONIGHT.
>> ONE BALL AND ONE STRIKE, THE
COUNT TO YORDAN ALVAREZ.
HIGH FLY BALL INTO CENTER.
AND THERE IS ONE GONE.
YOUR IS YULI GURRIEL.
I STARTED DOWN THIS -- HERE IS
YULI GURRIEL.
I STARTED DOWN THIS ROAD
EARLIER, WE SAW THAT SHOT OF
CARLOS CORREA ENJOYING A
NATURAL POTASSIUM BREAK
IN THE DUGOUT.
HE IS ROCKING THE SLEEVE ROLLUP
THING, THE CUT OFF.
IF WE CAN SEE IT, HE IS ROLLING
UP THE BOTTOM OF THE SLEEVE AND
CUFFING IT.
A BIT OF THE GUN SHOW GOING ON.
APPROPRIATE PLAYING THE ANGELS,
TIPPING YOUR CAP UNWITTINGLY TO
THE GREAT BRIAN DOWNING, WHO
MASTERED THE CUT OFF SLEEVE TO
SHOW OFF THE GUNS.
NOBODY DID IT BETTER.
>> SUPERMAN.
>> WAS THAT HIS REAL NICKNAME?
>> AS STRONG AS HE WAS, YEAH.
HE STOOD RIGHT ON THE PLATE AND
DARED YOU TO TRY TO GET HIM OUT
INSIDE.
THAT IS ALL PITCHERS REMEMBER.
BRIAN DOWNING GOT ME ONE TIME.
I REMEMBER THAT WELL.
>> BRIAN DOWNING WAS JACKED
BEFORE GUYS WERE JACKED.
>> THOSE WERE SOME GOOD
BALLCLUBS YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT.
I GREW UP IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
WATCHING A LOT OF THOSE ANGELS
TEAMS.
BRIAN DOWNING CAME OUT AND THREW
THE FIRST PITCH AT OUR LITTLE
LEAGUE WHEN I WAS A KID.
>> THAT'S COOL.
WALSH MAKING THE CATCH ON THAT
FLY BALL.
TWO GONE.
>> YOU REMEMBER THAT ONE
HIGHLIGHT PLAY IN LEFT CENTER
FIELD?
THEY HAVE THE BALL GOING TOWARD
THE WALL?
THEY ARE LUCKY THEY WERE ABLE TO
AVOID MAJOR CONTACT WITH
DOWNING.
THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN A REAL
ISSUE GOING FORWARD.
>> THAT WAS A VIOLENT COLLISION
OUT THERE.
>> HERE IS KYLE TUCKER NOW WITH
TWO GONE.
THERE IS THE FAMOUS CATCH
FREDDIE LYNN MADE DURING HIS
ROOKIE OF THE YEAR RUN IN 1975
WHERE HE COLLIDED WITH THE
OUTFIELD FENCE IN FENWAY.
HE MAY HAVE COME OUT IN WORSE
SHAPE IF HE COLLIDED WITH
DOWNING THAN IF YOU HAD COLLIDED
WITH AN ACTUAL FUNDS -- THAN IF
HE HAD COLLIDED WITH AN ACTUAL
FENCE.
[LAUGHTER]
A BALL IN A STRIKE, THE COUNT TO
TUCKER.
RYAN PRESSLY UP IN THE BULLPEN.
UNSCORED UPON TO START THE YEAR.
A LITTLE EXCUSE ME CHECK SWING.
HE WENT AROUND ON THE APPEAL.
A BALL AND TWO STRIKES.
CERTAINLY NOT A SAVE SITUATION
HERE FOR THE ASTROS, BUT PRESLEY
HAS NOT BEEN IN A GAME SINCE
SATURDAY.
AND AN OPPORTUNITY FOR DUSTY TO
GET HIM WORK AT THE START OF THE
SERIES.
THREE MORE BETWEEN THESE TEAMS
HERE IN HOUSTON.
ZACK GREINKE AND ANDREW HEANEY
TOMORROW.
LANCE MCCULLERS, ASTROS FANS
HOPE, WILL TAKE THE BALL SUNDAY
TO WRAP THINGS UP AGAINST DYLAN
BUNDY FOR THE ANGELS.
2-2 PITCH IS SLICED IN THE AIR.
LONG RUN AND A GREAT SLIDING
CATCH BY JOSE -- NO, IS THAT
IGLESIAS?
NO, THAT IS ROJAS WHO CAME OUT
OF THE SHIFT.
A FINE PLAY.
THAT'S, BELIEVE IT OR NOT, IS
JUST THE SECOND 1-2-3 THIS SIDEE
SCORECARD.
LAST CHANCE FOR THE ANGELS WE GO
TO THE NINTH.
>> I AM ROBIN SANDERS AND I AM
HERE AT MINUTE MAID PARK IN
FRONT OF THE RECENTLY COMPLETED
FAN APPRECIATION MURAL IN CENTER
FIELD.
>> WE BUSTED OUR TALES TO GET IT
FINISHED.
THEN TO FINALLY GET TO THE
UNVEILING, IT WAS SURREAL.
AND BEING THERE, NOT JUST AS A
BYSTANDER, BUT A PARTICIPANT OF
THE UNVEIL WITH MEDIA,
EXECUTIVES, THE UNVEILING CAPPED
OFF A GREAT PROJECT.
>> I AM GLAD I GOT TO PARTNER
WITH THE ASTROS, AS WELL AS THE
STUDENTS.
THEY WERE INCREDIBLE.
>> TO THE TOP OF THE NINTH
INNING, LAST CHANCE FOR THE
ANGELS TONIGHT, DOWN BY SIX.
COMING UP ON THE MLB GAME OF THE
WEEK LIVE ON YOUTUBE, NEXT UP,
TWINS AND INDIANS, A DAY GAME
FROM CLEVELAND.
THE BRAVES AND NATS ON THE
SCHEDULE, A GOOD BATTLE FROM THE
N.L. CENTRAL IN MILWAUKEE.
GIANTS AND REDS.
THEY SEEM TO HAVE PLAYED EACH
OTHER A LOT ALREADY THIS YEAR.
IN ACTION AS WE SPEAK.
THE PHILLIES AND MARLINS COMING
AT THE END OF MAY.
ANOTHER AFTERNOON AFFAIR,
THURSDAY, MAY 27.
FREE, EXCLUSIVE GAMES ONLY ON
YOUTUBE ALL YEAR LONG.
IT IS RYAN PRESSLY ON TO PUT THE
FINISHING TOUCHES ON WHAT THE
ASTROS ARE HOPING IS A SERIES
OPENING WIN AGAINST A DIVISION
RIVAL.
ON THE FIRST PITCH TO KURT
SUZUKI, A GROUND BALL OUT.
>> LAST TIME OUT FOR RYAN
PRESSLY IN SEATTLE, HE PICKED UP
HIS FIRST SAVE OF THE YEAR.
HE HAS YET TO GIVE UP AN EARNED
RUN, PITCHING IN SIX INNINGS
THIS SEASON.
HE IS ANOTHER GUY WITH THE HIGH
SPIN FASTBALL, BUT HE HAS TWO
WIPEOUT SECONDARY PITCHES WITH
THE POWER SLATER AND POWER
CURVEBALL -- THE POWER SLIDER
AND POWER CURVEBALL.
>> ONE OUT, BASES EMPTY FOR
DAVID FLETCHER, WHO GOT HIS
FIRST BASE HIT OF THE GAME IN
HIS MOST RECENT AT-BAT.
THE ANGELS HOPEFUL THAT MIKE
TROUT WILL BE OK TO PLAY
TOMORROW, BUT THAT IS CERTAINLY
SOMETHING PEOPLE WILL BE
WATCHING CLOSELY OVERNIGHT AND
TOMORROW MORNING.
I KNOW THAT THE ANGELS BEAT
WRITERS ARE LOOKING FOR
INFORMATION.
ANOTHER KNOCK FOR FLETCHER.
A KNUCKLEBALL SENT OUT TO RIGHT
FIELD.
THAT DID A RIGHT TURN.
A THING OF BEAUTY.
>> IT WAS ALMOST LIKE A KENLEY
JANSEN CUT FASTBALL WE SAW THE
OTHER DAY.
SOME CUT ACTION GOING THE OTHER
WAY.
>> FIFTH PLATE APPEARANCE
TONIGHT FOR SHOHEI OHTANI, WHO
HAS BEEN QUIET THIS EVENING.
0-4 SO FAR.
AND A MORE COMFORTABLE AT-BAT
AGAINST A RIGHT-HANDED PITCHER,
WHERE HIS O.P.S. IS 200 POINTS
HIGHER.
OVER .900 VERSUS RIGHT-HANDED
PITCHING, JUST OVER .700 AGAINST
SOUTHPAWS.
AND DID NOT SWING THE BAT.
A COUPLE OTHER GAMES GOING ON
RIGHT NOW, GUYS, IN THE BIG
SERIES BETWEEN THE DODGERS AND
PADRES.
IT HAS RESUMED.
FIRST OF FOUR BETWEEN THOSE
RIVALS.
SAN DIEGO HAS A 2-0 LEAD IN THE
BOTTOM OF THE SIXTH INNING.
THE ROOKIE THROWING THE BALL
EFFECTIVELY FOR SAN DIEGO
TONIGHT.
>> THERE HAVE BEEN SOME GREAT
GAMES SO FAR.
ALMOST A PLAYOFF ATMOSPHERE
ALREADY.
>> NO LOVE LOST BETWEEN THOSE
TWO TEAMS THIS YEAR.
EACH OF THE THREE GAMES IN SAN
DIEGO LAST WEEKEND WAS CHIPPY.
3-0 FASTBALL IS IN FOR A STRIKE.
>> THOSE GAMES WERE VERY
ENJOYABLE TO WATCH.
I AM STILL AMAZED AT HOW GOOD
DODGER PITCHING IS.
SOME OF THE GUYS THEY HAVE ON
THEIR STARTING ROTATION
ABSOLUTELY AMAZE ME.
I AM NOT SURE HOW GUYS GET HITS
OFF OF THEM.
>> THAT DEPTH IS GOING TO ALLOW
THEM TO DO EXACTLY WHAT THEY
STATED THEIR GOAL IS.
THEY ARE GOING TO START, TO
BORROW THE NBA TERM, THEY ARE
GOING TO START THE LOAD
MANAGEMENT PHASE OF THE SEASON
IN JUNE WHERE THEY WILL GO TO A
SIX-MAN ROTATION,.
OHTANI STRIKES OUT.
HE WAS IN FRONT OF THE COUNTS,
THEN TOOK TWO BIG CUTS AND AN
UPPER 90'S GASH TO COME UP
EMPTY.
>> HE LIKED. HIGH FASTBALL TO
THE LEFT-HANDED BATTER.
HE COULD NOT CATCH THAT ONE.
UPSTAIRS AT 96.
HE GETS IT BY HIM.
LAST CHANCE FOR THE ANGELS.
HE HAS STRUCK OUT AND GROUNDED
OUT SINCE COMING OUT OF THE
BALLGAME AND REPLACING MIKE
TROUT, WHO EARLIER WAS HIT BY A
PITCH IN THE ELBOW.
A BALL THAT MERCIFULLY HIT HIM
IN THE PAD, BUT STILL, MIKE WAS
REMOVED WITH AN ELBOW CONTUSION
TONIGHT.
HOUSTON A STRIKE AWAY FROM A
SERIES OPENING VICTORY AT HOME.
MAYBE IT IS THE HOME COOKING.
THEY WENT 6-7 TO OPEN THE
SEASON, RAN ROUGHSHOD OVER THE
OAKLAND A'S.
BOTH TEAMS HAVE CHANGED A LITTLE
BIT AND THE ASTROS ARE HOPEFUL
THEY ARE BACK ON TRACK TONIGHT.
>> IT HAS GOT TO FEEL GOOD TO
GET BACK HOME IN FRONT OF THEIR
HOME FANS, HERE THE CHEERING --
HEAR THE CHEERING, AND PUT UP A
BIG NUMBER.
>> THAT WILL DO IT WITH AN
EXCLAMATION POINT AND A 95 MILE
AN HOUR FASTBALL.
RYAN PRESSLY REMAINS PERFECT TO
START THE YEAR.
AND THE ASTROS POST AN 8-2
VICTORY AT HOME.
CONGRATULATIONS TO DUSTY BAKER.
WE TALKED ABOUT HOW HE WAS ON
THE DOORSTEP OF THE 1900 CLUB.
HE ENTERS ACCESS TONIGHT.
14TH ON THE ALL-TIME WINS LIST
WITH HIS 1900 MANAGERIAL WIN
TONIGHT.
8-2 THE FINAL.
THE MLB YOUTUBE GAME OF THE WEEK
POSTGAME SHOW PRESENTED BY TIME
STARTS RIGHT NOW -- PRESENTED BY
CHIME STARTS RIGHT NOW.
♪
THE ASTROS WITH AN 8-2 VICTORY
TONIGHT.
THEY TAKE THE SERIES OPENER.
TIMELY OFFENSIVE PERFORMANCES,
MULTIPLE HIT NIGHTS FOR GUYS
LIKE CARLOS CORREA, ALEX
BREGMAN, NAME BRANDS CASHING IN
TONIGHT.
AND CRISTIAN JAVIER WITH AN
OUTSTANDING NIGHT ON THE MOUND.
THE LOAN ANGELS HIGHLIGHT WAS
THE HOME RUN BY ALBERT PUJOLS.
ONE THAT JUST SCRAPED THE FAIR
POLE IN RIGHT FIELD, HIS FIRST
OPPOSITE FIELD HOMER IN THE
BETTER PART OF TWO YEARS.
AND A LIMITED CAPACITY CROWD
THAT CAME TO WATCH THIS SERIES
OPENER FOR THE MOST PART IS
EXITING THE BUILDING HAPPY WITH
AN 8-2 WIN FOR THE HOME SIDE.
WE ARE AWAITING A CONVERSATION
WITH OUR CHIME PLAYER OF THE
GAME TONIGHT.
WE WILL REVEAL WHO THAT IS.
YOU HAD A VOTE IN THIS WATCHING
OUT HOME.
BETWEEN CARLOS CORREA, ALEX
BREGMAN, AND CRISTIAN JAVIER, WE
WILL REVEAL THE WINNER OF OUR
PLAYER OF THE GAME HONORS AND
HAVE A CONVERSATION WITH THAT
ASTRO COMING UP SHORTLY.
I THINK WE HAVE GOT THE WINNER
IN PLACE.
HE IS CRISTIAN JAVIER.
A CAREER STRIKEOUT HIGH, A
CAREER PITCH COUNT HIGH, AND A
DOMINANT NIGHT ON THE MOUND IN
HIS FIRST START IN TWO WEEKS.
>> I THOUGHT HIS STUFF WAS OFF
THE CHARTS.
HE HAD THE FOUR-SEAM FASTBALL
GOING.
HIS SLIDER WAS THE DIFFERENCE
MAKER.
HE FINISHED OFF WITH A SLIDER.
NINE STRIKEOUTS AND IT IN --
NINE STRIKEOUTS IN FIVE INNINGS.
HE WAS RIGHT ON THE MONEY OR HOW
WELL HE THREW TONIGHT.
>> CRISTIAN JAVIER IS OUR PLAYER
OF THE GAME.
TAKING DOWN THE VOTE BY 45% TO
33% MARGIN OVER ALEX BREGMAN.
IT IS WAY TOO EARLY TO JUMP TO
ANY CONCLUSIONS ABOUT WHO IS
TRULY HOT, WHO IS TRULY NOT.
NOT UNTIL THE 40 GAME MARK DO A
LOT OF US THINK YOU CAN REALLY
GET A SENSE FOR WHAT YOU HAVE ON
THE FIELD.
BUT BASED ON THE START THE
ASTROS HAD, WINNING SIX OUT OF
SEVEN, BASED ON HOW GOOD THEY
LOOK TONIGHT, WE EXPECT THEM TO
BE IN THE FIGHT ALL YEAR LONG.
>> AND THEY SHOULD BE, AND THEY
HAVE THE PEDIGREE TO DO IT.
WE TALKED ABOUT IT IN THE OPEN
HOW THEY HAVE BEEN TO THE
POSTSEASON.
THESE GUYS UNDERSTAND HOW THE
SEASON WORKS.
IT WILL BE A LONGER SEASON THIS
YEAR.
I THINK YOU WILL SEE LESS PANIC
OUT OF THESE GUYS.
WHEN YOU START OFF A SEASON IN
APRIL, YOU WANT TO GET OFF TO A
GREAT START.
THEY HAD THAT FOR A WEEK WHEN
THEY WENT THROUGH THE OAKLAND
A'S.
THEY FALTERED WHEN AJAY HENCH
AND THE TIGERS CAME THROUGH.
A COUPLE OF GUYS REALIZED THEY
MIGHT BE IN A TOUGH SPOT, BUT
THESE GUYS HAVE REBOUNDED.
THEY ARE WAITING TO GET ALTUVE
BACK.
THINGS CAN TREND IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION, BUT CONSIDERING THE
WAY THINGS HAVE BEEN FOR THE
LAST 10 DAYS, THIS WAS A GOOD
WELCOME HOME.
>> FOR THE ANGELS ON THE OTHER
SIDE OF THIS THING, YOU GO A
LONG WAY TO BEATING THE ANGELS
WHEN YOU KEEP SHOHEI OHTANI AND
MIKE TROUT QUIET, AND THAT IS
WHAT THEY DID TONIGHT.
>> WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE POWER
THREATS, YOU HAVE OHTANI, TROUT,
AND JARED WALSH.
FOR THE MOST PART, JAVIER AND
THE BULLPEN DID A GREAT JOB
NEUTRALIZING THAT, ESPECIALLY
WITH THE BREAKING BALL
THROUGHOUT THE GAME.
DAVID FLETCHER WAS NOT ABLE TO
GET ON BASE AS MUCH AS WE ARE
USED TO SEEING.
LOOKING AT HIS DIVISION, IT IS A
COMPETITIVE DIVISION.
A LOT OF PEOPLE SAY THIS WILL BE
A WEAKER DIVISION, BUT THE
OAKLAND GROVE -- THE OAKLAND A'S
HAVE BEEN GOOD, SEATTLE HAS BEEN
REALLY GOOD.
THE ASTROS YOU KNOW AT SOME
POINT WILL START TO PLAY REALLY
GOOD BASEBALL, AND THIS IS GOING
TO BE A FANTASTIC RACE TO THE
END.
>> WHEN YOU GO BACK AND
SCRUTINIZE THE START OF ALEX
COBB TONIGHT, HE WAS CLOSE.
LIKE JAVIER WHO PITCHED AT THE
ALTERNATE TRAINING SITE, IT HAD
BEEN A WHILE FOR ALEX COBB SINCE
HE WAS LAST ON A BIG-LEAGUE
MOUND.
10 DAYS, HAD A START SKIPPED.
I THINK HE WAS GOOD AND I THINK
THE DIFFERENCE FOR HIM TONIGHT
-- I SOUND LIKE A GUY
BELLYACHING -- BUT THE ONE
PITCH, TWO OUTS IN THE THIRD,
THE 11 PITCH TO MALDONADO -- THE
1-1 PITCH TO MALDONADO
WAS CALLED A STRIKE.
COBB WAS OUT OF THE GAME BEFORE
THE THIRD.
IT IS A MATTER OF HOW ONE PITCH
CAN BETRAY YOUR NIGHT.
I
OF IT A COUPLE OF TIMES TONIGHT
BUT COULDN'T GET OUT OF THAT
FINAL JAM.
MARK: I STILL GO BACK TO WHAT HE
-- WE TALKED ABOUT IN THE VERY
FWING.
WHEN YOU'RE A SINKER BALL
PITCHER AND YOU'RE TOO STRONG,
YOU'RE GOING TO OVERTHROW SOME
PITCHES.
HIS KNUCKLE CURVE WAS REALLY,
REALLY GOOD BUT HIS LATERAL
CURVEBALL HAD MORE SINKINGING
MOVEMENT.
I WOULD BE CURIOUS TO SEE WHAT
HE SAID AFTER THE GAME.
THAT HE WAS TOO STRONG AND MAYBE
OVERTHREW SOME PETCHES.
MATT: WE HAVE OUR PLAYER OF THE
GAME WITH US WITH THE HELP OF A
TRANSLATOR AND CONGRATULATIONS
TO CRISTIAN JAVIER.
A TERRIFIC NIGHT.
THANKS FOR JOINING US.
TELL US HOW YOU FELT TONIGHT AND
WHAT YOU FELT WAS WORKING THE
BEST FOR YOU THIS EVENING?
[SPEAKING IN SPANISH]
>> THANK TO GOD FOR ALL THE
SUCCESS TONIGHT.
I FELT GOOD.
I THREW QUALITY STRIKES OVER THE
PLATE AND I FELT COMFORTABLE
TONIGHT AND SUCCESS IS TO GOD.
THANK YOU.
MARK: HOW WAS IT -- WHEN YOU GO
INTO A GAME PREPARING FOR SHOHEI
OHTANI, MIKE TROUT AND PUJOLS IN
THE LINEUP.
WHO WERE YOU ABLE TO STAY SO
FOCUSED TO BE ABLE TO THROW ALL
YOUR PITCHES IN THE STRIKE ZONE,
LIKE YOU SAID.
[TRANSLATING]
[SPEAKING IN SPANISH]
>> FOR ME IT WAS JUST ABOUT
STAYING FOCUSED, GETTING THE
FIRST PITCH OVER THE ZONE FOR A
STRIKE.
IF I CAN COMMAND THE ZONE EARLY
IN THE COUNT AND GET AHEAD THEN
THE REST OF THE AT-BAT IS IN MY
FAVOR.
GEOFF: GREAT GAME TODAY.
TELL ME WHAT IT LOOKED LIKE TO
GO AND WATCH THE ASTROS PUT UP
RUNS WHILE YOU WERE PITCHING SO
GOOD.
[TRANSLATING]
>> SUPER HAPPY WITH THE HITTERS.
IT'S A LOT LESS PRESSURE WHEN
THE OFFENSE COMES THROUGH.
I FEEL A LITTLE BIT MORE RELAXED
AND CAN ATTACK THE ZONE A LITTLE
BIT MORE.
MATT: PLEASE RELATE TO
CRMBINGSRMBINGS I SMBINGSTMBINGS
I AMBINGSNMBINGS THAT IT WAS A
PLEASURE WATCHING HIM PITCH.
WHAT THE YOUR NAME?
I FEEL WE SHOULD KNOW YOUR NAME
AS WELL.
>> MY NAME IS DERRICK.
MATT: THANK YOU FOR THE
TRANSLATION AND CRMBINGSRMBINGS
I SMBINGSTMBINGS I
AMBINGSNMBINGS, CONGRATULATIONS.
THAT WAS GREAT, AWESOME.
A PLAYER OF THE GAME.
HE WAS THE BULL TONIGHT.
98 PITCHES, NINE PUNCHOUTS.
BOTH ARE CAREER HIGHS.
ALL NINE OF THEM SWINGING.
GOING TO TAKE A BREAK AND WE'LL
HAVE MORE POSTGAME COVERAGE WHEN
WE COME BACK RIGHT AFTER THIS.
>> HE JUST SMOKES IT.
>> FORGET ABOUT IT.
>> OH, MY GODNESS.
GREAT BASEBALL RIGHT THERE.
>> AND THAT ONE IS GOING TO GO!
>> THAT BALL WAS CRUSHINGED.
>> AND THIS IS GOING TO DO IT!
>> STRIKE THREE.
>> THAT WAS A GREAT PLAY.
>> I TALKED ABOUT HIS FIELDING
SKILLS.
THAT WAS REMARKABLE.
♪
>> SOMETHING LIKE THIS WAS WHAT
THEY CAME FOR.
MATT: WELCOME BACK TO OUR GAME
OF THE WEEK POSTGAME COVERAGE,
PRESENTED BY CHIME.
AN 8-2 WIN FOR THE ASTROS,
TAKING GAME ONE OF THIS
FOUR-GAME SET WITH DIVISION
RIVAL THE LOS ANGELES ANGELS AND
IF YOU MISSED ANY OF THE
PLAY-BY-PLAY COVERAGE, HERE'S
HOW IT WENT DOWN.
JAVIER WAS DOWN AT THE ALTERNATE
SITE.
THIS IS HIS FIRST BIG LEAGUE
START IN A COUPLE OF WEEKS BUT
THAT WAS ALL BY DESIGN.
DAVID FLETCHER, SHOHEI OHTANI
AND MIKE TROUT FOR THE VISITING
ANGELS.
A STRIKEOUT FOR JAVIER.
TWO STRIKEOUTS STARTING THE GAME
FOR CRISTIAN JAVIER.
MARK: PRETTY NASTY CHANGEUP.
I'M CURIOUS TO SEE THIS MATCHUP
BETWEEN JAVIER, WHO HAS THAT
GOOD FASTBALL IN THE UPPER
PORTION OF THE ZONE.
WALSH HAS A REPUTATION FOR
HITTING THE HIGH FASTBALL AND
DRIVING IT.
MATT: JUST LIKE THAT, THREE
TROUTS TO.
.
-- STRIKEOUTS.
NOTHING COMES OF THE TWO-OUT
WALK.
CRISTIAN JAVIER, MIX IN A
GROUNDOUT, DUDE!
ALL SIX VIA THE SWINGING
STRIKEOUT AND HERE'S MILES STRAW
NOW.
SHARPLY HIT PAST THE THIRD
BASEMAN ROJAS INTO THE CORNER.
THAT'S GOING TO GET DIAZ AROUND
TO SCORE.
KYLE STRAW DRIVING IN THE FIRST
RUN OF THE NIGHT AND IT'S 1-0
ASTROS.
A BALL INTO THE SHORT LEFT FIELD
CORNER THEN HE TURNS INTO A
TRIPLE.
TWO BALLS AND TWO STRIKES TO
CORREA.
AND A GROUND BALL THAT TRICKLES
THROUGH THE INFIELD AND SCORES
EASILY.
THAT'S A TWO-STRIKE COUNT THAT
JUST GOT AWAY FROM COBB.
BIG PLATE APPEARANCE FOR EULI
GURRIEL.
BASES LOADED.
THE 3-2 PITCH AND HE JUST MISSED
WITH THE SPLIT JAM.
DIDN'T MISS BY MUCH.
AN R.B.I. FOR GURRIEL, HIS
TEAM-LEADING NINTH.
3-0 ASTROS.
KYLE, A STRIKEOUT VICTIM TO END
THE FIRST AND THAT'S LINED INTO
SHALLOW RIGHT, WHERE FLETCHER
HAD IT PLAYED PERFECTLY TO AVOID
ANY FURTHER DAMAGE.
MARK: MAN, HE GOT HIT IN THE
ELBOW AND I DON'T KNOW THAT THAT
GOD -- GOT -- THERE'S NO PAD
THERE, I DON'T THINK.
GEOFF: HE HAS A LITTLE BIT OF
PROTECTION AROUND THE TRY
ACCEPT.
THAT LOOKED LIKE IT HIT HIM ON
THE ELBOW.
>> I CAN'T PICK UP A BALL.
MATT: MIKE TROUT HAS COME OUT OF
THE BALLGAME AFTER BEING HIT IN
THE ELBOW A COUPLE OF INNINGS
AGO.
SCOTT SHE BEENLER HAS TAKEN OVER
IN CENTER FIELD FOR HIM.
BREGMAN, HE'S BEEN ON BOARD IN
ALL OF HIS THREE PLATE
APPEARANCES.
ADD ANOTHER BASE HIT.
MAN, HE AND CRI CRAY -- CORREA
ARE GOING NUTS AT THE TOP OF
THIS ORDER.
CARLOS IS GOING TO SCORE AND THE
ASTROS ARE ON THE BOARD AGAIN.
PUJOLS TO RIGHT FIELD.
THAT'S GOT A CHANCE IF IT STAYS
FAIR AND THAT ONE'S GONE!
ALBERT PUJOLS TO THE OPPOSITE
FIELD TO GET THE ANGELS ON THE
BOARD IN THE SEXT.
MARK: WAIT A MINUTE, ALL
BOUNDARY VIEWS ARE -- CALLS ARE
REVIEWABLE.
MATT: YEAH, HE KNOWS IT.
THIS IS WHERE THE FINAL SCORE
WOULD STAND, 8-THE.
-- 8-2.
TOP OF THE NINTH.
HE HAS NOT ALLOWED A RUN THIS
YEAR AND LOOKING TO BE IN
2008ISH FORM.
SO HERE ARE THE FINAL TERMS --
NUMBERS.
8- VICTORY FOR THE ASTROS.
BIG NOTE FOR THE ANGELS IS MIKE
TROUT LEFT THE GAME IN THE
FOURTH AFTER BEING HIT IN THE
ELBOW.
IS -- THE WORD OUT OF THE
ANGELS' CLUBHOUSE WAS AN ELBOW
CONTUSION.
HIS STATUS WILL BE EVALUATED FOR
THE REST OF THE SERIES.
MATT VASGERSIAN WITH MARK AND
GEOFF.
WE TALKED ABOUT SOME OF THE EXIT
VEALOS HERE.
NOT EVERYTHING --
VMBINGSEMBINGSLMBINGSOMBINGSSMBI
NGS HERE.
NOT EVERYTHING WAS HIT ON THE
SCREWS, AS IT WERE.
>> NO, THEY PUT THE BALL IN
PLAY.
NOT A LOT OF STRIKEOUTS FOR
THEM.
CONTACT, SOMETIMES HARD CONTACT.
TO THEIR CREDIT, THEY USED HIGH
CONTACT TO SCORE EIGHT RUNS, THE
MOST SINCE APRIL 4.
SO PRETTY IMPRESSIVE WHAT THEY
DID WITH CARLOS CORREA AT THE
TOP OF THE ORDER.
DUSTY BAKER ZOILEDED TO PUT HIM
THERE FOR THE FIRST TIME IN HIS
CAREER AND IT PAID OFF.
MATT: THEY MIGHT HAVE A HARD
TIME GETTING CORREA OUT OF THAT
PLAYOFF SPOT.
HE SEEMED TO LIKE IT.
THE FINAL RESULT THEME SEEMED TO
LIKE IT.
MAYBE THAT'S YOUR LEADOFF HITTER
UNTIL ALTUVE IS BACK IN THE
MICK.
GEOFF: THEY DEFINITELY NEEDED A
SHAKE-UP AND DUSTY BACKER WANTED
THAT 1,900TH WIN.
IN THE PAST CORREA HAS BEEN A
FOUR, FIVE, SIX-HOLE TYPE HITTER
WHERE HE GETS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
DRIVE IN RUNS.
DRIVES THE BALL OUT OF THE
BALLPARK, HAS SOME KEY MOMENT
BUT YOU WANT GUYS AT THE TOP OF
YOUR LAST TIME TO GET THE MOST
AT-BATS AND CORREA HAS BEEN
SWINGING THE BAT VERY WELL.
HE HAS A KEEN EYE AND ALSO HAS
THE OPPORTUNITIES TO PUT YOUR
TEAM UP EARLY WITH HIS POWER,
VERY SIMILAR TO GEORGE SPRINGER
WHO LEFT TO GO TO TORONTO.
MATT: ONE OF THE THINGS WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT WITH DUSTY BAKER
BEFORE THE GAME.
WHO'S GOING TO LOAD OFF?
THEY FOUND HIM AND THAT LAST
TIME CONSTRUCTION WORKED OUT
REALLY WELL TONIGHT FOR THE
ASTROS.
BRETT: IT CERTAINLY DID AND EVEN
THOUGH CRISTIAN JAVIER WAS OUR
PLAYER OF THE GAME.
WE STARTED THIS BROADCAST
TALKING ABOUT HOW THE ASTROS
NEEDED A WIN, SOME OFFENSE AND
THEY GOT BOTH TODAY.
THEY GOT EIGHT RUNS, AND 2/3 OF
THE LINEUP WAS ON BASE AT LEAST
MULTIPLE TIMES.
ALEX BREGMAN HAD THE THREE HIT,
CERTAINLY A BRIGHT SIDE AS WELL
AND A TEAM WAITING TO GET JOSE
ALTUVE BACK HEALTHY, HOPEFULLY
PRODUCTIVE.
GERMAN IS ANOTHER GUY THEY HOPE
TO BUILD ON.
OAKLAND HAS WON 11 STRAIGHT.
THEY MAY COME BACK TO EARTH.
WHAT'S THE STAYING POWER FOR THE
MARINERS?
THE ASTROS WOULD LIKE TO GET
ALTUVE BACK.
THIS COULD BE A WILD AMERICAN
LEAGUE WEST GAME THE REST OF THE
YEAR.
LANCE BERKMAN PLAYED IN THE
FIELD BEHIND ME.
HE ALWAYS SAMENTE A TEAM WAS
ONLY AS GOOD -- GOOD AS IT LAST
AT U  WIN FOR THE STROTES
AND WE'RE BACK WITH MORE ON OUR
POSTGAME COVERAGE PRESENTED BY
CHIME, COMING UP NEXT.
YKS --
>> HE CONTINUES TO BE THE MOST
UNDERRATED PLAYER ON OUR ROSTER.
>> RUNNER GOES AND IT'S A BALL.
THROW DOWN TO THIRD.
OUT AT THIRD BASE!
>> WHAT HE'S BEEN ABLE TO DO AND
HOW HE'S HELPED OUR YOUNG
PITCHING STAFF THROUGH THE
SEASON.
HE'S THE ROCK OF THIS TEAM AND
HIS WILL TO WIN, THE GRIT HE HAS
IS SOMETHING THAT I ADMIRE A
LOT.
>> MALDONADO DRIVES IT TO DEEP
LEFT CENTER FIELD.
HOME RUN.
>> BIG MOMENT FOR THE ASTROS.
KYLE TUCKER.
>> TUCKER HITS IT HIGH IN THE
AIR TO RIGHT FIELD.
MOORE LOOKING UP, SEE YOU LATER!
SEE YOU LATER!
KYLE TUCK WE ARE A WALK-OFF HOME
RUN IN THE BOTTOM OF THE NINTH!
AND THE ASTROS BEAT THE MARINERS
3-2.
MATT: WELCOME BACK TO THE MLB
GAME OF THE WEEK LIVE ON
YOUTUBE.
OUR POSTGAME COVERAGE IS
PRESENTED BY CHIME.
8-2 ASTROS IN THIS SERIES OPENER
TONIGHT.
THREE MORE TO COME AGAINST THESE
TWO TEAMS STARTING TOMORROW.
AND THE HOPE FOR ANGELS FANS IS
THAT MIKE TROUT, AFTER BEING HIT
BY A PITCH IN THE ELBOW TONIGHT
IS OK TO CONTINUE.
MIKE WORE A MIKE FOR US AND HERE
IS MIKE ON THE MIKE.
>> AMBINGSAMBINGS II!
>> I HONESTLY THOUGHT IT WAS A
SLIDER BUT I DIDN'T SEE IT.
>> THAT'S WHAT I TOLD DIAZ.
BECAUSE YOU MOVED YOUR ELBOW
DOWN LIKE IT WAS A SLIDER.
YOU GOD, THOUGH?
>> YEAH, I'M FINE.
>> I LOVE TO SEE YOU HIT.
I SAW YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT THE
NEW MAT.
PROBABLY TONIGHT.
>> YOU OK?
>> YEAH, I GOT CAUGHT ON A
SLIDER, DUDE.
>> REALLY?
>> YEAH, I CAN'T PICK OFF BALL.
>> I HAVE WAITING FOR IT TO
BREAK.
IF I HAD A PAD,
BMBINGSRMBINGSOMBINGS -- MATT:
MIKE TROUT COULD WOULD COME OUT
OF THE GAME SHORTLY THEREAFTER.
WE TALKED ABOUT THIS DURING PLAY
BY PLAY, THE FACT HE'S HITTING
ONLY.21  HERE.
THE LOWEST OF ANY MAJOR LEAGUE
STADIUM HERE IN HOUSTON.
MARK: ANY OTHER BALLPARK,
ESPECIALLY IN THE A.L. WEST,
INCREDIBLE NUMBERS BUT AT MINUTE
MAID PARK HE HAS A TOUGH TIME
SEEING THE BASEBALL.
I JUST HEARD JOE MADDON SAY HE
EXPECTS MIKE STRIKEOUT TO BE
BACK IN THE LINEUP TOMORROW.
THAT'S GOOD NEWS.
BUT JUST DOESN'T SEE THE BALL
WELL.
WASN'T ABLE TO DETERMINE IF IT
WAS A SLIDER OR FASTBALL.
HOPEFULLY MIKE TROUT WILL GET UP
THERE WITH BETTER SWINGS AND SEE
THE BALL BETTER DOWN THERE IN
HOUSTON.
GEOFF: I AGREE.
SORRY TO JUMP.
IN FIRST OF ALL, I AGREE.
EVERYBODY WANTS TO SEE MIKE
TROUT OUT THERE SWINGING THE BAT
AND PUTTING UP BIG NUMBERS BUT
HERE AT MINUTE MAID PARK IT'S
INTERESTED TO HAVE HIM MIKED UP
AND AS OPEN AS HE WAS, HIS
INABILITY TO SEE THE BALL HERE.
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT THE L. EMPLET
D. LIGHTING AND I'VE HAD SEVERAL
CONVERSATIONS WITH JEFF BAGWELL
WHERE GUYS WOULD COME IN AND
HAVE TO ADJUST TO THE LIGHTING.
IT'S UNIQUE THAT THIS IS ONE OF
THE BALLPARKS THAT GIVES HIM
TROUBLE.
MAYBE IT'S THE 10TH MAN FOR THE
HOUSTON ASTROS BECAUSE THAT
SEEMS TO BE THE ONLY KRYPTONITE
THIS GUY HAS.
MATT: WATCH HAPPENS.
-- WHAT HAPPENS.
HE'LL COME OUT TOMORROW AND HIT
THREE DINGERS.
WE'VE SEEN THAT MOVIE BEFORE.
YOU KNOW WHAT ELSE WE SAW
TONIGHT?
YEAH, IT'S LIMITED FAN
PARTICIPATION BUT OUR FAN OF THE
NIGHT.
FOUL BALL, SLICING OUT AND CHECK
THIS DUDE OUT.
EPIC FALL.
AND HE LIVED TO TELL ABOUT IT.
HE WAS ALL SMILES AFTERWARDS.
THANKS FOR BEING A GOOD SPORTS.
SIR.
AND ELSEWHERE ON THE FALLING
/FAMED DOCKET.
MONDAY IN PHILADELPHIA.
BRAND BELT GETS AHOLD OF ONE AND
IT RATTLES AROUND.
LOOK AT THIS.
HEY!
MARK: OH, GOOD LORD.
MATT: LIKE HE WAS WEARING
SKATES, ICE SKATES, LIKE
THREE-TIME STANLEY CUP CHAMPION
KEN DANEYKO.
RIGHT HERE IN NEW JERSEY.
MARK: HE GONE.
DOWN GOES FRAZIER.
MATT: KEN GOT A LITTLE TOO
COMFORTABLE.
[LAUGHTER]
GEOFF: STRAIGHT FARE.
MATT: GOOD THING I DON'T HAVE TO
WORK ON THE HOCKEY SIDE.
I DON'T KNOW IF KENNY IS HAPPY
WITH US FOR THAT.
THAT'S MR. DEVIL.
MARK: I KNOW.
HE MIXED IT UP A LITTLE BIT.
WE'RE PRETTY FAR AWAY SO WE CAN
LAUGH AT THAT.
GEOFF: THANK GOODNESS FOR SOCIAL
DISTANCING.
MATT: YES, AND THANK GOODNESS
FOR SOCIAL MEDIA BECAUSE NOW
THOSE CLIPS WILL LAST FOREVER.
THE REST OF THIS PACKAGE, THE
MLB GAME OF THE WEEK LIVE ON
YOUTUBE.
THESE ARE EXCLUSIVE GAMES YOU
CAN'T SEE ANYWHERE ELSE AND THE
NEXT ONE WEDNESDAY, THE 28TH.
DAY GAME BETWEEN THE TWINS AND
INDIANS AT PROGRESSIVE FIELD.
I SEE THE REST OF THE GAMES, AND
THE PHILLIES AND MARLINS COMING
UP THURSDAY, MAY 27.
THE TWINS AND INDIANS IS AN
INTERESTING MATCHUP BECAUSE
THERE WERE A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT
FELT LIKE IT WAS THE TWINS' AND
WHY'D WHITE SOX' DIVISION TO
LOSE.
CLEVELAND IS WITHOUT CARRASCO
AND LINDOR BUT IT'S A PITCHING
FACTORY THERE AND ANY STAFF THAT
STILL HAS SHANE BIEBER ON IT FOR
ME HAS A PUNCHER'S CHANCE.
I THINK THEY THINK THAT THEY'RE
EVERY BIT THE COMPETITOR IN THAT
DIVISION ALONG WITH THE WHITE
SOX AND TWINS.
MARK: YES, THEY HAVE SOME GREAT
PITCHING.
THEY DON'T HAVE A REALLY DEEP
LINEUP.
BUT THEIR YOUNG PITCHING STAFF
IS SO GOD.
BYRON BUXTON, BY THE WAY, FOR
THE TWINS, ONE OF THE BEST
PLAYERS IN THE GAME.
YOU'LL SEE HIM BACK OUT THERE.
HE WAS NOT AVAILABLE FOR THE
ANGELS SERIES BUT HE DOES
INCREDIBLE STUFF IN THE
OUTFIELD.
GREAT THROWING ARM AND ELITE
SPEED.
WE TALKED ABOUT OHTANI.
BUXTON HAS THAT ELITE SPEED AS
WELL.
GEOFF: I COULDN'T AGREE MORE.
BUXTON WAS A SWING AND MISS GUY
EARLY BUT IT'S BEEN GREAT TO
WATCH HIM MAKE THE ADJUSTMENT.
ALWAYS BEEN A GOLD GLOVE CENTER
FIELDER PER ME SO IT'S GOING TO
BE FUN TO WATCH THAT DIVISION
MATCHUP A LITTLE BIT.
GREAT PITCHING FOR CLEVELAND AND
NELSON CRUZ OUT THERE DROPPING
BOMBS STILL.
MATT: THE MINNESOTA TWINS LOOK
ING UP AT THE REST OF THE
DIVISION, ODDLY.
OFF TO A WONKY 6-10 START.
KANSAS CITY THE TEAM TO BEAT
RIGHT NOW IN THAT DIVISION.
GUYS, IN WAS A LOT OF FUN
TONIGHT.
THANKS FOR DOING THIS.
I HAD A BLAST WORKING WITH YOU
GUYS.
BEEN A LONG TIME.
WE ALL KNOW EACH OTHER AND
FINALLY GOT TO DO A GAME
TOGETHER.
IT WAS FUN, NARNINGSE A LOT.
GEOFF: IT WAS A BLAST HANGING
WITH YOU GUYS.
MARK: AND I FINALLY GOT ON THE
FIELD FOR THE FIRST TIME IN TWO
YEARS.
MATT: YOU WANT TO RIP THE
HEADSET OFF AND RUN THE BASES?
MARK: NO, THEY WON'T LET ME DO
THAT RIGHT NOW BECAUSE I HAVE TO
SHOW ALL MY ATHLETIC SKILL.
GEOFF: GREAT HAVING ME ON.
CAN'T WAIT TO SEE YOU GUYS.
MATT: THANKS TO BRETT DOLAN AS
WELL FOR HIS CONTRIBUTIONS
TONIGHT.
GOOD TIMES, EVERYBODY.
TO WRAP, THE ASTROS TAKE GAME
ONE OF THE SERIES 8-2.
THE NEXT GAME OF THE WEEK LIVE
ON YOUTUBE PRESENTED BY CHIME.
WEDNESDAY, APRIL 28.
TWINS AND INDIANS FROM
CLEVELAND.
FOR MARK, GEOFF, AND BRETT
DOLAN, MATT HAMMEL SAYING SO
LONG.
THANKS FOR WATCHING.